most people most Champions do not have
something that you do not have they lack
something that you have for a champion
in the Physical Realm a lot of times
it's they don't have an off switch they
just keep going and so to the same
degree you probably do things every
single day that you should not be doing
and so what I want to introduce to you
is a concept of the anti-routine as the
most productive routine that is humanly
possible for you to accomplish what you
want number one is obviously just
shifting the perspective of I need to do
more things and I need to add more
things to my routine when in fact you
need to stop doing things that you're
currently doing all that remains is the
work to be done priorities mean two
things cannot be equally important when
you work on something if I spend 30
minutes on both things and I say this
one's more important than this one I can
say that but that's not reality because
I basically just said they were both
important which means neither of them
are which is why most people cannot get
done because they cannot say no you need
to have a routine of saying no an
anti-routine and that is the thing
that's going to yield those outsides
Returns on productivity you can't do two
things with different levels of
importance it's either important or it's
not important so if you say this is the
priority then it means you do not do
other things besides that thing that is
how it is a priority that is how you
literally prioritize hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I quit I'm
a business partner I struggle to keep
going I was making 300 bucks a month and
felt like a complete failure and the
thing that saved me that pulled me up
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs I got the motivation from
them I also got the strategies of what
to do next so that I can go off and
achieve my dreams and quite honestly I
still need the stories today myself to
continue my motivation to take it to the
next level so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Alex harmosi
when I started out in business I've
heard I heard all these things in the
personal development space like ah you
should have you should read these
affirmations every morning blah blah
blah blah I never did that and it was
because it felt stupid to me now that
being said there might be some people
who've had life-changing results from
doing that but what I did notice is that
the stories I would tell myself about
myself were the things that changed my
beliefs they were the things that
changed my character and so a lot of
times in some of my other videos I've
talked about how entrepreneurship is
about three things it's about changing
the beliefs that you have it's about
increasing the skill set that you have
and then the character traits that go
along with that to make sure the skills
are successful so I'll give you a simple
example for this so a friend of mine he
started a fitness app it was doing about
twenty thousand dollars a month he was a
top game CrossFit games competitor but
he was really ashamed because he wasn't
the winner he was like you know really
really highly ranked one but he wasn't
the winner and so he believed that his
app wasn't good enough and so he never
promoted it so it grew to twenty
thousand dollars a month in Revenue with
him doing zero promotion right and
when he realized that it was okay for
him to promote it and people got a lot
of value from it and the app was good
enough he went from twenty thousand
dollars a month to like 150 000 a month
like that and the difference was his
beliefs his skills were the same right
his character traits are the same he
changed his beliefs right so let me give
you a different example so when I
actually started out getting in my own
business right I uh I had a chain of
gyms this was a very very you know this
is 10 years ago I had a change of gems I
knew how to run sales teams I knew how
to generate leads I knew to do all these
things
um but what ended up happening was I had
one missing piece which was also a
belief darn I was actually trying to
give you a different one but I had a
mentor come in and say you need to be
you need to get in the licensing
business you need to license this model
to lots of people rather than doing the
actual model yourself and so um I did
make that transition and then we went
from I think you know I think we did
like two or three million dollars to
doing seven and the next year we did 28
million so the year that we made the
transition halfway through is what
jumped us from two or three to seven and
it was just in the last like four months
that we saw this crazy growth and then
we did 28 million the next year and so
it was because I had all these skills
and I also had the character traits I
just needed again to change some of the
beliefs I was trying to give you an
example with the character traits I'll
let me think of one so if you have uh
for example if I had had those skills
but I didn't have the character traits
of being disciplined and being focused
on one thing I would have jumped uh
between multiple you know
entrepreneurial Endeavors and never been
able to see success because even though
I had the beliefs about what was
possible
um like if I said okay I'm gonna do gyms
and I'm going to do chiropractors and
I'm gonna do dentists I'm gonna do X Y
and Z right
until I had the character trait of focus
the character trait of discipline
um then I would not have seen the
success right and so the next natural
question is okay well if I have to have
aligned beliefs skills and character
traits at each level of the latter
because you can have and this is what's
crazy when you see the overnight
successes this is what happens I want to
describe it to you so you understand it
how you can do it so let's say that
there's a ladder all right and you've
got this pole on one side you got the
pole on the other side you've got the
middle bar okay you need all three to
move to the next level of the latter
right and so for example you might have
the left side built up six stories above
where you're at and you might have uh
the right side build up six stories you
know uh or you know 10 stories from
where you're at right now but all of a
sudden if you change your character and
that character trait development gives
you three more rungs all of a sudden you
go three rungs because you already have
the constraint has been removed and so
you can be more advanced in your beliefs
than you on your skills or it can be
more advanced in your character trait
than you are in your skills or you can
be more advanced in your skills and
you're on your beliefs right and so it's
having all three of those that are
checked off at each level of
Entrepreneurship that gets you to one
one million dollars a year three million
or 10 million dollars you're 100 million
dollars or whatever it is right is you
have to have all of them and so what I
the the point of this video and I'm
gonna is is to get you to understand how
to actually develop those soft things
because the skills are straightforward
right the skills are you just go buy the
course and you read the book and you
consume the content like this and you
practice you apply right that's what you
have to do that's it that's it right
um one of the skills that I see lots of
marketers these days not have is they
don't know how to sell they don't know
how to develop a sales team they don't
want to manage and grow a sales team in
order to lead a sales team that's a
skill they don't have and as soon as
they do they go from 3 million to 10
million like that very very easily right
it's understanding that that's the skill
deficit and as soon as they do it boom
they blow up I was fortunate because I
had a ton of the skills in my skill
toolbox but I went from making nothing
to tons because I had all of these rungs
of this ladder already built out to to a
30 million dollar level except I just
didn't have the beliefs that was my
issue candidly I suffer from a lot of
insecurity and so my wife was the one
who was like you can do this like you
don't have to have these gyms like you
can license out the model like you can
you can really succeed like this and I
honestly just thought she was a really
smart person and very wise and so I
trusted her belief in me before I really
trusted it for myself and so hopefully
you can have something like that in your
life but maybe that that could be me I
trust in your I trust in your your
skills and your beliefs so so hopefully
you can borrow some of that trust
because I promise you the world does get
better when you when you take those
leaps of faith if somebody is starting
from scratch what are the traits skill
sets that they should be cultivating in
order to up the odds of their success
they should focus on one thing in
general rather than lots of different
things that you're not sure about
because if you're starting out
everything looks like an opportunity so
the correct answer is all of them are
opportunities but all of them won't work
unless you pick one right so you have to
say no to all the other Mistresses so
boom you pick one and then from there I
always say six figures is sell something
to someone that's it and if you want
more detail sell something to someone so
it's one Avatar one product one channel
so you don't have to figure out how do I
create 20 pieces of content across it's
like
just pick one channel one media Source
whether it's Facebook Instagram YouTube
you know whatever Twitter consistently
start going on that whether that's cold
outbound whether that's content whether
it's running paid ads whether it's
Affiliates Word of Mouth whatever it is
um and start reaching out to people
there to start selling your stuff you
have to learn how to advertise which I
Define is the process of making known so
how do you let other people know about
the stuff you sell so you have to
advertise and then once people engage
with whatever advertisement you have you
have to sell them so advertising is the
first skill selling them is the second
skill and then product would be the
third skill which is the thing that
you're ultimately advertising and
selling okay so that gets us six figures
what gets a seven doing the same thing
consistently
so usually once people do it in the
beginning they're sporadic they're not
consistent with it just the act of doing
the same thing every day usually gets
people to
100 000 a month which sounds crazy it's
probably people listening but most
people who think that's crazy also
haven't done it consistently for an
extended period of time and so I use
something that I call the rule 100 which
is 100 primary actions whether that's
100 minutes of of content creation per
day 100 reach outs per day uh 100 of AD
spend per day uh like you have to pick
one of them but 100 per day and you do
that for 100 days and I promise you'll
have you'll be making six figures if you
do that unless your parents are
exorbitantly wealthy and have achieved
everything that you wish to achieve I
don't think you should listen to your
parents and so one of my first rules of
life is never listen to someone who's
poorer than you or poor than you want to
be alright so that's two different you
know caveats there because you might be
younger and it's like okay well yeah my
parents have more money than me but like
are they poor than you want to be if so
then only listen to people who are
wealthier than you want to be right and
the thing is is that they always will
and other people too right will always
side on the side of being less less
risky right and here's why because when
you naysay right it's like kind of like
when you're um if if someone's like oh I
don't like your girlfriend and and the
thing is is that if you date in general
right and dating can can apply like the
concept of dating and apply to business
Concepts doesn't really matter but if
you date then fundamentally every single
person that you date except for the one
that you marry is going to be somebody
who you're not going to be with and if
someone says I don't think this person's
good I don't think this person's good
then they will be right literally 99 of
the time except for the one time that
matters right kind of interesting and so
the thing is is most businesses fail 95
of business they'll fail within five
years right and so most times they are
correct and so it's very easy for them
to self-reinforce that they are so smart
right and they're always right and they
can tell you I told you so right but the
reality is that they are wrong in the
one person of times that it matters
right in your life and so when I think
about this what's interesting is that
like the only way that is guaranteed to
not get to success is to never take the
risk to begin with right that's the
guaranteed way of not achieving it and I
remember when I was quitting my job that
was the biggest conclusion that I came
to was that I was not happy at my
current earning level and that the only
job because there was one position one
job that made enough money that I wanted
which was being an investment banker so
the best investment bankers can make 10
20 million dollars a year but I knew
what it was required to get there and
the amount of effort time and sacrifice
and I was like the only people who will
pay me that amount of money
um will be making so much more money off
of me and literally draining my life
that I don't think it's because like
usually if you become an investment
banker that's successful you pretty much
donate 20 years of your life in order to
do that
um and you're you're really never going
to see your family and all that kind of
stuff and for me that was not a
trade-off I wanted to make and so I
figured there was no job that was going
to pay me what I wanted to make and
afford me the lifestyle that I wanted
and so
the path that I was on was guaranteed
to not get me to where I wanted to go
and so even though it was micro risky it
was macro
the only way I could do it right and so
that's one of those like one of those
things actually like from garyvee he
says micro speed macro patients right
money love speed wealthless time and so
if we're trying to build wealth we're
trying to build an asset right then we
need to have time one of my other
favorite things that I'll share with you
is um uh you get paid for what you do
you get Returns what you own right and
so anyways back to the back to the
reason why you shouldn't listen to other
people is that they don't have an
accurate understanding of risk right and
the biggest risk is not doing anything
at all the biggest risk is never dating
not that you're with this person right
and so Warren Buffett said and I like
this he said most people only need to
make four or five really good decisions
in their life so think about that for a
second because I think about like that
one really shook me because I think
about all the decisions that I make
every single day right and all the
decisions that I've made in my life and
there's really not that many of them
that have been the biggest levers but
the few that have been have been massive
and enormous lovers in my life and most
people don't take enough time to think
about those decisions that are the
massive force in the road am I going to
keep going in this position do I want to
live in this city am I going to marry
this girl who am I going to go to uh who
am I going to get into business with uh
what are we going to do right what are
we actually going to do in this business
and so people don't give put enough
thought into that stuff and spend all
their time thinking about what next show
they're going to watch on Netflix right
rather than thinking like I'm going to
take some time with this decision
because what my other sayings is
mistakes love a rushed decision right so
micro speed macro patience if you're
looking at long playing long then you
have to understand or at least this is
my you know my two cents on it is that
most people will oppose you at all times
and that is because it is safer for them
to do so because they will be right most
of the times but on the one percent of
times that they are wrong it's that one
percent decision
saying that you're going to buy Seas
candies for 25 million dollars and ends
up generating a billion dollars right in
Revenue it's that one decision that
they're going to miss out on and that's
the one decision that matters and so
they are 99 of the time right but
they're 100 wrong right and so that's
the only message that I wanted to to
Really drive home is that if you have
parents who make less money than you
want to make if you have friends who
make less money than you want to make I
had so many people who told me that
everything I was doing was stupid I was
giving up a really good consulting job
to open a gym right I took all my
savings and sucked into a business and
you know what that business wasn't the
one that set me free it was four four or
five businesses from there but I learned
the skills that one by one I was able to
assemble and assemble on a belief
standpoint of the world with the
character traits to reinforce them to
eventually yield the success that some
people think is you know cool most small
entrepreneurs try and get customers to
make sales
bigger entrepreneurs try to make sales
to get customers
and the difference is one person is all
about trying to get to the money as fast
as possible what do I need to say to get
this person to say yes what I need to
say to get this person to buy right how
do I get the money right
the other way is how do I make some sort
of exchange so that I can now create a
long time relationship with this
customer and continue to provide value
over time one has a compounding View and
perspective on time and value and the
other is short-sighted and I can tell
you the difference between the people
who are millionaires that I have that
I'm friends with and people who are
billionaires that I am friends with this
is probably one of the most fundamental
differences and so I was talking to a
friend of mine who's worth over a
billion and he was saying if it's not
going to grow on its own over time it's
not worth doing and I really sat with
that for a second and it was like if you
put in a one-time effort like this is
what this is how people who are the
ultra wealthy think if you put one-time
effort into something and it compounds
over time then that is an Enterprise or
a product that they want to continue to
invest in on the flip side if you have
to consistently show up and consistently
promote and consistently get out there
and sell and sell and do all this stuff
then what ends up happening is that the
product itself is not good enough right
because people in and of themselves are
not referring business and so let me let
me give you three questions that really
changed and hopefully will alter your
perspective like they did mine around
product and service and so the first is
if I have an existing product or service
and I were to make it 10 times more
expensive so really think about the
price so or you can say a hundred
thousand dollars or a million dollars
whatever it is right just a huge number
and if that's how much I were charging
for it what would I need to do
what would the experience need to be
what would the product need to deliver
in order for it to be worth that much
what happens you start thinking in a
very different type of mindset about how
much value you have to create right and
so that is the first question that I ask
there's two more and the third one's my
favorite I'll get to in a second
the second question I ask is
if this product that I have cost one
tenth as much as it does right now but I
had to make it better than it currently
is
what would I need to do what one time
assets would I need to create that would
consistently provide value that I could
do at scale that could I could do
profitably right so
first question If This Were 10 times
expensive or a hundred thousand or a
million dollars is what I charge for my
product
what would it need to be what would the
experience need to be and what value
would I need to deliver in order for it
to be worth that much
the second question is if it were
one-tenth the cost but I had to make it
better than my current product or
service what else would I create or do
or make in order to facilitate that
outcome
and the third question which is probably
my favorite which I think underpins the
entire ideology that that I'm hitting on
here is if I had a business and I were
only allowed to sell one more customer
and the rest of the growth of my
business had to come from that customer
without me asking as in that that
customer's experience was so remarkable
was so positive was so amazing that they
they alone had to on their own volition
tell other people about my service
what would need to happen
what would need to happen to create that
experience and when thinking about all
three of these product frames I like
them because they kind of hit on
different aspects of the product the
first question which is a hundred
thousand dollar million dollar question
hits on value which is how do I create
the most value in the product itself
the second question hits on the profit
of the product because if it's one tenth
the cost and I have to make it better
this means I don't have to do high
margin one-time investment type things
to make the entire product more valuable
right so that hits on profit so first is
the value of the product the second is
the profit to me right as a business
owner and then the third question hits
on the experience which is what's the
customer experience which is everything
else that surrounds the product that
we're selling or service that we're
selling right what is the experience
that has to occur in order for this
customer to become a raving fan that
it's so good that they remark about it
they cannot help themselves but remark
about it and what's interesting is that
every super wealthy person that I know
pretty much exclusively talks about
product and usually the really small
people that I know only talk about
promotion and promotion should really
only exist to get your product right and
then once it is right then you can juice
it and then let it go and take care of
itself and the reason that it's so
important at least in my opinion is that
if you think about the six ways of
getting customers right and if you don't
know what those are it's paid media
earned media So Paid media is
advertising right in promotions uh
earned media is followings right if you
have any kind of organic following the
third is through your contact list so
people on your phone and your email list
Etc that you already own their contact
information the fourth is through manual
outbound so that's DMS cold emails cold
calls cold all of that stuff where you
reach out to people
the fifth is through Affiliates of
Partners who can promote your stuff and
the sixth which is the most powerful and
the only one that compounds
is Word of Mouth
so think about that for a second every
of the other five ways of acquiring
customers is not compounding those are
linearly scaled right it means if you
double the amount of outbound people you
have you double the amount of customers
that you get if you double your ad spend
you might be able to double the amount
of customers you get sometimes it's less
than that but you get the idea they
scale relatively linearly right
whereas Word of Mouth referrals which is
the sixth way of getting customers is
the only one that compounds it
multiplies rather than is additive all
right if you get two people to tell two
people and those people tell two people
that it continues to compound and that
is what creates Enterprise Value that is
what creates an enduring thing and that
is what when you spend the extra time to
make the product so good that people
have to tell their friends about it then
that's where you get the unending scale
and also is where all the profit is
right you don't have to worry about the
churn as much because the product's so
good you don't have to worry about the
negative reviews because the product's
so good you don't have to worry about
customers bad mapping you because
instead they're telling their friends
about how good you are and
this has been one of the shifts that has
been most helpful for me and honestly
what I when I look back on my own
trajectory how much I talk about
promotion in the beginning of my career
versus now I talk so much more about
people and product the real nuts of this
is that
everything that the ultra wealthy do is
compounding it grows with time where
time becomes an asset instead of a
liability and if everything you do you
have to go out and get more business go
out and get more business go out and get
more business right it means that it
requires effort every single day whereas
if you put a lot of front-end effort
which is the investment which is the
patience right to make the thing that
much better in the beginning
then it will pay you in dividends over
time and most people skip that step
because they just want to make the first
sale they're just trying to get a
customer to make a sale rather than
trying to make a sale to get a customer
hard work will not make you rich I get
driven nuts by the amount of gurus and
influencers and whatever who want to
brag and say no one can outwork me I'm
the best in the world so many people
outwork me I still make more money than
them there has to be something else one
of the things that grinds my gears about
a lot of the people that I see on
Instagram that you probably see too is
this whole like no one can outwork me
Mantra first off it's objectively false
because many people a outwork you today
be at work you have in the past see you
haven't met everyone indeed it doesn't
matter anyways it's the same thing when
someone's like I'm the best and you have
to say you're the best because if you
don't think you're the best it shows
that you're not confident to me I don't
take that at all if someone's like I'm
the best then why aren't you on
billboards that's what the best would
look like absolutely you need to do the
work you need to put volume in it's the
only way you get better but if you start
claiming that you are the best you
cannot be outworked you are making stay
statements that you know are not true
why are we bragging about work because
work has very little to do with the
highest levels of the game Warren
Buffett talks about if he makes two good
decisions a year he's had a good year
and so how is it that one of the best
investors one of the best business
people in terms of measuring it by money
which is how you measure business talks
about how he does basically nothing
reads five or six hours a day eats
McDonald's and makes a couple good
decisions a year how is it that that guy
is making so much more money than the
people who are bragging about the fact
that they work so hard everyone only has
the same hours of the day anybody who
only sleeps eight hours or only sleeps
seven hours and works the remaining of
hours of the day all of them would be
tied for hardest working so what creates
output you have volume of activity and
then you have the leverage of the
activity that you're doing that's what
creates the total output in order to do
anything you must do something there has
to be some level of energy that gets
input into the system our activity in
terms of number of activities is a very
newbie measure of success in the
beginning Warren Buffett doesn't say
I sent a thousand emails today he
doesn't talk like that he's playing a
different game Jeff Bezos didn't like
woke up at 4am today now mind you I'm
saying this is somebody who likes waking
up early we can't be as superstitious
about what matters waking up early
doesn't matter going to bed late doesn't
matter not sleeping a lot doesn't matter
the few things that matter are the
inputs that go into the system that have
the most leverage to create the most
output now if you're a newbie and you
can't get your ass off the couch and by
all means figure out how to actually get
your ass off the couch and do stuff but
then there's only so many hours and so
boom and then very quickly you hit your
capacity of work great you've maximized
that now what the leverage that we have
on that activity is going to dictate how
much we get out of it and if we do a low
leverage activity many many many times
we might get more than a high leverage
activity that gets done once a CEO who's
going to work with acquisition.com Works
virtually every hour of every day when
they come in almost everybody does
sometimes they ask they're like am I
going to be working more or like it's
impossible for you to work more but you
are going to be changing what you work
on because that's the only lever we have
there's only 24 hours so we're going to
switch these nine out and we're gonna
plop these in with higher leverage
activities and so the way that we do
that is we look at their calendars and
we look at their org chart you look at
what they spend their time on and you
see which of these activities are low
Leverage is there anyone else in this
org chart that we can hand these
activities to and if a large percentage
of these activities are a certain type
of thing and they don't exist in their
chart then it's a role that we need to
hire the point of why I hate the concept
of no one cannot work me is that there
are many ways to win the game if you
were to think about an amazing goal as a
dragon to be slain if you are familiar
with video games in any way when you
create like a war party you have a group
of people that are going to go go on a
quest you don't just have 10 paladins or
guys who just have Shields and swords so
you've got a Healer a mage that's really
good at damage but can't take a lot of
damage you've got a paladin who can't
hit as hard but he can take a lot of
shots you find people who have
complementary skills if you're playing
football you don't have 10 running backs
the entrepreneur really should be the
coach of the team it's about organizing
the pieces and how the well they play
together that ultimately determines how
good the team is like how many times
have you seen the team with the All-Star
that has the for Supporting Cast get
beat by the overall better team it
happens all the time a lot of
entrepreneurs as I see in them are
trying to play the game like they're the
star player and they want to score all
the points but they lose to Apple
because Apple's got a team we celebrate
a specific action like work when it's
really just saying oh look there's a
paladin who can take a lot of hits cool
that's not the only thing that's
required to win I think what is more
valuable is to know what are each of the
roles that exists within the business a
b is there one of these that you map to
based on your characteristics and skill
sets and then see what is my eventual
Evolution through entrepreneurship we'll
start at the beginning which is what are
the players on the field so if you think
about it by function you've got somebody
who has to promote who's got to be a
good marketer they have to understand
how to make things known across
different platforms telling stories
building a brand providing value to an
audience that's what marketing is sales
is being able to convert that raw
attention into a sale direct response
ads sales Pages video sales letters Etc
which is pretty much anything that's
physical products or software based
that's low ticket or it's higher ticket
people-to-people hand-to-hand combat who
know how to in the beginning sell and
then later train how to sell and then
later later lead people who train how to
sell these are not necessarily the same
people I've met really brilliant
marketers with suck at sales I'm a
really good sales people sucking
marketing then you've got somebody who
understands product how do I make
something beautiful the guy who started
Shopify he's not CEO of Shopify he's had
a product he's a mage he knows how to
cast spells and you've got the
experienced people who are managing
everything outside of the actual product
itself how do customers engage with us
how it can provide more value how to
give an amazing experience how do we
make sure they're hitting these
Milestones this person who knows
customers experience and customer
success is not the same person who
understands product and ux and design
that's a different game which is
different the guy who knows how to close
this different guy that knows how to
promote the bigger the Enterprise gets
the more specialized the skill becomes
and the deeper The Well of experience
that people need to be they have to be
more specialized when people are like I
can't be outworked you're bragging about
the wrong thing it should be like I
can't be out I can't be outmanaged no
one can build a culture like me that's
super high leverage across the
organization no one can lead like me but
no one can outwork me
it's just an irrelevant activity metric
I love working I work all the time but I
would never claim that no one works
harder than me I tend to have very good
leverage with the activities that I do I
spend tons of time writing a book in
that book prints and sells copies
forever it's a different way to play the
game and so level two of this which
player you are in the Middle Run of this
you end up segregating yourself to a
portion of the business that you're an
expert at or that you're best at CMO or
chief sales officer Chief product
officer it's not about one player being
the champion here it's about how the
team works together which then gets to
the third level of this is just about
being the coach think about what the
best coaches do they're literally trying
to head hunt the best players and
they're trying to recruit the best
people from college look at what Google
does think about their recruiting
efforts they have huge influxes
dedicated to getting the best and
smartest people out of college and they
have another ring for the best and
smartest people come out of business
school and then another one is their
very high level recruiting at the top of
the executive level the parallels
between sports and business they are
almost the same in that way now mind you
you can only have you know 10 or 11
people on the field you might have ten
thousand but if each of those players
represents a function or Department of
the business it makes more sense when we
move up the levels of Entrepreneurship
we need to make sure that we're playing
the right game and that we're using the
right metric to measure our success
final level of this is being the coach
is recruiting the top level Executives
and creating a farm system underneath to
feed into the company that you have so
you can have a sustained competitive
advantage and create a dynasty for the
team so you can create the best winning
team every year and have the soft skills
of creating culture of high performance
so that you get the most out of every
individual player and the difference
between amazing coaching and mediocre or
poor coaching is what would players do
if they had no coach or leader and then
what would they do if they had the best
coach and best leader the Delta between
those two is the value of the coach the
value of the CEO the CEO needs to have
the highest return on time out of anyone
in the organization because they need to
always be solving the next problem as
long as when they replace their time the
activities they do with the new stuff
builds the business even more then that
trade will always work and if CEO can
come in and turn a business around even
behemoths around in two three years
based on the standards that they set and
the values that they stand for that
Delta across the entire organization is
your greatest leverage for me wisdom is
the number one character trait that I
wish to develop and so when I think to
myself I am wise because I use the same
formula that you that most people and
most of us myself included use to
destroy ourselves with these
insecurities with these with these
negative character traits that we
believe we have
and instead of saying an affirmation you
tell yourself the story of why what
you're saying is true you learn to argue
against your own thoughts and that's how
you start developing this muscle this
these traits that start to become a
whisper and then a shout and then they
become they emanate from you and you
project them when you walk in the room
subconsciously but it's a practice that
goes from active to passive in your mind
right if you are a patient person if you
are a kind person if you are an Integris
person right if you are a hard-working
person right we all have these stories
that we tell about ourselves and so
if you have a limitation right now on
your character trait or traits you don't
feel like you are patient enough you
feel like you are too easily distracted
you feel like you don't focus enough
then you start telling yourself the
story I am this way because not I am
wealthy stupid in my opinion I think our
brains are too smart for that stuff you
have to give it the reasons you have to
make the argument and I think instead of
affirmations if you make affirmations
into arguments that you make with
yourself every day then those become
things that will change who you are and
if you change who you are and how you
make decisions you'll change your entire
life and you'll be able to watch your
business grow as a result of who you
have become and so this is one of the
things that was most powerful for me in
my entrepreneurial journey I I had had
tons of insecurities right I had tons of
anxieties I had lots of anger I had lots
of perceived trauma and I'll say it that
way because I don't even want to make it
into trauma this is what I perceived as
trauma because I was a child in the
world with the the red the emotional
regulation of a child and so things of
course affect you more when you're a kid
everyone's traumatized traumatized
perceives trauma as a child like if I go
to a stage and I say hey who here had a
traumatic childhood in some instance or
had a traumatic event occur everyone's
going to raise their hand so stop
thinking that because you have trauma
and I don't say this I'll say this with
I'll say it this way better
for me I chose to stop giving trauma
power
and I think if you can do that you can
tell yourself a different story about
why you are who you are and make
arguments instead of affirmations you'll
be able to have
a stronger faster change in the
direction that you desire and you'll
have more control over your emotional
state and then in so doing you'll be
able to level up the business that you
have because most of times when I see
business owners the reason they're not
successful is not because they don't
have the beliefs or because they don't
have the skills it's just because of who
they are I think the difference between
like rich people and poor people
successfully people not successful
people is the degree to which they
attribute
or give power to their circumstance
right and so the difference between a
self-made
billionaire who started with nothing and
someone who else started with nothing is
not the resources obviously because they
both started at zero so what else is it
is there resourcefulness not the
resources and so
um if we give power to circumstance then
we cast power outside of ourselves if we
give power to other people we cast power
outside of ourselves and so it's you
know it's controlling the controllable
uh and when I you know when I say that
quote a lot of that is is how that quote
is how I see selling
it's people cast power to their
circumstances and my job is to get them
to themselves around the power that they
have just cast to something they cannot
control and so if I can just get them to
own
even just own the fact that they suck
that's good enough because they actually
can own it and there is pride in that
you can take pride in the fact that you
admit that there's a deficit right but
there is the only thing you can't take
pride in is casting and being a victim
right like no one moves forward even if
you're right it doesn't serve you right
if you're born with one you know one
less leg than you should you're right
you're not going to be you have a
disadvantage at being a sprinter like
you have a disadvantage
but it doesn't serve you in any way to
admit it
and so it's it's owning the fact that
like you are the only person who can
actually change anything about your life
because you may blame your circumstances
but no one else will care I have shed
friends every season of my life my close
Circle has always been very very small
very very small
very small
um assistant
um I also feel like I grow really
quickly because I don't hold on to
things long the moment something doesn't
provide me value I shed it I think about
my life in three to five year Seasons
first I was a high school womanizer for
the most part and then I was also like
really deeply angry I had high school
friends that when I left High School I
basically stopped being in contact with
them and then I had my come to Jesus
where my dad was like you suck as human
you have a terrible reputation maybe you
should stop being who you are cleaned up
my ACT I stopped drinking nearly as much
as I was I started going to school and
studying 12 hours a day present the
fraternity and that was my college
season and I had College friends and
then when I left College I pretty much
stopped being in contact with anyone
that I went to college with most people
suck at most things and aren't Bound for
greatness because of who they are and
the choices they're willing to make the
stories about friends leaving the
hometown and no longer remember where
they're from is one that is told by
Society because Society is the majority
the majority of people get left behind
if you look at the things that you want
to get in life there's a price for them
you don't buy everything you see in the
mall why not because you don't want to
pay the price just because you might
think that a shirt or jacket is cool
just because you think an outcome is
awesome you might not be willing to make
the trade winners and losers have the
same goals the goal doesn't make you
unique it's the willingness to pay the
price that makes you unique it's like
everyone wants to be rich one of the
reasons that I cut people out sooner
than most is because I do not like the
labels they speak over me one of the big
things with identity is the labels that
we say about ourselves I am ex I am
impatient I am angry I am whatever right
I am poor I don't like saying it people
in your past have the identity that they
know you as and then they will speak and
they will beat that label into you
because you're not matching their
pattern why have you changed you are X
you are why and you're trying to not be
that because you're doing something
different than changing you're growing
but they see it as change and that's why
the best response in the world to
someone who says hey you've changed is
to say yeah you have it the amount you
like or love someone is directly
proportional what you are willing to
give up to maintain the relationship for
example if there's a piece of car right
you work on it all the time you might
say that guy must really love it because
of how much time he puts into that thing
this guy must really love his country
because he's willing to give his life
for it what are you willing to give in
exchange to maintain the relationship if
you're not willing to give up basically
anything to maintain their relationship
then how much do you love them I think
it's been a very helpful filter for me
to say not do I love my friends but
which friends do I love the most which
friends am I willing to sacrifice the
most to keep the relationship and I am a
big believer in utility there is an
exchange in every relationship you get
something and they get something back
people don't like the idea that
relationships are transactional
but they are transactional just has a
commercial vibe to it but if we just
think about it as from a behavior
standpoint you've got two things that
can happen a behavior is reinforced or
it is punished that's it when you have
exchanges quite literally with people
those exchanges are either reinforced or
they're punished part of the strength of
the relationship is how long you're
willing to wait for the next time that
relationship is reinforced if you have a
long history of positive experiences
with a person you're willing to wait a
longer period of time if they're going
through a breakup they're having a hard
time to keep the relationship going but
at some point even if you've been
friends with somebody for 10 years if
there's just not any positive
reinforcement at some point
you do cut it off the people who are
surrounded with when we grow up it's
very unlikely just from a population
standpoint that they're going to be
great statistically that they're going
to be the top one percent or point one
percent is unlikely so it would make
sense that you change your friends over
time why do people get so weird about
keeping relationships that don't serve
them I think it's just because we have a
societal story around it that you're a
bad friend but I could also think of me
being as a good friend to my next friend
that I just made room for there's gonna
be a friend who's going to move in to my
spot on my buddy's calendar who does
want to do fantasy football who does
want to drink with him on Sunday so it's
not this like all right I'll go to the
game with you but I'm not drinking oh
dude you're not gonna come on man
because the other guy's like yeah shots
all around and they're gonna have a
blast they would better be served with
people who want the same things as them
just because I'm not seeing them anymore
doesn't mean that I don't wish them well
but if someone only tells you the
stories when you got and why you did
that stupid thing they're encouraging
you in retelling the story of who you
used to be and you want people around
you who don't believe the lies you used
to tell about yourself the character
trait shift is not a binary it's how
patient are you how kind are you how
loyal are you how honest are you and so
you want people who encourage you in the
behaviors that you want to be like and
this is why I like shedding identities
is such a core part of Entrepreneurship
is that you have to be willing to say I
am no longer this way I will no longer
behave in this way and I don't accept
that reality as truth many of the people
I had around me hey weren't willing to
pay the price that I was willing to pay
for the things that I wanted but also
wanted me to give them more than I was
willing to and so I'll give you a story
that will paint me in a bad light and
that's fine there was a teacher that I
grew up with in high school and he's the
one who stayed with me after school for
a year and worked out with me two hours
a day and you taught me how to work out
I got in shape got more confidence
better at school from there that
snowballed into me getting into fitness
huge Catalyst snowball somebody heard
that story and then found the teacher
and they linked us he was like hey man
I'm not asking for a lot I would love to
just have like a two-hour quality every
week
I was like a two-hour call every week
I was like I don't even talk to my
mother that much I don't talk to anybody
that much talk to my wife that's it the
value of the relationship was in the
past you may be like Alex you're a
horrible person and that's possible
maybe I am I was not willing to give two
hours a week 100 hours a year for the
rest of my life
to pay a debt for somebody who worked
out with me because we only have so much
Juju we only have so much time we have
so much Focus so much energy that we can
pour into things and if you're not
putting all your energy in One Direction
it's scattered and then you don't move
as fast my closest friend I spend one
hour a week with every week my closest
friend like clockwork it's my highest
party meeting it is something that
brings me joy and we get lots of
exchange with one another he's the one
who helps me write my books Dr Kashi Dr
Kashi here I get a lot from that now if
I didn't get anything from that over
time slow down the communication between
us I would make it every other week once
a month if you slow down your
communication cages with someone how
frequently you see them and when you
accept invitations it naturally Fizzles
but if it gets to a point where if
someone's like so close that it would be
obvious and a conversation needs to be
had
I encourage you to just have it you want
to be a kind person and the way you are
kind is that you tell the truth and you
just be honest and the easiest way that
I can tell you to be honest is you know
when you talk about somebody behind
their back just say it to them it's like
yeah Sandra's been like all over the
place lately and she's like I don't
drink it a little bit too much Sandra
you've been all over the place lately
you've been drinking a little bit too
much I'm just not sure if I want to
associate with that right now people
just don't have the balls to do that but
if you do that I promise you either have
better relationships or you'll be done
with this Mickey Mouse of not
even being in a real relationship and
not wanting to confront reality because
you may have a shot at getting them to
realize that they're not on the path
that they wanted to be on because you
were friends with him at some point and
so either your goals have changed or
theirs have if you listen to Kobe's
interviews where he talks about his
friends he says very explicitly that
he's willing to put everything on the
Altar for his dream now some people may
make the argument that's not quote
healthy the question that we're
answering here is not how do we do
healthy stuff question is how do we
become the greatest people will judge
you on how you spend time and their
judgments are simply Expressions that
they would not spend their time the same
way you do hey you work a lot and I
could say hey you don't
to the same degree it's like you spend
so much time with your kids
right if I say it like that people like
wait no I'm supposed to it's only the
supposed to this the thing that gives
all the emotional charge to these
conversations otherwise it's just
observing reality you can't expect to do
the same thing everyone else is doing
and somehow achieve a different outcome
once you have the vacuum of friends
because you'll probably have weeded
people out then the best thing to do is
join communities and then you'll make
friends with people in those communities
who have the same goals as you and then
if you crush it because you understand
that volume is the answer and time is
the ingredient you're going to rise in
that community and you'll gain more
status and you'll start hanging out with
people who are at the top of that
community and then you can LeapFrog into
other communities it's just lunch tables
on steroids I've wanted to live a rare
life and so I will have to be surrounded
by Rare people and rare people are by
definition rare they are not common My
Hope Is that the people that I meet now
are trying to go all the way with me I
want to do epic if I die and don't do
epic I will be bummed how much am I
willing to endure or sacrifice in order
to maintain that relationship that I
have with my dream if I have many many
friends over different seasons I'm
totally cool with that thank you for
that season it was awesome I don't
believe things need to be forever to be
good and it's only the romantic story
that we were told of friends for life
Etc if you die with one good friend or
two good friends like you've had a
really good life to get started you have
to sell something to someone that's it
like literally that's all one Avatar one
product one channel that's it so you
have one way of getting customers you
saw one thing to one specific type of
person that is all you need to do to get
to six figures
to get to Seven figures you need to
learn how to do those three things comma
reliably comma consistently right so you
know how to sell one product one avatar
on one channel in a consistent manner so
you start having predictive metrics on
how you can acquire customers so it's
either I spend this amount of money on
advertising and this is how many you
know calls to get booked and then from
that many calls I get that many you know
sales Etc uh if it's outbound it's like
I send this many emails or make this
many calls or this many texts and this
many you know reply back this many
schedule this many show this many
clothes Etc if you're running organic
it's I know that I need to have this
many posts that I have to make across
these different channels with call to
actions that drive towards this page for
every thousand visitors on this page I
get why opt-ins you know what I mean so
each of these vehicles or I have to hit
my email list you know once a week and
if I hit it once a week with a call to
action again so all these are the
different ways you can get customers you
can also do Affiliates you can do
referrals there's many ways to do it but
the point is you pick one Avatar one
channel and one product as soon as you
can start predicting
how many inputs it takes to get an
output then you get to a million right
and at that point you're you know one
two three millionish a year uh one to
three you have to build out your core
team so that's usually like the first
five hires first five to ten ish that
are it depends on the on the on the
ticket of the thing that's being sold
you know if you're selling 25 000 things
versus 500 things the the team size is
going to be different
but it's the core team at about 3
million and that's that's the reason
that we take companies on at three is
usually because because there's a core
team and at three million there's
product Market fit so they've
demonstrated that people want this thing
and they have enough support that we can
take them from three to ten three to ten
uh and this is interesting because this
is a mistake a lot of people make it
three and I can stop whenever you want
me to cut the lines of the problems that
come up but the problems that come up at
three-ish
um
are that people start getting cute right
and they start saying and here's what's
difficult is that you get reinforced on
the fact that the more you Market the
more you sell the more money you make
right and it's true and you can scale
from there by doing more sales more
marketing and that is what the vast
majority of the industry will do because
they got reinforced doing it early the
problem is that they switch the
objectives the objective of the first
phase of business which for me is like
zero to three is just to demonstrate
product Market fit and an acquisition
channel that is profitable that is the
objective now
at this point we transition objectives
to increasing lifetime value per
customer so this is improving the
customer experience putting Data
Tracking in place
um if there's an Ascension opportunity
that makes sense we need to build out
that product or service line so that and
this is the big point so that when we do
choose to add another Channel or expand
on our current Channel we can do so more
profitably right where if you just sell
a single product that might not have as
much LTV as you would you know you would
want as you scale or put more in uh your
margins begin to compress so you might
go up to 10 million but your margins
have compressed over time and then you
get in this place where you have to keep
selling to maintain your overhead but
you're not really taking enough home and
you can't have enough cash free cash
flow to grow the business and so
sometimes it's like you have to take the
step back fix the product fix the
customer experience fix the the service
fix the data fix the infrastructure that
everything's built on probably higher
and fire so people that you promoted a
little bit too early that didn't have
the experience because they're actually
actually running things that well
um and then once we fix that stuff then
honestly going from three to ten usually
almost happens on its own once we're at
10. then we go far more aggressively on
the acquisition side which is you know
the the easiest moniker that I use is
more better new so we do more what we're
currently doing until we Max that out
and then we do better of what we're
currently doing is there any cro
opportunity so conversion rate
optimization can we switch this headline
out can we change this lead magnet can
we can we Implement some of the best
practices that we know to get you know
more people to show up if it's a service
business if it's a if it's a product
business now I only focus on service
businesses so lots of me lots of our
stuff is over the phone
um can we change the the video sales
letters and the follow-up emails things
like that all the improvements that can
happen
um
and then different is okay or new is can
we add a new channel to this so we have
six that we can choose from to get new
customers we've got we've got we can hit
up our own lists we can do cold cold
outbound we can do content we can do
paid ads we can do Affiliates and we can
do referrals and so those are the only
six ways to get in your customers we
look at those six and say of the skills
that we currently have which of these
would make the most sense to add to it
and you can even go adding a new thing
within a current so if you're running
paid ads it's like going from Facebook
to YouTube or going from Facebook to
tick tock and so there's you know is
each each one of those six squares has
channels or media channels that you can
or platforms that you can tap into that
give you new audiences so that was a
little bit of a crash course there but
that's what allows you to scale from 10
to 30 and Beyond at 30ish the uh the
founders typically will start feeling
constrained because they are the juju
behind the entire business and please
cut me off if I'm starting to bore you
guys there's a tweet by Layla my wife
she said like stop listening to people
about how to play the game who've never
been anywhere but the sidelines and the
problem is too many of the people who
are watching this right now y'all are on
the sidelines and have always been on
the sidelines and are trying to pick a
niche to get into to sell how to do the
niche well that's dumb you've never done
it so a lot of times people are trying
to skip to a higher leverage opportunity
without having done the requisite work
of understanding the niche which is why
the Y combinator people look for like if
you want to make a software in the
payment space we'd love to see that you
have experience in the payment space
because there's so much stuff that you
don't know that you know when you
actually spend three five you know years
doing something in an industry you
understand the lingo you understand the
Avatar you understand the problems and
you can see opportunities if you have an
entrepreneurial hat on there's always
problems in every industry which means
there's always opportunity and
fundamentally business is just solving
problems that exist with it and making
sure the math makes sense like that's
literally it it's like where is there a
problem how much do they think this is a
problem and is there a way that I can
solve it and charge for it that's it
like that's really all that business is
and really how well you solve the
problem is going to dictate how much
virality your business has because if
you solve it really well people will
tell people and your your business will
grow right I think the problem that a
lot of people have is they didn't know
how to make an offer right is the
fundamental thing that is the beginning
of building a business is you got to
know what you're selling and so that was
a problem for a lot of people and then
people got that problem solved and then
they told their friends and books sold
100 000 copies in six months with no
promotion and so I'm only I'm sharing
this because I couldn't write a book on
offers without having made a ton of
offers and I feel like there's too often
people who are trying to focus on a
niche who've never actually done the
thing in the niche and this is really
really rampant in the Internet space
because everyone's trying to take a
shortcut to get there when they realize
like what I'm telling you right now
you're never going to get there because
you're not good enough like you're never
going to get there because you're not
good enough you have to do the Rocky
cutscene you have to eat or period of
time so that you can get the Reps in so
you can put your time under the bar in
so that you can actually get good and
before you are good you will suck and
you have to accept long period of stock
and you do enough volume that eventually
you'll suck so little that you'll
actually be good and then at that point
then you'll actually have a real
decision to make which is I'm actually
really good at this thing now that I've
learned do I want to teach it to other
people or I just want to do more of the
thing that I'm doing right because like
a realtor can then just grow a team of
100 Realtors and own the entire thing
which is what I'd recommend this guy do
right rather than have an agency um that
doesn't right and so this is kind of
where where I think the problem is is
that like I had another question that
was sent to me on Instagram which is
like Hey how do I solve churn because a
lot of my a lot of my clients are
getting results and I'm like well duh
he's like I know he said he said how do
I sell from 10 000 to 100 000 a month
when I don't have a lot of testimonials
I was like
you're not good at the thing that you're
supposed to be good at it's why I don't
have testimonials it's why you're not
going 100 000 a month like he's making
the goal a hundred thousand dollars a
month rather than being good
I I I have no words I have no words I
don't get it you know what I mean like
everyone's in such a rush that you will
never get there it is the slowest path
to getting there is to fool yourself and
thinking that you're good something that
you're not you have to go and pull the
thread and say which and the thing is is
like well do what you're passionate
about whatever you're not gonna be
passionate about stuff that you suck at
what you have to do is like which of
these opportunities seem like they have
potentially have high leverage and I'm
going to learn from the bottom right
it's like one of the best ways to learn
stuff is starting at the bottom not
because because it's the only option but
because if you understand the entire
pathway of of a client Journey or of an
industry Journey then you will have more
trench knowledge more depth of
experience that you will be then able to
apply people see my you know videos on
Personal Finance people see videos of
mine on sales people's videos online
recruiting people see videos of mine of
marketing and it's like how did you
acquire all these skills it's because
like it's not like because I tried to
jump to the spot that I'm at you can't
skip like there's a sequence buildings
are built with foundations and your
career is a pyramid in the peak of that
pyramid is based on the depth of the
foundation that you build and so like
I've said this before and I'll say it
again but your work works on you more
than you work on it and so even though
you might not be getting paid in the
period that you're at just because
you're struggling doesn't mean you're
failing and it means and the thing is as
long as you're getting better you're
making progress and the progress is the
success is that you are getting better
and like you will turn the corner like
that's an inevitability if you put
enough time in period I promise you that
I started studying wealth after I became
wealthy so like what did you learn about
it afterwards and what do wealthy people
do that you think poor people don't do
they pick higher leverage opportunities
in a sentence so like poor Rich Dad Poor
Dad like Poor Dad says get a job Poor
Dad says get a higher paying job like
Rich Dad says like and the thing is
there's so many innate beliefs that seem
commonplace like well of course you know
what I mean like well of course you know
and you know you buy some real estate
and you know it'll appreciate over time
of course you invest in some stocks like
yeah of course but like poor dads just
don't say that and so you have to like
learn that I think and I didn't so I'm
grateful in that I didn't have to to
learn that because I heard that just was
of course yeah once you have some money
like of course you don't spend your
whole income of course you don't and so
there's a lot of of course you don't
that I think I I inherited just by being
in like a saving father but there's also
some upper middle class people who don't
save anything so like right but I think
my dad did a lot of I think he helped a
lot with like money hygiene I think I've
had a lot of really good money hygiene
from my dad the big the big breakthrough
that I had for me was when I stopped
focusing on and this is going to sound
backwards but when I started my gyms I
was all about building the business
right
and when I built the biggest companies
that I've had and now recently sold and
now we have our portfolio it was about
how do we make the most money
and I know that sounds completely
backwards but the only way that you can
make the most money is to provide an
exceptional valued service and charge a
ton of money for it and because I
optimized around making money I I
started going through four low Capital
expense businesses because I had lost
everything after that five-year stint
and so I was like never again am I going
to reinvest every dollar from the
business back into the business because
I've lost it before so when I started
the the next business in every business
I've had thereafter like we take
dividends every month and we do that
because you don't wait till there's an
accident 10 years later I mean put a lot
of money in I'd love to do both yeah
yeah why not both sure right and so that
was take a dividend and get a bigger
course yeah but not just put money in
and wait and get no money back 100 and
the thing is and this was a fallacy I
had because people always talk about
like reinvesting in their business but I
realized that that just meant that they
weren't making profit and so and so the
vast majority of businesses even the
software world is somewhat shifting in
this
um but they want to see profit and then
even better is if you have net free cash
flow which is just a fancy word for the
amount of money that you can take out
every month after making Necessary
investments in the business and so I
wanted to have businesses that pumped
cash flow because I lost it all before
and so I think there's a lot of like
every every one of my business Seasons I
would say I've had three uh business
Seasons I had my gym ownership period I
had my turnaround and early gym launch
day period and then I had prestigious
Labs the licensing business in Allen
that was like my last season were you
exited yeah yeah and then I say like now
we're in we're in our this third season
I guess so brick and mortar gyms
licensing supplements and software and
then you know third season is what we
have now and each of those has a huge
huge magnitude of Leverage that was
added to it and so you know this like
gym launcher started on accident in that
I was like this might be a way that I
could make money we think that for some
reason we are doing something wrong when
we are not self-caring because it is bad
two not self-care because as we should
we must or else or what and the reason
this pisses me off the reason that I
made a tweet that went viral this
morning about this is that weekends are
new for humans they're not even 100
years old 1929 in England is when the
first weekend got passed by a union and
it's because people hated what they were
doing for their life and so if you want
to truly give self-care then stop hating
what you do every day novel concept I
know stop hanging out with people that
suck mind-blowing like I said I know and
the reason that I am so passionate about
this is that I have been told throughout
my entire life that I was working too
much I was not balancing the things that
I was supposed to be balancing and you
know what who gives it's my life I don't
need to live by anyone else's rules and
neither do you right and so when people
say you should be doing this you are not
doing XYZ just take a pause and be like
are these rules that I want to listen to
are those your rules that you're trying
to apply to my life because there are no
rules you can do whatever the hell you
want if you want to work for a year
straight work for a year straight and
the reason you can work for a year
straight is because you like what you do
the reason these people try and project
their own self-hatred for their own
lives onto you is because they cannot
imagine a world in which someone might
actually like what they do every day and
didn't don't need an escape a break from
what their existence is on a daily basis
and so don't feel guilty for just being
you and if you don't like your life
every day rather than try and figure out
and make time for self-care it would
probably be better to flip the ratio and
start thinking what can I do in my
actual life to stop hating it so much
that I need an escape from it right and
that's different from like yes you need
to sleep yes you need to you know rest
Etc but there's a difference between
that and like uh I just need a total spa
day and if that's how you relax cool but
the thing is is projecting on someone
else how they should must need to have
to relax or do whatever it's nonsensical
it doesn't exist right I wanted to make
this video even though it's short
because I it just drives me bananas if
you want to work work if you want to
take off take off just don't listen to
what anyone else says about what you
should do for your life you're going to
die and so will they and it's not going
to matter and in 10 Generations don't
even remember your name so do what you
want you're going to die and that is the
ultimate freedom and for some reason we
live under these chains that we think
exists but don't and so I think the
process of of growing and really making
ourselves free is just simply
identifying the things that don't really
exist and only existed in our mind to
begin with and I think that's why
self-credit really bugs out of me or
this whole self-care movement it's also
softest like just work right to get it
done you need to like give yourself a
bubble bath every day because like your
work's so hard like humans been here a
very long time we've dealt with much
much harder your you know boss having a
deadline the next day is not the worst
that you've been through and so as a
final sign off on this think about the
hardest things that you've been through
in your life everyone has gone through
hard everyone has had difficulties in
childhood everyone has had difficulties
with siblings with parents blah blah
blah blah these events that shape Our
Lives you have been through harder than
this you will survive it will be okay
you don't need to self-care you don't
need to listen to what anyone else is
saying you do you I wanted to give you
the simplest single hack that I have
used inadvertently and seen a tremendous
amount of success that is asking myself
the question what would a person who
does this type of thing do in this
instance the the one that I'll tell you
that I've repeated a lot to myself over
the years probably over the last five or
ten years has been the repeated chorus
of what would a wise man do I think it's
because I did not consider myself to be
very wise and I acted many ways
that were unwise earlier on in my life
and I still continue to do so but I try
to do less of it right and I think that
and I'll I'll borrow this again from
James clear's book your identity is much
more of a weighing system actually
that's not from this book but like it's
much more of a voting system where you
you cast votes in either direction based
on your activities of what type of
person you want to become and I think
the simplest distillation of that
concept is simply asking the question
what would this type of person do if you
can use that as the refrain that you
come back to over and over again the
chorus of your day that gets repeated
over and over again I think it's much
easier than trying to remember the
50-point checklist of all the activities
that you need to do to achieve the goal
in the the friend that came back in my
life
um where we were having this
conversation I just distilled it down to
like what would a billionaire do and so
when we're confronted with these
crossroads right you wake up in the
morning and you're like I don't know
what I should start it's like what would
a billionaire do and so basically what
you can do is have a certain refrain or
chorus that you ask yourself what would
this type of person do and that type of
person when you ask that question is who
you will eventually become as you
continue to cast votes that reinforce
the stories that we tell ourselves about
who we are and those are the things that
create long-lasting deep change and
what's more about this is that these
changes when they become internal when
they become ingrained in our Behavior
they become effortless but it takes time
and so I think that the mental cue that
I have given myself inadvertently over
the years I don't have a lot of choruses
that I referring to or that I come back
to over and over again and so I tweeted
about one and it got shared a zillion
times so it is what would someone 10
times smarter than me do in this
situation right and a different way of
saying that is what would a billionaire
do and and word in whatever way that
resonates with you but I think rather
than having that big checklist you can
put just a little Post-it on your
computer or wherever you work that's a
reminder to yourself that this is the
type of person I want to become and in
order to become this type of person I
need to do these things because those
actions will reinforce the thoughts that
I say about myself because the whole
concept behind affirmations that I do
not like right which is IMA you know I'm
a lion I'm a tiger I'm a whatever right
just saying them doesn't make them true
unless you're a crazy person and most of
us are not crazy I think right there's
plenty of crazy if you don't get me
wrong but if you're probably watching
this channel you're probably at least
semi-sane right if we have you know this
degree of Sanity that's on our side then
what we have to do is create something
else which is evidence we have to give
ourselves evidence that we are this type
of person in order to become that but
how do you have evidence that you are
going to be this person when you have
none well it starts with activity it
starts with doing the stuff and as an
added core layer depending on the goal
that you have it might be what would a
person with a six-pack do what would a
pro-champion bodybuilder do what would
an amazing husband do or what would the
best husband in the world do and so you
can use this framework of asking the
question of what your ideal self would
do in any given circumstance to apply to
a vast number of scenarios rather than
trying to fix for the Habit fix for the
being and then the habits will take care
of themselves in accordance with the
type of person that you have stated you
wish to become and so then the goals we
have become becoming
the person we want to be once we know
who we want to become then that can
direct the types of activities that will
be in accordance with that and the
reason I like this better too is that if
we're trying to reinforce an identity or
an identity trait about ourselves this
is a really good habit I think that I've
picked up over the years some of our
older OG Jim Lords have been a while you
know I mean they turn their gym around
they've grown they're at you know you
know close to seven figures or right
around there and they've been doing it
for a while and they were complaining
about show rates they're like hey our
show rates are low and um you know you
go through the stand while you're doing
the reminders are you doing all this
above like yeah yeah we're doing all
this stuff okay cool and uh I dig a
little bit deeper and I look and it
turns out that they're only open one
hour
per day at 7 15 am
for their availability availability for
for new clients
and I'm like do you think that you're
going to grow your business if the only
time that you can take new customers is
at 7 15 a.m in what world does that make
sense right like imagine a grocery store
that's only open from seven to seven
thirty because that's when it's
convenient for the owner what chance do
you think that that grocery store has at
succeeding virtually none and so what
happens is people have success they
Implement tactics they use gym watch and
then they make money right and then what
happens they get comfortable they get
complacent right and they lose their
hunger like after that point everything
like it's almost like I was gonna say
like after you after you've like quote
made it in your mind and that's what's
funny is that making it in some people's
mind is like having 10 grand at the bank
account so like it's scary in terms of
what level of making it is but like once
people have made it I almost want to say
like none of these tactics matter
because you're just not hungry like it
doesn't matter like the obvious you
aren't doing you know what I mean if
you're a child was going to die or your
spouse or you're sitting together your
family member whatever it was who's
going to die unless you succeeded unless
you've got more clients unless you made
more money with your gym
how would you approach it right would
you only be available for one hour a day
would you only be available from seven
to eight a.m would you only set aside an
hour a day to prospect for new customers
would you only reach out to your
customers if they hadn't shown up for a
month sometimes people ask questions
that they already know the answer to
it's like duh right and and it goes back
to the the main thing which is like what
drives you right like what drives you
what drives you to be better what drives
you to continue to want to win I was
asked that question yesterday by the the
gym awards that were here and I think
honestly it comes from a dark place and
I think I've said this before but like
I'm saying it again because I think
people need to hear it sometimes you
have to wonder like why is it that only
when someone else's life is on the line
do you then actually try right like why
is it only then you actually cut all the
noise out of your life and then would go
laser focused on actually succeeding
like why can't we do that all the time
right like why can't we do that because
it's like well then I wouldn't be happy
whatever right like whatever happiness
means right and so the people who are
the most successful in the world are
driven by something that is deep inside
of them that it's normally an insecurity
or a fear of some sort
if you're only trying to make enough to
live on you will always only make enough
to live on
and you will slack the moment you get
comfortable and you will wonder why is
it that as soon as I start making money
I stop because you actually don't want
to make more
that's why you actually don't want to
make more and so your internal
motivation is not there right because
you've accomplished what you set out to
accomplish the real question is do you
actually want what you claim to want do
you actually want it because if you did
you'd already have it you'd already
you'd already be willing to sacrifice
other things in order to achieve it and
that might mean like maybe waking up
earlier maybe like working four to eight
pm to take sales appointments or
whatever that thing is like if you were
coaching you
what would you recommend you to do right
like a lot of times if you think about
it like
you most of the time know what to do
like you do on some level like you
probably know that you're like man I do
stupid sometimes right you probably
think that on some level sometimes right
then you're like man if I were if you
could step out of yourself and say I
need to coach myself you probably have
the answer and it's just that you don't
do it for some reason and so all of your
attention should be on that reason why
is it that this thing is preventing me
from doing the things that I already
know I should do our minds are meaning
making machines and so what that means
is we determine what is Meaningful and
what is not and then we ascribe labels
to them in terms of positive and
negative because that is how we survive
now that being said our brains Are Meant
To Keep Us Alive not meant to help us
Thrive right to use a rhyming word for
you now that being said with this whole
concept around labeling it's something
that I'm probably most passionate about
like the concept of labeling as a whole
it's unbelievably powerful when it comes
to persuading people to do things
unbelievably powerful when it comes to
changing people's World Views and their
perspectives on life and I will share a
few of those examples with you so I'll
give you a quick persuasion example for
how powerful this is if I wanted to
persuade someone to do something then
what I would do is I would create a
positive label that I would associate
them with so I would say you are
probably a loving and caring man for you
know you want to provide support for
your family is that true they're like
yes and I'm like yeah you definitely
seem like one of those types of people
and since you are one of those types of
people I think that you should invest in
this program that we have because that
would be in alignment with this ideal
that we just labeled the person with and
so what happens is it creates cognitive
dissonance because for the person in
order for them to stay in accordance
with the label that they would like to
have they then feel obligated to then
act in accordance with that label that
we just uh prescribed now that's a very
simplistic example you can weave that
into narratives and sales scripts so
that people become psychologically
labeled and then want to act in
accordance with that label because they
see it as positive right the thing is is
that it can also work in Reverse in
terms of how you can harm someone and
the reason that this is so viscerally
upsetting to me is that I have had
members of my family extended and
whatnot who have I would say debilitated
themselves in large part because of what
they believe to be mental illness and I
disagree now many people will get
triggered at this and so I will say my
big disclaimer which is this is not
Financial advice this is not grammatical
advice this is not spiritual advice this
is not even advice this is a guy making
YouTube video about stuff that pisses me
off and hopefully some of the things
that serve me well now let's talk about
the labels that are negative one of the
things one of the most pernicious acts
that exists negative bad stuff is when
we take the human experience that has
ups and downs that has extremes that
exist on continuums and we label one
side of the Continuum is bad and the
other side of the Continuum is good for
example happy sad
energized or weak tired right we have
equal opposites they're you know relaxed
stressed right there's lots of examples
of these the reason that this is so
dangerous when we give a positive or
negative label is that people think that
they have a problem when they are not
feeling happy or energized or relaxed or
clear-minded versus foggy you you know
what I mean whatever and the thing is is
in order for there to be light there
must be Darkness think about that for a
second in order for there to be good
there must also be bad one if you want
to admit the existence of one there must
also be the existence of the other right
awesome now the problem this is why we
have to be careful with labels that most
people suffer from is that they label
normal variations in The Human Condition
with negative experiences and so they
see themselves as tired and say this is
bad whereas it's really just part of the
human condition they see themselves as
sad rather than happy and see that as
bad and so what happens is you start to
upgrade a finite emotional condition
into a long-standing emotional
disturbance because you think it's a
problem and the thing is it's very easy
to sell people on why these things are
problems big Pharma is is the king of
this are you feeling tired stressed you
know are you hungry are you horny well
you are suffering from being a human
being it's being human and so I think a
lot of this and the reason that it wraps
into the original part of the prompt of
this video is that if we want to be
enduring entrepreneurs we want to be
people who have resilience we want to
people who have mental fortitude we must
be careful about the things that we
label and there's also the good bad
label which is the simplest label that a
lot of people ascribe to conditions that
are that are ephemeral right they're
they're brief right and then they change
but there's also the shoulds have must
need to
Etc that we say in our lives that we
have to do these things we must do these
things and if we do not or else we put
out a threat towards the universe if I
don't get my coffee I must get my coffee
I need to have coffee before I start my
day what happens is that we create these
implied threats to ourselves in the
universe if we don't then what your
decision-making process is ultimately
the most valuable thing valuable thing
that you have right it's what makes you
it's your picker right it makes you
decide what what way to go who you're
going to marry what business opportunity
you're going to pursue how you're going
to price how you're going to start
marketing what you're going to learn
first who you're going to you know get
mentoring from all of these things so
you're going to become friends with like
all of these are decisions right and
you know you can take the money away
from a billionaire and then they can
recreate it again Elon Musk you know
lost it and then gained it all back
right and so like the thing is is the
decision making is what ultimately fuels
all these things and the hardest part
about entrepreneurship and really I mean
I think almost life in general is that
you can make the right decision and have
the wrong outcome and I think and let me
give you a couple examples of this so
for example
um you may say you know what like I look
I listen to Warren Buffett I think he's
a good investor and so he says I
wouldn't I wouldn't touch Bitcoin right
and I hear that I'm like man well he
knows a little bit more about it than I
do but his argument was simple it is
speculative which means I'm buying it
not because it has intrinsic value but
only because I believe that someone else
will buy it for more later right that's
all it is he only believes in investing
in things that have intrinsic value and
also produce right so they actually have
production so like a business you buy
you still own the business at the end
and then it spits out production which
would be profit or crops or whatever
right
so that's the basic difference right and
so the thing is is that you can make the
right decision so for example I chose
not to buy Bitcoin two years ago or
whatever and now the amount of money
that it would have been worth is a lot
more was the decision wrong or was it
that the outcome
did not match the quality of the
decision and so let me explain let me
like unpack this
if you are going to change the way you
make decisions because a decision that
you made in the past that was probably a
good decision ended up bad you have to
apply the same decision making context
or framework to everything else all
right so let me explain so if I say I'm
now going to be a Speculator right I'm
going to be someone who buys things with
the hopes of selling them later for more
even though the thing itself doesn't
have more value right
if I choose to start making those types
of decisions then I have to think about
all the other Investments I would have
made and lost money on as a result of
that decision making framework and the
place that I heard this first was Ray
dalio in principle so he was he's one of
the richest men in the world uh investor
as well he said one of the hardest
things is passing up on an opportunity
and then seeing it you know do really
really well right he's like and but the
thing is is
I have to think to myself if I were to
use the decision making framework that
would have made that deal a winner then
I have to apply that same framework to
all of these other businesses or
situations that would have been losers
and my net net of having that different
decision making framework would
ultimately cause me to lose and so this
has been one of the most powerful
concepts for me as an entrepreneur
because what it does is it allows me to
separate the outcome from the quality of
the decision why was it that I did these
things right and I I can't even tell you
like so for example
you know actually I won't even give that
one but like their their decisions that
I made when I was younger
that ended up being you know poor later
but when I thought back about why I made
the decision I would make the same
decision today so it's not fair for me
to say well I wouldn't have made the
same call now but you can't use the
information that you have today to make
the decision that you would have made in
the past because then it means that you
were a different person because you're
not using information that you have
access to right and so claiming that
this decision that I did in the past
that didn't end up well you know working
out in my favor was the wrong call can
just be really poisonous and it may not
be true now if you make a mistake
because you had poor calculations and
you repeat the same mistake over and
over again then you should consider
looking at your decision making calculus
and see if you need to tweak some things
right but for me this has been one of
the hardest learned lessons and
emotionally one of the most trying
is looking at decisions I've made
looking at the outcome and being able to
separate was this a good decision
independent of the outcome and I'll wrap
this up with just a quick example to
show you if you had a perfect baseball
swing right you're just an amazing you
know batter right if someone gets up
there and they're the best batter in the
world and you strike out
is it because their swing is horrible is
it because they they don't have the
right decision making about how they
swing at pitches or how they pick the
pitches probably not he's probably
really good batter right because I just
said he's the best
but it still means he's going to strike
out and it still means he's gonna he's
gonna get out and hit pop flies and all
that kind of stuff but he's going to be
an amazing batter
with 300 you know a 350 average or
whatever it's still two out of three
times he's gonna strike out or basically
you know not get on base get out and so
when I think about that like you can be
the best at this thing and still only be
write a certain percentage of the time
right and so rather than that bad or
striking out once and saying I need to
change my swing and then getting back up
there and striking out again and be like
I need to change my swing and always
resetting the Baseline
instead being like I understand that if
I apply this swing to enough at-bats
quite literally I will get the
opportunity to knock it out of the park
and Me Knocking out of the park on one
of these right decisions will ultimately
outweigh the negatives of the wrongs
that I have done I think a lot of my
definitions have been defined by my
actions and so I am the person who has
done these things and I will do things
that will get me closer to the things
that I want to achieve
and so a lot of my definition of self
has always been based on evidence and so
I think it was harder for me in the
beginning because I didn't have evidence
to support what I hope to be true about
myself which at the time wasn't
and so and what did you hope to be true
that you could figure it out or was it
always a result that you Associated it
to I mean it was I want to make more
money than my dad you know I mean that
was that was the thing you know for me
and that was that was all I needed you
know what I mean I didn't I didn't have
there was I remember thinking
uh uh in college because I you know
you're young in college and it's like be
happy and all that stuff and I just
remember being like happiness and that
was like a moment for me I don't care
about happiness I want to do this
why didn't you care about happiness
that's very counterintuitive even now
super counterintuitive at that age yeah
um because I was obsessed with how not
happy I was and so so the things you
were doing that weren't designed to make
you happy that's what's weird so I was I
was so obsessed with like positive
psychology and I was reading all these
stuff and watching these TED Talks I
remember the whole I remember this whole
period of My Life
um and I was constantly assessing my
mood as a determination whether I was
happy or not it became so obsessive that
I was just like all of this that's all I
was like I'm just gonna do and hopefully
it works out and did you ever Define
what works out means if it isn't
happening be less be less unhappy I
would say was my my thought process it's
which is like I'm just gonna do the
things and so I shifted from a lot of
introspection internal mood regulation
and thinking and stuff and I think a lot
of the reason that I have the World
Views I have about you know emotions and
whatnot have come from this kind of
initial experience so it's like I had
that and then I just started working and
then I found myself
actually looking up after you know a
decent period of time you're like you
know I'm actually I haven't thought
about happiness in a long time
and
I think I might be
and so I also don't really like the word
happiness because it's circumstantial
versus Joy but like I experienced Joy
significantly more now than I did than
when I was younger and I think it's
partially because like you can be
mournful and enjoy but we'll have to say
like so like if someone imagine someone
like it's like an appreciation of The
Human Experience
like this is terrible but like even like
even in the suffering there's Beauty in
that you know what I mean because it's
purely human yeah and so I think it was
disconnected interesting that that it
matters to me as well but I've never had
to articulate it what what is the
connection to like The Human Experience
that is so
valuable that it's joyful even in
mourning I think it's just understanding
both sides of the coin I feel so like so
like if there's a few things that I
believe it is that is that like
I right now they're you know there's
things in my life that I don't like that
I wish were better and there are things
in my life that I really like and you
know 10 years ago it was the same way
and 10 years from now it'll be the same
way and when I die there will be stuff
that I will not have accomplished that I
will wish I had there will be things
that I wish I had done better that I
will not have done and there will be
things that I have done that I am proud
of and so like those things are not
going to change and so if
the only thing I mean this sounds I hope
and not overly tried but it's like all I
can do is just enjoy the game and it
took me a really long time to get there
like it took me a really long time to
get there um or at least it felt that
way or at least it felt like I suffered
a lot on that process
um which is why I have a heart for
people who are like dude I'm you know
I'm super sad I'm super depressed
whatever it is because I judge myself so
much on not being happy all the time
because I thought there was something
wrong with the fact that I wasn't happy
that I drove myself insane not being
happy rather than just being like you
know what maybe I'm just gonna do the
stuff and just happiness for a minute
and so I think it's like when we have
these uh like am I happy am I not happy
I think my my opinion is that you you
have to rise above it
so that you can just see you can feel
the Spectrum which is just being present
because I think again Alex's two cents
um have been around that long uh
if you are present you can you're
present like most people aren't present
ever and so it's like if I can just be
present even in my suffering I'm there
right then I can experience joy for
being human and having this experience
that I only get once and
the biggest frame shift that I've had in
terms of my experience of living has
been it's it sounds it sounds weird but
it's
so I'll call the grandfather frame which
is I learned how to become apathetic
right because that that took that took
me time to stop feeling pain the one
trait I see over and over again that is
clear to the people who are are winners
right the top one percent I'm not
talking top 10 but the top one percent
is the speed with which they execute
after making a decision one of the
definitions that like we talk about in
the community is that definition of
power as I understand it is the gap
between thoughts becoming reality and so
if you thought about an omnipotent being
right something someone who has
unlimited power as they think that thing
would be right and so if you were to
believe in a creator of some sort then
you might think as that Creator thought
the universe became right and so if you
think that as like the ultimate scale of
power then the closer we can get to that
the more powerful we become the more
potent we are as entrepreneurs and so I
see this so many times that it's it's
not even it's not even a oh like this is
associated with success like this is
what creates success because the gap
between where you decide something is a
good idea and when it actually occurs is
the loop with which you can improve your
business and so it's a lot like I can't
remember what the saying was but it's
it's not like how old the car is but
about how many miles are on it what I
mean by that is like We're Young right
but there's been a lot of a lot of
iterations that have happened from you
know when the business first started
when I started my first gym until now
and I think the key to that is the speed
of the ooda loop and that's that's just
like a military term like observe Orient
decide act and it's just the loop with
which that you can basically see what's
going on make a decision act on it and
then do that whole loop again right
because the faster you can pivot and
iterate the more responsive you are as
an entrepreneur the faster you can take
advantage of opportunities the faster
you can find out what failures are then
move on I want to talk about this within
the context of running a team and
employee and then also within yourself
and so from running your team right one
of the things that you know once once
you're moving out of you doing things
all the time there's how do I get other
people to do things and so that's why I
call this like end of week right is that
I one of the things one of my biggest
pet peeves is like yeah I can get you
that by end of week I'm like why don't
you just get it to me in an hour because
that's how long it takes and then all of
a sudden it's like oh it's like well I
have a meeting right then it's like is
it more important than this no okay well
then do it like if you think about how
you can run an organization like that if
you can get things done end of day right
rather than end of week you were
literally speeding up the organization
7x think about that and so when you're
thinking about deadlines and you're
thinking about expectations you as the
owner could set the extra you set the
Cadence people say hey can we do this
and then you're like cool let's start
right now
hone for how the organization is going
to move how quickly it's going to orient
how quickly thoughts become reality and
ultimately how powerful the organization
will become because of the speed right
and speed isn't doing things fast it's
basically just not being distracted by
others it doesn't matter it's being able
to prioritize and most people a lot of
the times aren't doing something that's
high priority right A lot of times
they're just doing nothing if you can
speed up that Loop and Force and and put
apply pressure to your team to not do
things by end of week or even end of day
it's like it's 10 a.m can you get this
done by noon uh okay and then you can
have that Loop happen three times within
a day rather than it taking three weeks
right because you've set that Cadence
from the beginning and then things get
done faster so I've been reading some
really interesting books lately and I
referred them out to
um a handful of entrepreneur friends
that I have that are all doing
five five to Fifteen million kind of in
that range and what was amazing to me is
that
every single one of them read the book
immediately sent me back their notes and
what they were going to do with it and
like and basically we're asking feedback
on on the angle that they were going to
take with it what's fascinating to me is
that if you look at if you look at lower
level entrepreneurs they and I'm not
saying in a negative way I'm just saying
in terms of just objective Revenue like
just they haven't achieved as much the
delay between being able to gain
information and access so much longer
and that's why they how where they want
to be it's kind of the same degree of
people who are like who pay for our
program and haven't gone through the
party I'm like what are you doing right
like what priority like what what
education do you have that is not
relevant to your business like you're
reading a motivational blog right now
when you have to translate that
motivation into a thought that you're
then going to quote test and then you
have to see how that test works and then
maybe it improves something rather than
just following the Playbook that has
already been tested and has already like
the the tree has been shook right and so
if you look at like Joey for example who
by by all definitions his Jim is the is
the number one gym within gym launch
right he had already finished everything
in Legacy by week eight his first eight
weeks he had already implemented every
single system in Legacy and so it's not
like it's not like he has more hours in
the day right it's not like his business
is different it's just that his level of
efficacy and execution was so high
because it allowed himself to get
distracted by things and the moment he
has something he needs to execute it
creates this itch inside of him that he
cannot he can't move forward without
executing this so that the relief comes
and if you can start to Foster that type
of behavior in yourself in those
attitudes about execution you will grow
faster and you will become more powerful
as an entrepreneur right if you think
about your competition who would you
fear right the competitor who sees what
you're doing can immediately execute
Implement and improve on it at a faster
Loop than you can even understand what's
going on right life and that's where
speed of first to Market and things like
that don't matter as much because if an
ex if a competitor can execute an out
oodaloo right can can speed that Loop up
faster they can iterate improve on it
faster than you can and then you have no
chance to catch up and so if you're
looking at your business look at it from
a context of speed of how long does it
take us to improve things how long from
understanding that our churn is high to
executing the five Horsemen how long did
that take we knew what the problem was
how long did it take for us to do and if
you can if you can if you can get real
with yourself about how many actual
hours it will take to do something and
then you look at your week and you think
okay what am I doing today that is more
important than this and where can I put
these two hours and start with the
moment that you make the decision and
then all of a sudden you'll be getting
things done that day that afternoon
rather than end of week end of month we
purposely delay these things because we
just procrastinate for no reason when
the the problem will not go away right
and so
that is why within Jamal speed is King
is one of the core tenants of the
business because you have to and the
tone has to start with you as the
entrepreneur like you have to apply that
pressure you have to say end of week why
like what are you doing today that's
more important than this right what are
you doing in the next two hours that's
more important than this tell me right
and a lot of times you'll get the answer
like well I guess I can do it now it's
like yeah then let's do it now let's get
it done right and that small change can
7x right if you even going from end of
week to end of day can 7x how quickly
your business grows because the
solutions that you need to implement to
solve the problems and break through the
bottlenecks happen today not in a week
not in a month and then the reaction to
the next thing that breaks the next
bottleneck in the business happens not
in a week not in a month but in a day
and then that's how quickly you can
pivot from where you are to where you
want to go because it's not one big
thing it's a million small turns that
will get you there anyways I hope I hope
anyone you know somebody found value in
this if you haven't employee or you're
managing your team and you want to
implement new things
start with today you need someone who
you can trust like if you're giving
someone your money like or you're trying
to take someone's advice or counsel you
need to trust their intentions all right
and so it's not just whether they have
integrity it's whether they have your
best interest in mind all right so I'm
going to get to how I solve for that in
a second but if that is the first
character trait of you need that you
need of a council of somebody of any
kind of council really whether it's
investment law Etc the second is
efficacy or their skill set right so
let's think of both let's think of just
different scenarios here so let's say
you might trust your mom implicitly but
she doesn't have the skill of knowing
much about you know how to structure
insurance policies or trusts or you know
investments in Tech startups right you
might not have that skill but you might
trust her intention right for you
specifically on the reverse of that you
might see that there's this person who's
got lots of skill is prodigious in this
but it also means that they know exactly
how to screw you if they want to right
which is one of the double-sided things
of being really good at something right
you know all the details you know how to
write the agreement structure the deals
in order to make sure that you you know
get the best outcome right and so the
idea is to find someone who has both
your best interests at heart and has the
ability to deliver on what you want
right and so it's both of these things
and so you're like well yeah maybe that
seems obvious for me just even boiling
it down to that was very helpful for me
because when I look and I look through
advisors look for people I want to get
counselor from I have to look at these
two things all right so here's how I
test for the Integrity piece and here's
how you can kind of like you can control
for risk here right one is I always try
and interview as many advisors as
humanly possible all right and I do that
because I'm going to get as much
information from each of the council
during this process that will give me
perspective from which to make a
judgment right one of the biggest
problems with this like if you think
about Julie who's trying to lose weight
right she goes to the gym and then she
talks to 10 personal trainers one
personal trainer says it's all about
high fat low carb another guy says hey
don't worry about that keto stuff it's
all about high carb low fat and then
another guy says no you really just need
a balanced thing and another guy says
it's only about calories it's only about
counting your Macros and so you get this
huge perspective so that hopefully you
can make a judgment call otherwise when
you talk to the first guy and he says
it's all about keto then you're like
well I guess this is it right I guess
these guys all have opinions when in
reality there is a truth you just don't
have the perspective in which to make a
judgment yet and so the first step in
this is that I interview as many as I
possibly can from reputable sources so
this is where I reach out to my network
I make posts Etc to try and get as many
referrals as I can alright so that's
step one step two for the integrity is
that I try and have a line incentives
now a lot of times there are incentive
systems that appear aligned but not are
not in reality so let me give you an
example so in the real estate market if
you're a realtor for example you may
think oh this realtor has my best
interest at heart right because they
have an incentive to sell the house and
so that is why they're going to get
compensated so they want to sell it for
as much as possible ah but they aren't
incentivized to sell it for as much as
possible they're incentivized to sell as
fast as possible and get a deal closed
all right and so think about this for
you selling a house for 500 000 that's
worth five hundred thousand dollars is a
normal you know that like that's normal
that's the market price right but for
you to make an extra let's say twenty
five thousand or fifty thousand dollars
would be really material that would be a
huge extra outcome for you you would
probably push a lot harder to get the
extra 25 or 50 000 now let's say that um
you could probably sell it in a day at
four hundred and fifty thousand dollars
because it's below the market value of
the house right now here's what's crazy
is that if a a selling realtor you know
like total it might be seven percent two
percent goes to the buyer and five
percent goes to the seller if five
percent is going to your realtor five
percent of five hundred thousand dollars
right is 25 Grand okay and so for them
the the fifty thousand dollar decrease
to drop you from 500 to 450 means that
they're going to give up 2500 so they're
gonna make twenty two thousand five
hundred so let me ask you a question now
the reverse if they sell for 5.25
they're gonna get twenty seven thousand
five hundred right and so it's a five
thousand dollar swing off of a you know
twenty five thousand dollar nut for them
and one of them might take them three
months and one of them might take them a
day so what is their incentive
their incentive is to get is to is to
make as much money as possible per unit
of time and so they're incentivized to
sell as fast as possible and so this is
one of those things where you have to
put your thinking cap on and say are our
incentives truly aligned and so when
we're looking at this when I say there's
two aspects that I look for counselor or
somebody who's going to help me do
something financially legally Insurance
wise whatever it is so first is that
Integrity piece and are there incentives
aligned the incentives being aligned and
you could restructure that deal and say
hey you know what you're going to get
zero percent on anything below 400 000
I'll give you three percent on anything
between 400 and 450 and then from 450
and up I'll give you 20 right or 15 or
whatever right and so now they're highly
incentivized to push and now your
incentives are aligned because each
increment for you is worth almost as
much it is to them and that is how you
would align incentives all right now how
do you test for the second thing which
is their skill set this one's hard all
right especially if you don't have their
perspective from which to make a
judgment which when I enter new things
when I'm trying to learn about trust and
I'm trying to learn about investment
things and different Vehicles I'm
learning about storage units more about
multi like you're like oh man there's so
much stuff and there's so much Nuance
that you have to have right and so the
first thing is I like to usually read
two to three books on the topic all
right and I read two to three books just
so I don't appear like an idiot
um and so I can at least understand what
they're saying and they're gonna respect
you to they will it's kind of like
defense if you bring your if you bring
at least some level of knowledge they
don't feel like they're going to take
advantage of you so this is this is the
first thing that I do and this is
because I don't like feeling exposed in
these types of conversations the second
thing you can do is if you have someone
that you can trust you can bring them in
alongside you and the third thing that
you can do which is probably the the
most and highest recommended is
repeating the same action I said in the
first hand which is try and talk as to
as many of them as possible and then you
will gather the insights and you'll see
the people who demonstrate the most
expertise and what you can do is take
what one person says and say well what
about this and see what they reply with
right and as you gain more and more
knowledge and this is how you so in the
Consulting world this is qualitative
research right this is where you're
literally doing interviews essentially
to gather information so that you can
make an informed decision right and so
when you do these interviews and this is
what this is the lazy part this is what
most people don't do is they won't do
this work right they won't take the time
to interview 20 people or 10 people when
in reality these one decisions the guy
who you decide to you know invest in in
their fund or if you decide to buy this
building or invest in a fund that buys X
Y and Z right or you'd or you have
somebody who manages your portfolio
whatever it is right that one decision
can be one of the most if not the
biggest influence on your total net
worth over a long period of time and
people take more time to figure out what
they want to where they want to go on
vacation than where they're going to put
their money right and so my ask to you
is that if you if you put these put
these lenses on think about both of
these lenses lens one do I think this
person is Integris do I think this
person has my best interest at heart and
then two do they have the skill to
deliver on that promise because I don't
want my mom doing my investments I know
she has my best at heart but she has no
idea what she's doing and then I don't
want somebody who absolutely knows what
they're doing and does not have my best
interest at heart right which honestly
unfortunately is a lot more of the cases
that you'll come up with and candidly
you know a lot of times they're
literally incentivized against you you
know uh in in the insurance industry
they're they're kind of incentivized to
rip you off it's it's it's pretty
terrible and there's a lot of Industries
like that mortgage brokers are
incentivized to rip you off and so you
really have to look at it from both
lenses and these types of decisions can
make the biggest impact on your net
worth and your financial future simply
based on who you decide to work with
when I started in this business I took
every single sale and it was because I
was so afraid that somebody would waste
the opportunity so if you have that fear
I understand where you're coming from
second when I had my first sale that was
not me I I just had this emotional
breakdown so I was like oh my God this
could actually happen and I promise you
if you haven't had it happen yet you
will when it does because you realize
that this business can actually work
without you and other people can make it
rain too right and then I'll tell you a
quick story that'll illustrate the next
point that would make so as I you know
hired some sales people now that first
sales person were they exceptional no
but they were able to get the job done
later on I I had my first kind of like
killer
um and his name was Mario negretti and
he uh he came in
I don't know a year or two into the
business a year into the business and he
so quickly was able to assume the sales
role and to show you how laughable this
is he started and I was about to start
training him and some lady walked in the
door and I was like hey man like I can
take you he's like no I'm good he's like
go do your thing he's like Fitness
Nutrition accountability okay I'll
figure it out and he ended up closing
this first lady who walked in the door
for a paid in full and I remember
walking in like completely dumbstruck I
was like he didn't even know what the
pitch was but she walked out giggling
happy so excited to start and would that
moment taught me was that
it is good to train sales people but
it's better to take great sales people
and then just point them in a direction
and so this has informed a lot of the
thinking that I have Around Talent in
general and I'll tell you a couple of
Frameworks that have informed this but
like if you look at Harvard Harvard
doesn't produce the smartest people they
select the smartest people and then they
put smart uh professors in front of them
but like the base level of intelligence
of everyone who's at Harvard is already
exceptionally high and so like even if
the teachers at Harvard were not
exceptional the students are and they
would be successful independent of that
because their selection is so ridiculous
right and so if we can think about our
own companies that way and especially if
you're in the service business like look
at the biggest service companies out
there like look at McKinsey look at Bain
look at BCG look at basically a lot of
the finance world is or service-based
businesses a lot of times right and
they're able to do that because they
create such a pool to select from that
they are able to skim for the best
talent right I heard this uh quote from
Esther Kathy who's the founder of
Chick-fil-A you win the championship in
the draft and so it was such a belief
that they had about picking the right
people even more so than training and I
would say that I have moved in that
direction of a little bit more nature
than nurture when it comes to roles
specifically sales especially there are
certain characteristics about building
Rapport about having certain you know
Dynamics or energy whatever you want to
say that like Mario negrady when he
walked in he had all of these things and
he didn't even know the pitch but he won
that sale off of Just Pure Rapport and
so if I'm going to allocate the same
level of time to training somebody I
might as well start with somebody who
has a much higher base because I could
spend 10 hours to take someone from a
two to a four and a half or I could
spend the same 10 hours taking someone
from a six to a nine and the thing is
I'm also going to get more bang for my
buck in terms of my hours of training
with somebody who has natched a natural
somebody for selling compared to
somebody who does not what's interesting
about this and this is just like my
observation is that you just have to be
willing to talk to more people in the
recruiting process I will say like from
a recruiting standpoint there's there's
two kind of things to look out for if
you're if you're if you cannot pay super
handsomely based on your price points
which you need to maybe fix later but
like if you can't pay super well for the
sales person then you need to look
harder and you'll need to interview more
people and you'll need to probably run
ads and use your network if you can pay
well the best sales people are already
employed and so it comes down to
recruiting those sales people from other
sales jobs ideally from companies just
like yours so that they already know a
lot of the things coming into it so it
decreases the ramp up time for them
because all we were really doing is
swapping products and the actual sales
cycle the type of sale is it a
transactional sales and a long sales at
a software sales is it a coaching
program set whatever it is right there's
so few variables that were changing that
they can immediately Jump and Go which
also allows you to make a judgment on
their proficient you faster and so as a
quick side note to this because this is
something that I've given a lot of
thought if you look at the top sales
people and sales trainers and this is
going to drive Point Drive home the
point that I was making earlier about it
being much of it being born all right is
that if you look at the top people who
are in the space you look at Jordan
Belfort right you look at Bradley you
look at and some people would would say
me in term from a selling perspective
all the guys that I know who have taught
sales were exceptional sales people day
one Bradley started selling cars when he
was 18 years old was the top salesman at
18 years old when he started and he was
like I just found something I was really
good at Jordan Belfort talks about how
he didn't know how to train anybody in
his book and then all of a sudden he for
the first time ever wrote out a
framework to explain the straight line
sale system which became his book and
all that kind of stuff but he up to that
point it was just what he naturally did
right and I can tell you in my instance
as well I'd already closed thousands of
deals before I even consumed my first
sales training and so like I I do think
that if we are selecting sales people I
think it's much more about selection
than it is about training the training
is to remind them how good they are not
necessarily to make them good all right
and this is something that has shifted
over time for me specifically now if
you're like well I suck at sales you can
absolutely put way more time into
yourself than a business would recently
put into an employee all right like you
have you all the time so you can train
you in all your off hours and you're
spending your own time to invest in
yourself but from a return on investment
perspective it's the cost of finding a
good salesperson compared to the cost of
training a bad or mediocre sales person
is significantly lower it's much easier
to find the right people than it is to
take somebody and then make such a crazy
extensive training unless your entire
model is we just take on every single
person who walks in the door like 24
Hour Fitness has this model they take on
anybody who has a pulse and then they
put them through a ridiculous culling
process and then 10 of people make it in
the first 90 days a lot of people I
would say mistakenly think that the
number one resource is time
right everyone's like time is money time
is money time is money
and I would argue that that's not
necessarily true I would argue that
attention is money that is the golden
resource so the billionaire friend that
I have he's actually been helping me on
um the new Endeavor that we are
launching to our gym alerts uh soon
which I think will change the industry
anyways he's been helping me with that
stuff but like here's an example on his
phone his phone does not ring unless you
are already a contact that has been
whitelisted his phone doesn't ring it's
he's impossible to reach the more
successful the more the the larger your
company grows the more you scale the
more you need to scale the only way to
scale you is because you don't have a
finite amount of attention and so what
happens is you have to decrease all of
the other things in your life that drain
attention because you can have as much
time as you want but if you're not there
you're not potent you're not able then
you can't get anything done with that
time that you're supposedly allocated
which is why a lot of people end up in
this in between state of always
everywhere and at the same time nowhere
right and so they're they're everywhere
but they're not paying attention to
anything and that's and the reason that
it's difficult to focus is because
entrepreneurs the character trait that
made us into entrepreneurs is that we're
go-getters we're we're risk averse we're
creators we're innovators we're Builders
right we have all of those traits but
the difficulty is is that the thing that
gets you from zero to one is not the
thing that gets you from one to two
right and so one of the the reason that
you have to totally morph and why you
have to be a growth oriented individual
is because you have to change your own
individual character traits in order to
progress as a business owner and so like
I said the things that got you here are
not the things that are going to get you
there the things that got you here which
is your own internal skills are not the
things that you need to pass on to other
people so the only way that you were
able to grow your business at a certain
point is by growing other people right
and the only way you can do that is if
you have the attention and the bandwidth
in order to do so and that's why if you
look at a business owner and like the
more I obsess on looking at billionaires
and people who are doing better than we
are is I look at how quiet and how clean
they keep their space and I mean that
both in a literal sense that like their
surroundings their office their house
their homes their cell phone their
computers right there it's it's it's
quiet right everything like it's it's
pristine and when you talk to these
people there's a certain amount of of
Tranquility that's there and
and they just they just have very low
tolerance and it's not that they're
trying to be impatient with you or I'm
patient with the world it's just that
they understand that they have so like
they're they're operating at such a high
level that there's so many things that
are demanding of their time and
attention that they just like they can't
and so they have to forcibly remove
themselves from so many different
situations and I'm going to give you an
example so one of the people that I'm
I'm someone mentoring right they had
they had four businesses and this is
something that happens so many times it
lit like like you want you want a
hundred thousand dollar coaching this is
what happens in 100 000 coaching
questions and I'm being honest with you
what happens is someone who's coming in
usually doing between one and three
million dollars a year
um can't get past a certain point right
and the reason they can't get past this
because they only have so much attention
and if it's spread between four or five
different case that's when the gym owner
has four gyms and is making less money
than they did when they had one gym
because the amount of attention that
they can allocate to one facility has
gone down so much that with fixed costs
they basically are breaking even right
and so the same thing happens now that
entrepreneur is probably making one to
three million in gross revenue but not
taking anything home because they don't
have the attention to actually put onto
things and so in order to grow you need
to do less
in order to grow you need to do less and
that comes from both delegation and also
choosing what not to do the better you
get the better the opportunities that
you have to say no to imagine the level
of opportunities that we have now I'm
just being honest so imagine how many
things we could do or trying JV with or
do a partnership with or whatever
because of the distribution Network that
we have and the trust and the Goodwill
that we have with the gym owners that we
have in our Network right a lot I get I
you know how many people cold message me
like I have an opportunity for you I'm
like really you have an opportunity for
me and so the better you get the better
your opportunities you have to say no to
which is why becoming a higher and
higher and higher level entrepreneur is
more and more difficult because it
requires discipline
it's not about doing more it's about
doing less because we innately want to
do more so doing more of your own
internal characteristic if that was what
it took to get to be more successful
then everyone would be more successful
because it would be something that does
not take effort because that is
something that we already do it's like
man I outwork anyone I've got all this
work with it cool that gets you from
zero to one
it's not going to get you any further
than that so stop identifying with that
it was something that I used to identify
with I was like I'll I'll outwork anyone
or whatever like that was something that
I used to think about and it was a
character trade it was an identity thing
and the more you grow the more you
realize that your identity needs to be
fluid because what it needs to be is
exactly what it needs to be at that
given time of development because the
character traits that I'm going to have
to emphasize in a year are going to be
different than the ones that I have to
emphasize now the skills that you need
to learn like delegation leadership
those are things that are not the things
that take you in the beginning you have
to be independent you have to be
hustling you have to be grinding you
have to be willing to put in the work
because no one else will do it for you
especially if you have no Capital to
start which most of the people who are
on here are in that situation to reel
this back in the number one thing that
you have to be paying attention to is
where you are paying your attention
right like you spend attention that's
why they call it paying attention it's
because it is a resource and most people
don't pay attention to that right and so
one of the things that a lot of people
don't know about I mean this one's going
to go along
um
some of the things that a lot of people
don't know about me is that I for nine
months paid a coach to teach me one
thing which was to manage my attention
was to teach me how to think and so for
90 minutes every single day all I did
was talk about what I was thinking about
think about that
every day I paid attention to where my
attention was
and when I did that all of a sudden my
business blew up right and I realized
that I had toxic relationships I had
toxic relationships with parents I had
toxic relationships with friends or
pseudo friends things that I that were
taking my attention past things that I
had on my mind that I knew I had not
handled so those are called like open
Loops or open Cycles right so when you
have something that you like I haven't
resolved this then you need to handle
that and you'll get that attention back
because what happens is you have this
bowl this tiny little bowl of marbles
that each of those marbles is is a unit
of attention right if you had to measure
it and so you put little marbles of
attention on your childhood traumas you
put little marbles of attention on your
marriage you put little uh marbles of
attention on your health you put little
marvelous attention on your spirituality
and then massive marbles of attention on
your business but the thing is is that
sometimes you need to quiet and collect
all of these other little marbles so
that you have more potency more
potential energy more potential units of
attention to spend on on the one thing
that you're trying to grow which in this
case would be your business and what's
interesting is that what happens is that
things that were perceived as difficult
become really easy and I don't know if
you've ever had this happen but like if
you were in college or you were in high
school and you were like man I can't
solve this problem this math problem and
you were exhausted then you go to bed
then you wake up the next morning and
then all of a sudden it seems really
easy you're like I don't know why I
didn't see that before because attention
gives you the ability to see
right like if you're if you think about
wisdom right wisdom is an ability to see
what other people cannot see right two
people are presenting the same situation
the wiser person sees things that the
other person doesn't and how can you see
better you see better if you have more
ability to see which comes from your
most valuable resource attention how
much horsepower do you have and so look
at the things that you have in your in
your life right now like if I see
someone who has a messy relationship
life who's got a messy love life who
goes out every weekend and gets trashed
right like I can tell you billionaires
don't do that that like the whole Tony
Stark like vision of the entrepreneur is
a farce it's not true don't believe that
every single billionaire every single
high-level entrepreneur is quiet
unbelievably quiet they keep themselves
completely isolated they have a bubble
around them of of layers of protection
they're like like for me it's it's me
and then there's Layla and then we have
our CEO and then we have our executive
assistant team because we have a team of
EAS at this point we have four
um who work the next level there's no
one who has direct access to me
including our employees no one does
and that's because it's it would
disserve you you guys our gym owners if
everyone had access to me the reason
that I don't respond to Facebook
messages is not because I don't want to
it's because I literally can't and if I
did I would be disturbing everyone
because then my attention would be split
because someone can't generate leads in
their mind or whatever you know what I
mean like because these little things
these little things that are perceived
as huge issues to you in that moment
because you have a little bit of
attention you you have so little left
that everything seems like an explosion
but when you have lots of capacity big
problem seem small and small problems
seem big and it sounds reverse because
what you do is you start seeing that all
of these things are attention drains and
you just say I don't want to play
anymore
then you stop playing I would say there
are days that I feel like less energized
or things like that for sure not about
like the big picture of like I don't
believe that this cause is not worthy
but I do think a lot of people have that
too where they're like what I'm doing is
meaningless right and then I get into I
think everything's meaningless and then
we can just create whatever meaning you
know we choose to because if we don't
believe in a capital M meaning which a
lot of people disagree with that's fine
but if you don't believe in a capital N
meaning I think that's very freeing
because then you can create Little M
meaning for whatever you want and so if
you believe you can then choose to
architect your own life in whatever ways
that you deem meaningful and make the
activities you do aligned with that
meeting the difference between capital M
meaning and Little M meaning and this is
kind of like the basis of nihilism which
people have like a very negative
Viewpoint around which I'm not entirely
sure about why but like capital and
meeting means that like this is the
meaning of life period like for everyone
this is the meaning of life whereas if
we say that there is no single agreed
upon meaning of life and then people say
well then that is your big meaning of
life and I'm like yes you're right I
believe that there is no meaning that is
the meaning that I that I believe and
they're like well then that is the
capital then sure that's my capital A
meaning is that there is no meaning
what's the implication of that it means
now that we have meaning making machines
in our brain and so we get to create and
Destroy meaning as we see fit and so if
we choose an activity and we deem that
goal meaningful because we think it's
more interesting or it energizes us then
we can ascribe meaning to that and do
more of it and what's nice about not
having capital M meaning is that that
can shift right that might be good for a
season and then it can shift I will say
that the downside of not having capital
M meaning which I consider to be
religion off the shelf is that it's more
difficult because you have no one who's
saying here's the big box of rules you
can read it and then that way you don't
have to make the decisions about it but
I think it's more difficult but and
ultimately more rewarding if you have
reasoning behind why you believe what
you believe because then you have to
independently come up with your own
conclusions about those things it also
makes it malleable so that if you get
new data or new evidence then you can
change your mind which a lot of people
again have difficulty with but like if
you change the information then it would
make sense that if it materially changes
the outcome that the way that you
believe about something should change
and I think a lot of people will
identify with their beliefs as a part of
themselves rather than as what I prefer
to call them which is assumptions
because they work the same way what's
the difference in belief and assumption
not a lot right the only difference is
just what we call the word and so
assumptions are based on things that
we've observed and then we assume
something as a result and so I would say
that beliefs are just assumptions and
but when you call them that they become
less tied to your identity if you have
an assumption you don't say you
challenged my assumption it's like well
yeah I challenge my assumption Ah that's
great I I was assuming this it must be
this and then they become much more
flexible and then we don't tie our egos
into them and I think ultimately it
serves more people better in the long
run I've said this quote many times in
our communities and on this channel
which is you must outwork yourself down
right if you feel like you are not
confident then you must outwork the
things that you're insecure about if
you're like man I'm selling these
services and I'm not sure I'm not sure
if I'm that good at them then do more of
them and don't pretend honesty is one of
the most compelling and convicting
things for persuading people right
saying what you are good at and what you
are not good at truthfully will we knew
far more followers and fans and and
loyal customers and loyal employees than
pretending because the end of the day
they can feel that you are disingenuous
because they know that is hollow they
know on the inside you do not believe
the words that are coming out of your
mouth and that is how people speak
without conviction and they cannot sway
others because they have not swayed
themselves because they have lost their
own respect and so I am not the believer
in buying the Ferrari when you can't
afford it I am not the believer in in
affording the home and paying for the
home
that you cannot afford because you want
to pretend like this is the lifestyle
that you want to be around if you go
into the guise of networking you can
still go to those places without buying
a four million dollar house when you
you're barely making you know a few
hundred thousand dollars it doesn't make
sense I like Jay-Z's quote around this
which is if you can't buy something
twice don't buy it once I really like
that and so
this is one of the most common questions
I get for newer entrepreneurs because
they think that they have to they have
to they have to pose on Instagram in
order to get to get wealthy and what it
does is it conflates sequence Jeff Bezos
is famous because of what he did not
because he became famous as Jeff Bezos
and then used his following to build
something Elon Musk is famous for what
he's accomplished not for being Elon
Musk and then creating something as a
result right let the actions be the
thing that gives you the fame rather
than yourself right at least that is
that is Alex's two cents in my viewpoint
on the world and I think most of Mosey
Nation you guys share that belief with
me and for those of you who are new to
this channel you're going to get more of
this type of stuff uh and none of the
fake until you make it nonsense that is
a sure way uh to be broke and I will
tell you this as a last thing
the amount of people who in 2008 when
everything crashed who were faking it
until they quote made it
just faked it until they lost it all
because they lost what little amount
that they had because they were so
overextended but I can tell you that
just about everyone can become wealthy
if you choose to live on Lower unless
than you make right and that is a ratio
wealth is a ratio not a number all right
and so anywho if you are having
struggles with this question I would
pause it I would I would beg of you that
you build your own respect first that
you're honest with yourself first and if
you always maintain the Integrity of hey
last year we we got smashed right this
year we'll do a little bit better and
two years from now when you do even
better than that you can be truthful and
people will believe you but if you
always are telling a story about how
you're always doing so well hey everyone
will hate you B no one cares and C you
will know that you are full of it and at
the end of the day I think that is the
only thing that we're going to keep with
us and when we die everyone's going to
forget about us anyways so you might as
well at least enjoy yourself while
you're alive we have these people that
we collect you know throughout our lives
and sometimes that come in you know
you've probably heard the saying they're
here for a season or reason or a
lifetime and I think you know for me a
lot of people have been seasonal and so
I wanted to share that because I know
that I mean I'm sure some of you have
had a similar path to me and that I
didn't have a tremendous amount of
support from my parents I think they now
retroactively think they supported me
because it's much easier you're that way
but I did not I did not have any support
from my parents for the decisions that I
took until it was already Beyond obvious
that I was going to be successful and
that took years and that was very hard
for me at the time I think friends fell
in that same category and so when I was
having this discussion with Dean we we
dove into this a little bit more but as
we you know Ascend towards our goals and
I don't say Ascend in a literal sense in
terms of like socioeconomic status or
whatever but just like we moved closer
towards we want to where we want to go
and our vision and our mission in our
lives become clear it also becomes clear
when you have contrast with people from
your past and I have several rules of
thumb that are I begin to develop around
these relationships one of them is if I
could only talk about the past with
someone they usually aren't good friends
of mine because I don't really live in
the past I live in the future I live in
where I want to go what I want to do the
things that I find interesting or the
present of the things that I find
interesting today or right now top of
mind and if I can't talk about those
things with somebody then our friendship
kind of by its very nature will decline
over time time because there's no growth
right because it's only in the past and
I have felt a tremendous amount of guilt
around the loss of those relationships
but I also felt a guilt of carrying them
on as in I felt like I needed to water
these plants out of necessity rather
than out of you know some sort of
exchange now some people might decry
that or speak against the idea of having
an exchange but I don't think that's
realistic I think that people stay in
relationships because there is an
exchange of value that occurs now I
think the difference is the strength or
depth of the relationship is how long
you are willing to wait for the exchange
to occur so a parent for example is
willing to wait a very long time for a
positive exchange from a child coming
back to them right now and some people
could make the argument that you know
children are a gift throughout that
entire period of time and that's awesome
and that's a perspective whatever but
just to use the time frame as a nice
thinking process if you just met someone
if you don't feel like there's you know
a huge benefit to to to knowing them uh
you know within the immediate future you
probably don't really pursue them out
and the longer you have had positive
changes the longer you are willing to
wait for the next one right it's it's
intermittent reinforcement from a
behavior standpoint right like we are
literally reinforced in this
relationship and the way that addiction
works is the same thing right like you
immediately get Positive Hits and then
you can start extending how long before
you get another positive hit which is
also how abusive relationships work
right like abuse abuse positive abuse
positive positive positive and then like
abuse and then positives a little bit
later and then a little bit later until
the point where there's almost no
positive whatsoever I'm not saying
that's how you should run relationships
but more so how we work as humans the
point of me breaking this down is that I
have lost a lot of the friends or almost
all of the friends that I had uh when I
started my journey and the upside is
people will come into your life to fill
the vacuum that the other people left
but sometimes it doesn't happen
immediately and I think getting
comfortable with having space is a good
thing and a lot of people have the
impulse or urge to always have people
around them and I think it's to their
own detriment because I think if you can
spend time alone with your your thoughts
and be okay with just being you without
other people then you are more selective
and it's the same way with dating some
people can't be alone some people can't
be without a significant other and so
they just end up shacking up with the
first person they see after they become
single again right and it's because they
have a fear of being alone more than
they hold a they have an aligned Mission
with someone that they think that this
person is really the best pick and so a
lot of ways are similar to dating with
friends in that we can hold out uh and
really just pick the best people and I
think that you know if we at least for
me if I have two or three good friends
I'm I'm more than satisfied my cup is
very full but I think where I feel
drained is where I feel like I have lots
and lots and lots of acquaintances that
are transactional in nature but purely
transactional or at least they have a
much shorter time Horizon for the
transactions to occur and so I sell this
to say if you have lost friends during
the process of the climb I don't think
it is something that you should lament
or be upset about I think that it is a
sign of growth because a lot of people
say hey you've changed and the only
natural response that I can have to that
is
you have it and I think that that's kind
of sums up the entirety of this of this
video which is if you grow you change
some people most people don't like
change especially if they themselves
have not grown or changed and or if they
have grown in a different direction from
you and it is natural for us to not want
to continue relationships with people
that have grown or have values that are
too far in contrast to our own and those
contract those values can change over
time and that's okay I feel passionately
about my viewpoint of the world mostly
because I struggled and I was in so much
pain for such a long period of time I'm
only sharing this despite the fact that
I get attacked for sharing this because
there are people who this does resonate
with but when there is no required
meaning then a lot of language changes
which is should must need have to like
all of these things no longer exist
because there is no capital M meaning so
I don't should have to must need to
anything and so a lot of the expat that
we bury ourselves into that weigh us
down are just implied shoulds have to's
musts and so if all of those disappeared
then in a lot of ways it's very
liberating and so for me in business it
allows me to take actions even though I
know that I shouldn't or must not or
other people would judge me for not
doing it the way that they thought I
should do it because there are no rules
which is why that was the preface to the
book it's like there are no rules we can
live our life whatever way we want to
live it
and that's okay
I read a YouTube comment the other day
it's like hey you know you talk a lot
about being sad and like how have you
been able to X Y and Z and I don't
identify with being a sad person I think
I I have been sad in the past but I also
don't think that there's a problem with
being sad
and so
I think that there's just so much power
and acceptance It's like so many people
make themselves miserable because they
think that they shouldn't be who they
are and they shouldn't feel how they
feel and so much of the medication that
gets prescribed right now is because
someone's like oh I'm anxious and why do
we feel like someone shouldn't be
anxious they are human why do we feel
like we shouldn't feel sad we are human
why do we feel like we shouldn't feel
frustrated or angry we are human and so
I think it's one of the most like
interesting things or phenomena where if
you have a line which is the normal
human existence and you have points
above the line and points below the line
you have the median right or you have
the the middle point and people want to
not feel the things below the line and
then we ascribe or label the things
below the line is bad and things above
the line is good when all of it is and
so I think that if we just accept that
and accept ourselves and accept the
feelings that we experience as things
that we experience like rain and weather
and sunshine it's not like rain is bad
not like Sunshine's good it just is I
like happiness is good or happiness is
bad or sadness is bad or sadness is good
we just label it that way and I think
the labels create more suffering than
anything that we ever experience I love
the saying you know in our 20s we're
concerned about what everyone thinks
about us in our 40s we don't care what
anyone thinks about us and in our 60s we
realize that no one was thinking about
us to begin with right and I just I just
feel like that's I mean who else have
you thought about today besides yourself
probably not I mean you have your kids
which is an extension yourself but you
know what I mean like yeah not a lot and
so most people are like that and you
know
a lot of like we have a lot more leeway
than I think we give ourselves credit
for and I think the more that I have now
you know I'll say accomplished with
quotes in in material success the more I
am excited about the things that I can
do and that was why the opening of the
book was like there are no rules and it
just took me a very long time to realize
that and I continue to unlearn rules
that I thought existed you know as I
continue to you know go on this journey
yeah I love that idea of unlearning I
think we all just try and go back to
being like we were when we were children
just because when you're a child you're
purely present you're just present in
the moment and I I don't like the word
happy very much I prefer using Joy
because you can be you can mourn
joyfully right because it's it's a it's
a it's internal rather than happiness
which I feel is more like happenstance
it's more from external and so
um you know one of the things that bring
me joy were the things that I find you
know to find joy in
um and I think for anyone who's who's
listening it's a much harder question to
answer what are the things that bring me
joy than answering the question what are
the things I hate
and it's easier to correct those first
be like well I hate my job and I hate my
relationship and I hate the city okay
those are all very changeable and a lot
of times you get there by by inversion
well if I wanted to destroy my life I
wanted to have the worst life possible
what would I do and then taking all
those things that you would do to really
destroy your life and make your life
miserable and then reverse them it's a
much easier way to solve the positive
psychology equation in my opinion so
when you're sad do you try to not be
said no I actually don't think about it
much I think a lot of people spend a lot
of time and effort trying to figure out
how they feel because they want to then
judge or label themselves as I'm doing
well or not well like a lot of effort
goes into showing like how do I feel
about this I mean my follow-up question
be like why do you care why does it
matter and that's why when you ask way
longer about like how much do you think
feelings matter I don't think they
matter at all
like what would the case for feelings
mattering be then why do you believe
they exist it's a good question and it
gets really interesting because it's
like how I experience a feeling that I
label in my head as sadness is it the
same way you experience the thing that
you let it's like seeing green and I see
green and you see green what if all of
our greens are different right I mean
it's it gets very interesting like that
but I think that I experienced something
and if we were to just measure it based
on like brain activity and like heart
rate I would say that I become aroused
in the literal sense uh from
experiencing what I would deem as
emotions and so if we were to describe
it or Define the term in that way I
think I experience emotions and so I
mean I'm fairly confident I experience
emotions if we were to try and measure
it that way then that's how I would say
yes I do experience them but the
question is just like how important are
they and then it would be like for what
if it's for accomplishment not very
important for Fitness not very important
you know if if we're saying how
important is emotion for love which is
another emotion right it becomes like
amorphous trying to go to amorphous but
then you say okay well for defining Love
by AI what I'm willing to endure to
continue to keep something then how
important is it well it depends on how
much I've conditioned myself to accept
this thing so like if I want to stay
married it's probably far more effective
to condition someone to stay married
because that is the external consequence
of a good marriage as you stay together
right I'm just saying like we're just
purely measuring from out from external
circumstances and so I think trying to
measure and Define things is what I
actually geek out on and I really enjoy
I think most people get bored of Tears
when I talk about this stuff so I don't
talk about it much but that's the stuff
that like um when when we keep peeling
back layers of like why do you think
you're able to get out of you know a
difficult place in your life or why do
you think you're able to go through
these things a lot of it is because I
believe that I will redefine terms and
so we'll have some instance or something
that I should do and I will redefine it
or I'll say I I don't should I can just
accept it and that's why the biggest
refrain that I have in my head for like
my own mental illness is just like and
that's okay period
like I don't want to go to that thing
that's okay mortality has been the
single biggest driver and the biggest
decisions that I've made in my life and
it has become a more routine
process for decision making for me in
general because I think it it provides
Clarity and it provides context to most
of the decisions we have which the vast
majority of them don't matter which is
helpful in and of themselves and then
you know beyond that it helps me make
the decisions that I think removes
everyone else from The Playbook because
if you if you study subjective
well-being and how people perceive how
they're doing in their own lives it
looks like a smiley face so
seven-year-olds think they're killing
life and then it drops dramatically
between 20 and 30 and then there's still
a little bit more of a dip right around
45 that's like when people are their
true they hate life the most and then
and then it kind of slowly goes up to
like 55.60 and then it shoots right back
up again when people see that they're
going to die and that life is short and
that they can make the decisions without
worrying about the ramifications of
other people and some of the people
they're worried about are also dead and
so it was using that context for that
biggest decision that's been duplicated
many times in my life since then because
if I have a good decision-making
algorithm I try and reuse it as many
times as I can you apps absolutely just
need skills you can have nothing else in
your life and a beautiful thing is that
no government can take it from you no
person can take your skills from you in
a divorce those are always your own
which is something that I don't know for
some reason feels magical to me and so
one of the things that I've seen as I've
kind of you know moved moved up I'm not
saying that arrogantly just you know
just developed progressed whatever
um is that the people who I surround
myself with now have more money than the
people that I surrounded myself when I
was early on in my career and what's
ironic is that these people actually
spend less money
they they have they have less desire to
spend money and they find ways to
acquire things for less money out of
pocket and um that's always really
interesting to me and so right now I
think there's you know if you were to if
you were to look at quote investment
opportunities right
um you could you could you know invest
in buying a house so let's say let's say
you've got I'll do two scenarios all
right let's say you've got fifty
thousand dollars all right
and you're like okay I'm thinking about
buying uh a house right and I think for
first house you might only have to put
10 down I'm not sure it's 10 or 20. yeah
I don't remember but anyways let's just
say 10 for for sake of whatever so 500
000 house all right you put 10 down and
then you get the mortgage right you get
the liability of the mortgage payment
every month yippee
um now if you were to if you were to and
let's say that in order for you to save
that you've been making
I don't know 60 Grand a year and you've
been saving that for you know five years
something like that now let's look at an
alternative scenario where you um are
still making that same amount of money
60 and you saved up 50 and instead of
buying a house you have a long
conversation with your spouse and you
say or maybe you don't have a spouse
whatever with yourself and you say
I wonder how much money I could get for
this money ah interesting right and so
you you Leaf through the businesses that
are in your area and by the way
um the best way to do that is one you
should contact Brokers not necessarily
to buy a business but to get an idea of
some of the businesses that are in the
area and what price ranges look like but
if you buy from a broker you're going to
pay retail you could definitely
negotiate a deal and I'll tell you one
of the deals that I did that was really
good at the end of this let's say you
you know you reach out to some
businesses things that you like or enjoy
or feel like you have some specialized
knowledge in
and uh you find out that there's a
business that's doing let's say
I don't know
250 000 a year in uh in in profit right
and uh because it's a small local loan
business and you're not going to pay
retail for it you get it for two and a
half you know times earnings right which
would be
uh what's two and a half times uh it's
5.25 hopefully I think two and a half no
that's 625 excuse me 625 000 is what a
business you might pay for businesses
doing 250 000 a year in profit all right
now here's where here's where it's
interesting right so I had
um an early Mentor who taught me this
negotiation tactic that I've used pretty
much throughout my entire life since
this moment and I used it in the deal
that I'll tell you about in a second
which is agree on price then agree on
terms right and so when you when you
would go to quote talk to this business
right there's there's the price which
you might say cool you know this
business 625 and then there's terms
right and so the term side once you've
agreed on the price you negotiate down
whatever
and then you say okay well I'm gonna
need you to seller finance meaning
you're not going to pay anything you're
going to pay them over time right I need
you to sell or Finance uh you know three
quarters of the deal all right and so
three quarters of the deal man I'm doing
some math today but like 400 and you
know 30ish 437 whatever thousand dollars
um
and you're going to finance that for you
know three years right
and then on top of that or five years
you could do whatever you want here I
think um
I mean you could probably I mean you try
and push it out as far as you can right
and then what you have remaining which
would be like in this instance two
hundred thousand dollars then you get a
note from the bank right or SBA loan
which you have a two hundred thousand
dollar
um loan for it and you put your your
fifty thousand dollars down right so
then that would be 200 uh so you put 50
which would be 25 of 200 000. so I'm
going to recap this 625 is the cost of
the business you know 437 you get seller
finance meaning you can pay that over
time and then you've got two hundred
thousand dollars that you get a loan
from the bank so uh which you put fifty
thousand dollars for
so if you're thinking about this the guy
who's selling the business he sells for
625 but he's only getting 200 000 up
front you're only putting 50 of that 200
and you're taking a loan for the rest of
it right
um and so when you're looking at this
you've now acquired this business that
makes 250 000 a year right so you
upgraded your income from 60 to 250 000
right and within you know 24 months
all of that you know income will be
yours uh and maybe hopefully you'll grow
it or you'll probably try and work extra
hard and take over some of the some of
the other positions or cut out some of
the waste Etc in the business and uh and
and so that massively speeds you up in
life right and if you compare that to
what it would cost you to start your own
business
um in terms of investment and like
existing book of business client lists
all the knickknacks you have to buy that
you don't even think of zoning permits
and all the fees and licenses it's
actually pretty decent deal
so
um
I'll tell you one of the deals that I
did that was pretty good so I had four
locations at this point this is one of
the gyms and I opened a fifth location
so the first two locations I opened I
opened the first one I think for forty
thousand dollars I mean I put I didn't I
put as little as I possibly could in
this thing
um and it happened to have been an old
gym so there was like Turf already in
the flooring was already in it was
painted like there was a bunch of things
I didn't have to pay for so I lucked out
there
um
and but the second one because I thought
I was smarter I put 200 we put 250 000
into the second location and here's the
fun thing it made no more money than the
first location did uh which I always
think is hilarious so like uh to the
undisciplined everything looks like a
spending opportunity uh it's uh I pretty
much would empty my bank account and uh
and so on my fifth location uh my next
two locations were corporate locations
which are actually pretty cheap
um which was pretty cool those are those
are good deals but the the fifth
location that I did I had a gym that
went out of business or not out of
business he wanted to uproot because his
it got divorced or he had some some
family crisis
and so he's looking for someone to buy
his his gym and so it was beautiful it
had all this equipment that was really
expensive in it and I was like man this
is like a dream come true and so I
agreed on price because I had my mentor
talk me through this I agreed on price
which I think was 40 000. I think it was
40 Grand it was 40 or 50. I think it was
a bit so that's what I agreed and then I
was like cool
I'll pay you over the next year
and he was like fair enough and so I
mean you didn't say it like that we
negotiated and then 12 months is what we
what we came to and so I mean I try to
go for 24 months uh but he agreed on 12.
and so the beautiful thing with that was
I didn't I didn't put any money out of
pocket so you know my first year I put
50 Grand in second gym I put 250 000 in
fifth gym smarter more experienced me
puts no money in right and in the first
30 days we did 51 000 in sales
so this gym in the first 30 days
literally paid for itself period right
and so this thing is now kicking off
profit right every month
during this during this whole period of
time
and then 12 months later I ended up
meeting Russell and telling him how I
was doing this stuff and he's like you
should be teaching other people how to
do what you're doing now and so I ended
up selling the gym for one and a half
times more than I quote bought it for
right which I then had the gym pay for
it on its own and so I basically
acquired a cash flowing asset for
nothing
and then had just acquired a cash
flowing asset for for no money and so I
think about that
um in light of the original thing that I
I mentioned was just like I get I get
people who message me all the time like
what happens if I don't have any money I
don't know what to do you always have to
just get skills or this is just my
opinion is that because there's no one
who can take them from you there's no
divorce there's no government there's no
Revolution there's no financial crisis
that can ever take your skills from you
and that's why when entrepreneurs hit
zero they can usually bounce back I've
done it I had eleven hundred dollars in
my bank account at one point at my at my
lowest point after I had six gyms right
after this so even when I had this
experience and it sounds cool like I
messed up and um you know that's why I
think I love the saying you only
should only have to get rich once and um
and that's why people who are wealthy
are more risk-averse because the
downside risk of losing everything is
always bigger right like you can reverse
30 years of great decisions with any
number multiplied by zero any number
multiplied by zero you could have a
billion dollars if you make a bad
investment it goes to zero right
and so that's why when people are like I
don't know why you're motivated and I
don't know why uh they're like it's just
there's there's just always things that
can happen you know what I mean and so
just being risk-averse is what I have
noticed from the people who have the
most money is that they actually have
way lower risk tolerances than the
people who have no money uh which is
hilarious because it's like the people
who have the least amount of money uh
then go buy lottery tickets which are
literally the worst investment you could
possibly make
um and and and they they consistently
invest their money in a terrible
investment that has all the downside
risk of going to zero whereas the
richest people in the world find things
that could never go to zero and they buy
them for zero so think about that for a
second people are using their money poor
people use their money
to buy things that have virtually
guaranteed you know risk of going to
zero right with tiny risk of of upside
right whereas rich people buy stuff for
zero dollars that have
um upside potential but that doesn't
that doesn't have a billion dollar
upside potential they would rather have
a guaranteed small return with no risk
than a potential for huge return with
guaranteed risk think about that so uh
anywho I think if over time and it's not
like you can shift your perspective on
this overnight it took me a long time
and I still am doing it now
um and shifting how like as I still get
excited about you know I see these you
know these these these cryptocurrencies
20xing and stuff you know in like a
month and I'm like man that's crazy uh
but then I also think like well the
downside risk of me going to zero is far
more upsetting to me than me getting 20
times more on some tiny investment that
I would make
um and so I I don't do it right
and so anyways
um I say all this to say uh agree on
price agree on terms try and get
something for nothing see if you're
gonna if you're gonna make an investment
in any kind or you're trying to start a
business there's usually a business
that's already for sale or has a
motivated seller an owner who doesn't
want to do it anymore who almost gave it
to you for free right and that's the
thing is when you're new you're getting
so excited but you're not patient right
that's why you have to have the
character traits of being successful
before you will see the success because
if you if you have that character trait
you'll look and you'll say I can take
six months because in the in the decade
of my the next decade of my life there's
no rush but me making a good deal or a
bad deal of like should I put all my
investment in this thing or should I be
able to get something that makes four
times more money for free you can do
that you can do that and I'm telling you
I talk to business owners every day I
mean guys making a million two million
four million dollars a year who
literally have told me they're like dude
if someone came today and offered me
like guys who are making a million
dollar a million dollars a year in
profit or like if someone had offered me
200 Grand right now I would take it I
just I'm so tired of this business so
like there are opportunities they're
just not listed anywhere you just got to
look for them right the secret to
happiness is uh
haves over once uh which is let's say
you have you know have one thing and you
want nothing
you will be infinitely happy the problem
is where you might have a million things
but you want two million things and you
will not be happy right and so you can
simply change how happy you are by
expecting less
and so one of the things that I
specifically wanted to address today was
the expectations around education
and the reason this is a really
meaningful topic for me is that I've I
think I've talked to you about my
neighbor
um and watching him go through the the
crazy expectations that he has as a
young person has been really valuable
for me because I've also seen a lot of
those characteristics that he has in
myself just add zeros to it but it's
still fundamentally the same thing and
that's what's been uh it's been
meaningful for me and so anyways I have
tried to frame things so if you are
trying to learn things which is going to
be the first step to any kind of
entrepreneurial Endeavor is I like to
liken everything to a bridge because I
think it's a simple visual so imagine
where you are on one side of you know
this this Valley right is where you are
and where you want to go is on the other
side of this big valley right and you
have a bridge that goes across the two
sides now the problem is is that people
will buy
things they will buy courses they will
buy mentorships they'll buy workshops
they'll buy seminars they'll buy events
they'll buy whatever right in an effort
on some level to get over this bridge
right of where they are to where they
want to go and it could be from zero to
a hundred thousand dollars a year it
could be from a million dollars a month
to two million dollars a month it could
be from 100 million dollars a year to a
billion dollars a year whatever it is
there's a bridge right along that bridge
are bricks and I like to liken
um each skill as a brick on the way to
where you're trying to go and the
problem with the expectations of
somebody who's trying to learn a skill
or achieve a goal is that they have a
binary outcome I either achieved it or I
did not I either am making a hundred
thousand dollars or I am not and the
problem is it can be incredibly
frustrating because if you have a binary
outcome uh then it's very easy to get a
zero out of one right where the reality
is most things are exist on a Continuum
and so this is the difference between a
psychological binary and a and and the
biological Continuum which is I'll give
you a couple of examples so it's not uh
uh are you diabetic are you not diabetic
it's how diabetic are you right it's not
uh are you smart are you dumb but it's
how smart are you right and so we like
to psychologically bucket things into
yes no's because it's simpler for us but
it it it misses Act actual reality right
and this can be especially dangerous as
we're trying to acquire new skills and
so the reason I liken this and I think
it's so dangerous in education because
that's what we're doing right if we're
trying to educate ourselves we're trying
to acquire skills is that we think as
we're trying to get across this bridge
that let's say you buy a course on
copywriting right and so you're on one
side of the bridge you buy a course on
copywriting and then you still aren't a
millionaire wow right
the problem is uh you may have put
another brick on your Bridge you may be
closer to where you were to getting to
the other side of the bridge you just
haven't achieved it yet and so this is
one of the issues that I also see
um just in general like it's so funny
because in the in the in the I'll say
quote Guru World
um you know people will take on a coach
that coach will move them forward you
know to a certain degree and then
they'll take another coach and that
coach will move them forward to a
certain degree and so forth and so on
and then the thing is is that they're
they're like I'm working with so-and-so
I used to work with that person they
suck right
but the problem and I used to do this
right like and this is why I think it's
so ridiculous
um is that like if you were looking at
your schooling right and you had a had a
third grade math teacher and then later
you had a calculus teacher you wouldn't
be like screw that third grade you know
uh math teacher the stuff that I'm
learning from this guy is so much you
know more advanced whatever right and
I've had you know a lot of our clients
say that about their franchises that
they work with and things like that and
I just it it drives me nuts because it's
it's stupid you know it's for lack of
it's stupid because a lot of times you
need
you need step one to get to step two
right and you don't have to and P it's
because people have psychological issues
but like they they can't they can't say
I've learned from all of these people
right and it doesn't it doesn't decrease
your status to say I've learned from
many teachers look at all the richest
people in the world they say like I've
had multiple mentors I've had so many
people help me out over the years and I
think if you can shift that perspective
it will be incredibly valuable for you I
think that the whole ego death concept
that we were talking about the very
beginning I try not to talk about this
too much because I think it's it's um a
lot of people find take offense to it
and I don't mean it that way I sure this
is just what worked for me and not as a
criticism of any anyone else's beliefs
for me the idea that there was no such
thing as Legacy that when I died
eventually everything that I had would
become dust
and that anything expanded over a long
enough time Horizon disappears right
which if you are like Christian for
example it's the whole book of
Ecclesiastes
um
if you and I think the realization of
that allowed me to quiet my ego a lot
so that I could be more present in the
idea that like this moment will only be
here in my mind and anything that I do
here will not last and so
it shifted how I worked it shifted how I
saw relationships and a lot of my
thinking is around like my 85 year old
self I feel like my number one Mentor is
like my fictitious 85 year old self
because it's the only person that I
really believe has my best interest at
heart and is no ulterior motive and so
there's this there's this tweet that I
had that went pretty viral but it was
like
listening to a billionaire or a
millionaire I'll just use that like when
I was in my 20s I wanted to be a
millionaire and when I was a millionaire
I wanted to be in my 20s
and so the idea that my future self
would trade all the money he had to be
poor in 20 again made me really
reanalyze how I saw living life in the
moment if I literally in the future will
value my present moment more than the
achievement of the thing that I'm I'm
seeking right now in the present
then something's something's off because
even my future self knows that because
right now I would pay all the money I
have to get 10 years back it's not even
thinking about it and so then all of
what I'm going to achieve in the next 10
years I would happily give up to be
right where I am right now
and so I think thinking about that
really shifted a lot for me because it
helped me quiet I'm not saying eliminate
but quiet some of the thoughts that are
more ego driven because the ego always
wants to like separate and isolate from
others and prove that it's better and if
I know that it will all be dust there is
no better because we're all going to be
destined so in that same way if like if
we're all going to be Dustin we're all
siblings
like two very strong frames for me at
least it helped me quiet that aspect and
I think in that way I was able I think
you can ask my people but like I think I
was able to show up better as a leader
there was better able to show up better
as a husband
um so I better like to make content
things like that like I don't think I
could have made the stuff we make now
five years ago because I still think it
would have been more it would have been
to proving something yes perfect 100 of
improving proving someone proving a
fictitious foe wrong
right right they're all talking about
right no one cares about you exactly and
so that was really and it's like I had
to shift from like no one cares about
you to
like
I really want to have a shirt that says
no lives matter but I feel like
no one cares about you yeah yeah but I
feel but I think there's like a lot of
like meat to that where it's like if we
can because in that way we are all equal
and so as I think it's almost the most
egalitarian perspective is that like in
the end we will all be dust yeah and so
I think in that way that's like we have
these exchanges that we have
um and in some ways it makes it more
beautiful
why are you trying to change people's
perception of you when you can just
change who you are and let their
perceptions catch up the only way you're
going to change your reputation is by
being different he's like you need to
stop being this person that does all
these things and your reputation will
catch up and even if it doesn't you'll
always know I and I honestly it barely
scratched the surface because my ego was
so high and I was like no I just have to
think of a better way to like Market
myself but I ended up knowing that he
was very serious about the threat of
pulling me out of school if I didn't get
my grades up and so what I ended up
doing for the next half of the semester
of my first semester freshman year is I
didn't go out at all I didn't drink
anymore I really didn't like hang out
with girls at all and all I did was
study and I was able to pull my might
have been one two it was very low up to
a 3.2 for the semester which basically
meant I got an A on everything from that
point for the rest of the semester and
so when I went back home he was like
well now you know you can do it and so
we should always expect that that is
what you're going to get from here on
out and it also kind of proved it to
myself too I was like I guess I can do
this and you know what happened is after
I started switching that way
people still thought of me as a
and I still had to deal with that it
took like two years to really reverse
the reputation that I had acquired in
the first three months I think during
that period of time I grew an
appreciation for how easy it is
especially in First Impressions to set
the wrong one and how hard it is to
overcome a negative impression and my
reputation overall the realization I had
was there's too many people that you're
interacting with in the world to try and
curate reputation
the only way to change your reputation
is to change who you are reputation is
fundamentally just what people say about
you to your face and behind your back
I'm not saying that you need to care
about what everyone else thinks that's
not really the point of this it's much
more if one person says you're an
whatever if every person you
know says you're Nestle like you might
be an and so if you have one of
those situations where you feel like the
proof or the evidence is overwhelming
and you might even believe it then it's
probably you I think that for me getting
out of the hole like I can control this
and try and curate what people think
about me and transitioning to be like at
the end of the day I'm the only person
who knows who I am and I don't like who
I am and just saying like well how can I
get to a point where I would like me
even if everyone else hated me how can I
like me when I started operating from
that place it really changed my life
because then I started thinking like
what version of me do I want to be and
what does that guy do well that guy
studies really hard and that guy works
out really hard and that guy's a really
good friend he's always respectful
doesn't have an ego and it took me a
long time and I still work on this stuff
you know what I mean I'm not saying I'm
done by any any sorts of imagination but
but I think that if you can simply shift
the perspective of like I'm going to try
and appear this way to like I want to be
this way if it just so happens to get
captured great and if it doesn't great
and there's this this quote by we teach
us that I'm probably gonna butcher but
he says if you need someone else to tell
you something about yourself you are out
of Integrity because you can always be
your own witness I think that that's a
great point to wrap the this little
video Lesson up with because that piece
strikes to the core of everything which
is we are our own Witnesses and if we
want to change our reputation we need to
change our reputation with ourselves
first and then eventually it will
reflect in the world when I was 15 16 17
I was a pretty angry kid I thought that
I had all these issues I would tell
people I have anger issues I'm not a
nice person I would tell people those
things because I believe those things to
be true and I saw them as problems and
then I went to college and College it's
all propaganda of people who are
teaching who've never actually done work
in a real economy ever they're all
tenure they don't live in reality they
tell everyone they should pursue their
purpose and their passion and the things
that they love and I ate it up and so I
read all these books on pod psychology I
watched all these TED talks and the
problem was I didn't make any progress
and I felt like there was something even
more wrong with me because I didn't feel
any of that stuff I wish I could go back
and tell myself dude
all the stuff they're saying is just not
true
like you don't need any of that you can
embrace the fact that you are angry you
can embrace the fact that you feel like
you are in pain and you can use that to
make the life that you want you don't
have to use the lovey-dovey purpose
passion to build the life that you want
to build what it does is it tells people
that having a negative emotional
experience is a bad thing but half of
your life is below average by definition
and so if you are not using the half of
your life as energy or motivation to
create the life you want then you're at
a huge disadvantage they interviewed the
top Olympic medalists and they found
that they don't actually love winning
they hate losing when they win they
experience relief not Euphoria if you
look at Steve Jobs he wasn't some
happy-go-lucky dude who was like man I
just want to make the world a better
place he was a tough dude to work for
but he created Something Beautiful from
that pain MJ you look at Kobe they had
imaginary situations that they created
in their minds to create more suffering
in their own lives to motivate them and
uses fuel imagine you have this big
vision for your life that you want and
on this side your family gets kidnapped
and if you don't do something they will
kill them all which of those motivates
you more right now in this video
probably the one with your family
getting kidnapped it's not trying to
harness a lovey-dovey feeling it's
harnessing pain felt like I had
experienced more pain than I had good I
saw it as a disadvantage I saw it as
something that I had to overcome I
didn't have this big purpose I didn't
have this thing that I loved I didn't
have this thing I was passionate about
and if I could have just skipped all of
that
and started the moment I accepted that
it was okay to be angry
what wasn't okay was not doing anything
about it while I procrastinated by
trying to find purpose jumping from
thing to thing to thing trying to find
the thing that really lit my fire and
just accepted that it was totally okay
to work my face off in disgust from my
current circumstance and who I was than
I would have gotten to where I wanted to
go much faster so many people are
believing a lie they have to be happy
they have to have purpose passion for
what they're doing in order to get out
of their situation they think that they
are poor because they don't have passion
that is false you were poor because
you're not doing the activities that
makes you rich and you can fuel those
activities whatever way you damn well
please and so if you are somebody who is
more motivated by the dark side then
Lean Into the Dark Side unlike the
saying the road to hell is paved with
good intentions the equal opposite of
that is the road to Heaven is paved with
bad intentions you can do good with bad
motivation and when I say bad I mean
negative experience is pain anger Etc I
still have tons of motivation from that
side you can use that negative fuel hit
it on speed dial every time you're
confronted with that thing that you
don't want to do you push through it and
what happens you do that enough times
you start to get good at the thing you
start seeing the result of work that has
compounded and start to see a purpose or
start to see a bigger Vision the big
vision for Alex's life until maybe four
years ago was don't be broke what was
your mission with jumbo my mission was
to stop being poor there are elements
that I do that I absolutely love but
there are tons that I do every day that
I hey I just don't hate it more than I
hate the alternative and the richest
people in the world they all say it's
not about the money because if it's
about the money you stop the moment you
have enough the people with the
wealthiest in the world have the three
things in common they have the big goal
they have massive fears about never
being enough and then they have impulse
control to stay on goal and oftentimes
that impulse control comes from right as
you approach the guard rail looking over
the edge and imagining what it would be
like to have your friends tell you that
you were a failure have them laugh
behind your back or talk down about you
or have your parents when they're
introducing you as their fun-loving kid
you know he's still figuring himself out
that is what would crush me the boring
that you have to do is not fun Jeff
Bezos talks about overhead in business
there's tons of things that you have to
do and be willing to do that you do not
enjoy the question is whether you do not
enjoy them more then you do not enjoy
the pain that you are going away from as
long as the pain of moving forward is
less than the pain of going back and the
pain that you imagine from not taking
the action that you know should be
taking then you can use that energy as
the single fuel that you can stay on
path for an extended period of time I'm
writing my book right now I'm on the
11th
draft like there is no feeling that
makes me more sick than the idea that I
could have done more the pain of the
idea of that book not doing well or that
book leading to people being like I
don't think he tried as hard that is the
thing that hurts so much more than going
from the top yet again to make another
video to make another article to make
another short to make another chapter
revision yet again so that when I do
launch it I think to myself I literally
exhausted every option on this one of
the things that I live by is that I will
not do my best I will do what is
required and the difference between what
your best is and what is required is the
difference between what you think your
real best is and what your actual best
is and what your actual best is is the
thing that you would do to prevent
everyone you know from dying what people
care about is the outcome what you put
out in the world now why you do it what
fuels you that's your business and so if
you are in one of these situations and
you can't find that purpose you can't
find that passion cool but it doesn't
give you permission to not be successful
yes so you go from in your late teens
and early 20s kind of live in your Dad's
life going to school being a Management
Consultant the whole kind of Iranian
work ethic become a doctor all that
stuff and then at 22 you decide no uh
peace out I'm not doing this and and
your dad feels you're making this giant
mistake
um but then but then what I loved about
that story was that he comes back and
gives you his his only ever apology to
you uh for saying it was a mistake what
did you what did you have to do to then
ultimately make him proud that he
apologized to you
well I mean there's probably there's
probably layers to this you know I mean
everyone's relationship with their
parents are different but for me at
least my my dad he he was very much a
material success guy
um like every time you introduce
somebody like before he got in the car
after he got in the party they go this
is so and so this is how much money it
makes right and so it was very clear
whether he said it consciously or
unconsciously like that money was what
to him is what was most respectable
about someone
um he would probably not liked me saying
that but not through his words but
through his actions it became clear to
me that that is what he valued and so
for me to gain the affirmation or the
approval of my father I had to make
money but he also has his you know his
own ego and his own pride and whatnot
and so it couldn't be like I just have
to match the amount of money that he
makes it's like I had to make more money
than it ever made in his entire life
um for that to really solidify and we're
both pretty um domineering personalities
and so we had to there was like a
five-year period where we didn't talk
too much
um and there I think there had to be a
power shift um that had to occur and it
only really occurred when the the
evidence was overwhelming um and so like
when I started making money
um I mean I think the first year that we
made like 10 million dollars uh he was
like well we'll see how long it lasts
like it wasn't you know what I mean so
like it it wasn't just like you have to
make more money it was it was it had to
be so insurmountable the evidence that
it was undeniable and so I think that
that's also been a theme that that I
applied to a lot of the facets of my
life is that just through my own
insecurities
um I wanted to create uh you know
different different pillars in my life
that would be successful quote like
Beyond reproach so that no one could say
like Alex is in good shape it's like no
he's in such crazy shape that no one can
say that he's overweight right or you
know he's he's not just like doing okay
but he's making so much money that no
one can say that he's not successful I
think honestly that's just because of my
own insecurities I don't think that's a
testing with anything besides that
um I may still Harbor those and I just
have evidence that that allows me to
function you know better you know I live
in a more normal lifestyle rather than
continually suffer from those just
because those that evidence acts as a
crutch against the insecurities that I
have there's three traits that people
then they looked at because they were
trying to find Habits of Highly
Successful People and when they actually
pulled apart it's not you know and I
hope I'm not contradicting anything
um but there's people who are really
rich who wake up really late and work
really late and there's people really
rich who wake up really really early and
there's people who really chewy really
healthy and there's people really rich
who drink cocoa and eat french fries
every day and so there's all these
things that we want to make as truths
but there there's easy examples that
counter those things so it's like what
are the few things that are true or at
least that seem to be present in all of
the situations and it seems as though
they were surprisingly few
and so the three common traits that they
had that they had found were one that
people have superiority complex they
believe they're better than others and
they believe that they deserve more than
everyone else does and that they can
accomplish big goals right so they have
a bigger Vision because they believe
they deserve it or whatever it is that
they were able to identify that the
second thing that they would identify is
that they had crippling insecurity and
which which is a paradox of paradoxes
they feel they'll never be enough
um and they'll always be measured
against the things that they've achieved
and so you've got this crazy dynamic
between they they think they're better
than everyone they think they deserve
more they want to go after this big hill
and at the same time they fear they'll
never be good enough and they'll never
actually achieve it and they actually
suck and then the third piece which kind
of adds the beautiful like mix of this
is impulse control and so they're able
to control their actions and focus on a
single thing for an extended period of
time and so if you put those three
things together it's like you've got a
big goal that's pulling you this way
you've got this big fear that you are
running away from and then you've got
impulse control to keep you focused on
the one thing that matters yes and if
you do that if you if you are the type
of person who has the those traits then
you are very likely to be successful the
single greatest differentiator between
the poor and the middle class middle
class and rich rich and the truly
wealthy is how they see time and if you
think about money as simply a condensed
unit of time right that's all money is
like you trade it for time I mean you
can trade time for money so like it is
they're almost equivalent units and the
people who know how to master their time
the most mean that they know how to
master their money the most right and so
really if you want to master to the
original question of like how do wealthy
people come off these because they
Master their time and so time Horizon is
just like the perspective from which we
see what we want to achieve and so if I
am doing if I'm building a company from
the place of like I believe that this
company should exist I believe this
problem is worth solving and that is
where you start it from then you build
it differently versus versus I need to
make money I need to make money this
week I need to make money tomorrow
because what can I go make money with
exactly and so I think like I mean
you've built this amazing brand here
if if people were able to
not ask for 12 months and just serve if
you see something as a forever option
then it probably means you do not
understand it well enough to begin doing
it so there's a little mine for you
um and so let me give you a couple
examples to bring this home
so you know when I was you know in the
fitness space I had a lot of people
who'd come up to me and be like hey man
like I want to start working out I want
to get bigger I was like awesome you
know this is how you got to train blah
blah and they'd be like well I don't
want to get too big
I'm like
you don't even look like you work out so
why don't we start with that and then we
can worry about you getting too big
right so it's not a perfect example for
business but that's an example of
somebody trying to Discount starting
because they think they cease an end
that they do not even understand the
journey well enough to comprehend
another example would be hey we're
running Tick Tock ads right now and
we're crushing it right and someone says
well
we don't know how long tick tock's gonna
be around or SnapChat or insert whatever
new opportunity there is and so we don't
want to do it right
but the reality is all opportunities are
by their very nature Arbitrage where
you're taking advantage of
inefficiencies within two systems or two
markets and so over time all Arbitrage
disappears right and then markets become
more efficient that's how markets work
right more and more people see the
opportunity the bit the Arbitrage
decreases until eventually it's
efficient right
and so when you're looking at
opportunities and you see something and
it might be a big opportunity but it
only is going to be open for two years
three years
do you do it or not it's another series
of questions that would happen after
that but I would not discount it simply
because you know that it is finite
because all opportunities are finite and
to take this exaggerate you know this
example to a Max degree of exaggeration
think about the Fortune 500 there's only
one company that's been on there for
over 100 years and that's GE just one
one company right and so every one of
those companies you might have thought
or during their day might have been like
this thing's going to be here forever
the reality is it's not and markets
change so rapidly it's difficult to
reshift an entire infrastructure some
companies can do it many fail and so if
your business is founded upon taking
advantage of an Arbitrage opportunity or
an inefficiency in a Marketplace or
something that is
fleeting right that comes and goes
that's okay many businesses were built
off of Arbitrage opportunities they
created cash flow human resources that
could then be deployed and pivoted in
another Direction when the opportunity
closes and so it's kind of like saying
well I don't want to invest in this
investment because it's only going to
Triple my money in three years well what
do I do after it triples my money will
you take the money you invested
somewhere else right it's the same
concept except you're just applying it
to your business and so this is just a
caveat that was top of mind that I
figured I'd share with you because just
so many times we try and take 10 steps
forward without even realizing that
there's this big pile of money and you
can just pick it up and move about your
life and it doesn't need to be forever
and so it's just remembering like if
this were an investment would you triple
your money in three years probably
so then don't worry about what you're
going to do in 20 years because you're
going to be such a different person then
anyways you might not even want to be in
the same thing forever and so I think
sometimes we just create this reason
because the real reason is that we fear
failing when something seems so easy
right we fear failing because we might
not think we're good enough or we're
being lazy and we don't want to even
start or try and so it's usually the
fear thing but for some people you
shouldn't you get off your ass
um but anyways I hope I hope you found
this valuable uh maybe this you're at a
decision right now where you're thinking
about investing something or you're
thinking about taking advantage of an
opportunity or think about investing
your time into uh taking advantage of
some sort of inefficiency and uh if it's
a massive one even if it's going to be
fleeting as long as the return is high
enough I think many times it can be
worth it there are a lot of different
things that come up in the business
world where I will see people conflate
or mistake what thing they are solving
right and most times when I'm talking to
a newer entrepreneur or even a more
established entrepreneur and they reach
out for help or guidance or whatever
right or it's one of our portfolio
companies most times they'll start
talking right really fast about all this
stuff to try and provide context and
I'll just usually pause them and be like
what problem are we solving it usually
really gets them to stop right and I
would highly advise you if you're if
you're dealing with if you have
subordinates or you have direct reports
uh who roll into you and they have a
whole bunch of decisions a lot of times
it can get caught and sometimes
ourselves too we can get caught in the
in the day-to-day the minutia and just
simply pause and say what problem are we
solving there's so many pieces of this
that I want to unpack that I think are
going to be really interesting for you
but the first one is when you define
what problems you are solving you may
even have to ask the question is that a
problem when some people are like well
hey we're getting you know customer
service complaints it's like okay
understood
is this something that we believe that
we can reasonably eliminate is this
something that is catastrophic to the
business or is this something that we
can kind of try and improve over time
you know through systems and process
right and so a lot of times people
misprioritize problems because they
perceive them as as threats to existence
when in reality they are a course of
doing business and things that be
consistently improve right especially if
you're newer you're starting out of
course your product's not going to be
perfect yet right you're just getting
going
but you improve these things rather than
thinking I have to stop everything to
fix this problem right and so the first
frame shift is that most people think in
terms of like I have a problem to solve
rather than a dichotomy to be managed as
in these are two things that will always
exist all right I'll give you a
different example of this
um actually this will be a fun one the
reason we will probably never have
people who are all happy about a tax
code is because you cannot have both
fairness and equality equality means
everyone pays 10 percent fairness means
the rich people pay more than the poor
people that's fair this is equal both
are ideals and yet somehow they're not
the same thing and yet both are right
and so because of that we will always
have this conflict it's the same thing
between Justice and mercy both of them
are ideals both of them are right and
yet somehow they're conflicting and so
we we see these situations and this is
why I'm trying to hopefully give this to
you because the more I started to
recognize these patterns the more
quickly I can recognize them and then
identify by them and then either dismiss
them or say oh it's another one of those
right it's a pattern recognition it's
like oh you guys are spending all this
effort trying to solve a problem that is
unsolvable this is a dichotomy that must
be managed and will never be eliminated
and so I think what my goal with this
video is if I can help you get out of
these little mental hamster wheels uh
it's been incredibly valuable for me all
right so that's the dichotomy that's
like one of the one of the things that
people will mistake they'll mistake a
dichotomy for a problem that needs to be
solved all right another framework
um that that I find immensely valuable
is the concept of of a Continuum versus
a binary all right this is probably one
of the biggest mental errors that people
make when they're trying to identify
things and this is what I mean by that
so for example I might say I'll use a
weight loss example so people will say
something like uh I am off my diet or
I'm on my diet right it's a very simple
thing and that's because psychologically
we like to be binary we like to label
things as yes or no but biology and
reality exist on continuums as in to
what extent did you go off of your diet
right did you go 200 calories average
you go 500 calories over and as even
though it is quote more difficult to
think in this way it is also more
accurate and so our brain uses binaries
as placeholders for decision making to
store data right when in reality when
you start storing all these binary
decisions they start adding up and you
start getting more and more unaccurate
if that's a word on your decision-making
process because you're actually basing
your decisions not on facts but based on
binary shorthand that your brain saves
and so that is one of the biggest
mistakes that I see all the time in
thinking in entrepreneurs and really in
anything in general because we like to
have that shorthand it is easier right
it's easier to say I fell off my diet or
I am diabetic when the reality is it's
not whether you are diabetic it's how
diabetic are you right kind of
interesting I stole that from Dr cashier
but I just love that um who's my closest
friend he's a biochemist and we talk
about this stuff all the time point
being if you can think about this within
I'll give you I'll give you a business
example so if we have a a binary where
people are saying yes or no which is
let's say Facebook doesn't work
marketing doesn't work I hear these
statements all the time and you may
laugh at this right but I get DMs like
this all the time Facebook doesn't work
for me marketing doesn't work for me
like you can't sell this way in my
business right and so people want to
shorten a problem into yes it works no
it doesn't work when so much of business
and problem solving is understanding the
Nuance between where we're starting and
where we're going and it's to what
extent
has Facebook not worked right where is
the fall off right it is not that it
doesn't work it is just we only got it
to work this percent right now we need
to get all the way over the hump to get
there but it's to what extent and I
think that when I when if you if you can
ask the right questions if you can see
the problems as they truly are they
become far more solvable and so this has
been probably I just gave you two of my
my best frames that I think with all the
time all right so I'll say these again
so the first uh mental lapse I'll say
that I see all the time
is mistaking a dichotomy that needs to
be managed for a problem that needs to
be solved people do this in their
marriages as well right so you look at
your wife right you look at your wife
and you're like I need more variety
right but later you're like I need more
consistency and you're like we have to
figure this out we need variety we need
consistency it's like yes you need both
right and so it's not a problem to be
solved it's the dichotomy to be managed
in a perfect world if everyone had
absolute information and everyone was
unbelievably well trained and you had a
great infrastructure and all that stuff
then yes the more products and services
you offer in theory you would make more
money but we don't live in that
theoretical world most of the time and
most small business owners are not that
good at operating right it's the number
one issue they have they're super
disorganized they feel like they're
spinning the reels all day their team
completely has no idea what which way
they're going they change things all the
time Etc and so in an effort to combat
that we have used this process over and
over again and it has worked very well
so it is as follows we sell two things
and I've done this in virtually every
business that I've ever owned we sell
two things two products or two services
and this is once we're going from one to
ten million all right zero to one
million you sell one product or one
service one Avatar all right that's it
one channel one product one Avatar
that's it right but once you're going
from one to you know one to three ish
million and you're trying to go to ten
you introduce the second product line
and so here's how this works if you have
two things that you sell you'll have a
front-end thing and you'll have a
back-end thing we can still have a
massive accommodation in the buying
curve based on the payment terms that we
introduce so for example people will
look at their monthly expense more than
the total contract value that's a huge
money hack I'm giving you right now this
is a wealth hack this is something that
will make you a fortune in your life if
you can properly understand this people
do not look at the length or the total
contract they're signing they will only
pay attention to what is it going to
cost me every month because no one is
good with their money all right so they
only look at the cash flow expense month
over month over month and they just
think can I make it happen yes cool I'll
sign they don't think about the total
contract value for you as a business
owner the contract value matters almost
more than anything so I'll give you a
quick hack on this total side note
tangent for you life hack Pro tip if you
want to extend the contract value that
you have I have a sag which is the
bigger the head the longer the tail all
right and so what that means is the more
you can get someone to pay up front and
relative to The Upfront cost of signing
up or what they paid down
the lower their contractual recurring
payment is the stickier it will be so
I'll give you an example if I had
someone sign up for 99 a month for
whatever it doesn't matter that price
point might be medium sticky depending
on the value that I have now imagine I
had someone pay five thousand dollars
down and 99 a month after that how much
more sticky would it be significantly
more sticky now the beauty is if you
have one of these upfront type payments
you can also use that to liquidate your
ad costs cover your commissions for the
salesperson cover The Upfront
fulfillment and onboarding which is
going to cost more for a new customer
than an existing customer and so you can
build all that in if you know that the
thing that you are selling has very high
gross margins then you can still have a
lower cost as long as you know that the
person is going to stay for a long time
and So based on how you structure the
pricing you can actually get some you
can use the pricing to actually get
people to stick longer Pro tip complete
that is it moving back to the original
thing that I was talking about in one of
our portfolio companies we actually had
this as a really in-depth discussion
that we had to make a decision about all
right and so they had a different you
know Mentor person whatever advice uh
who told them that they should have
three products and they should have uh
you know low a medium and a high product
and then based on uh you know what the
salesman thought the salesman would sell
them the low medium or high
in my experience it is not that
effective and that is because the
salesperson can't decide which of these
things they are trying to sell most of
the time and so what we have found is
more effective is you give the
salesperson the one dream to sell this
thing is going to solve this person's
problem and we make it the most valuable
thing that we're trying to sell because
at the end of the day you do want to
solve the the customer's problem right
we do want to actually make sure that
we're providing value rather than having
a diet a medium and a great right Simply
Having one thing that solves all the
problems and then based on the the
customer's budget we can decrease how
they pay all right so hear me out so
let's say that uh we want to do a uh
this is a six month implementation of
whatever kind of solution you sell if
you have a six month duration you can
have the person a pay the entire thing
up front so that would be for somebody
who has the highest budget version two
would be a split pay version three might
be three payments right with at twenty
percent higher and then finally you
might have a have a have a you know a
six pay or whatever over that period of
time so one two three six now here's the
cool thing the more payment options you
provide the higher your conversions are
that's proven all right so the more
options you give someone to pay the more
people will buy
period now you might not make more cash
flow because if you give your sales guy
more options then they might use they'll
end up defaulting to the lower ones
right but if you have one thing to sell
then they only have one thing to
convince the person of because a
confused mind doesn't buy if you have
too many options the salesman won't know
what to sell and the prospect won't know
what to buy and so I prefer when I'm
coming into a portfolio company I'm
thinking what is this true problem that
we are solving with this business for
what Avatar and we make that the main
thing and we communicate it clearly in
the scripting and the salesperson has
Clarity on what they are selling and
they're always solving the same thing
and so the question becomes no longer
which of these things are you going to
buy but once you are buying how would
you like to pay and so then the
discussion is around what payment plan
is best for them rather than what
product is best for them and so by doing
that you can get people to go between
different payment terms that is not
going to change whether they're going to
buy but if they're unsure about which
product is going going to best suit
their needs and the salesman doesn't
know because at the end of the day he's
just trying to sell the most expensive
thing then you'll have way more confused
people who leave unsold so this is a
single tactic that you can use to
execute within your business which is
why I'm a big fan of making offers
people cannot say no to is that you can
focus all of your sales and all of your
persuasion attempts on selling the one
thing which is getting them to say yes
once they say yes we can we can reach
the we can accommodate their wealth and
their budget based on the payment terms
that we provide and if we have done we
have structured our offer properly the
offer in and of itself should already be
very high gross margins which means
whether or not the person pays a
thousand dollars a month or a hundred
dollars a month it's still almost all a
margin for us because of how we
structure the thing that we are selling
and so we are able to capture Higher
ltvs by getting the people who have more
money to prepay the thing up front that
is how we do it and with those people
you'll be able to ascend into the second
thing faster because they've already
prepaid that thing and then you can
solve the next natural problem in
another sales conversation rather than
trying to pick all of the things in one
conversation which makes it incredibly
difficult to do this is just for
everyone again a broad brush stroke of
statements for most entrepreneurs who
are not very good at operating their
businesses uh her operations is not
their strong suit and are below three
million dollars a year we need to be
reminded more than we need to be taught
that is a saying that we have in my
world and I will I will pass it on to
you guys Mosey Nation we need to be
reminded more than we need to be taught
do the boring work repeat successful
actions and so
if he's gotten to this point or if
you've gotten to a point in your
business and it has plateaued the
question is has it plateaued because
this is true like I have the only reason
a business should Plateau that is
reasonable that is not your fault is
that you have reached the total
addressable Market as in you have
saturated the total the total Market of
that thing so for example if you were
selling dog food and every dog within
this you know maybe you saw a specific
type of niche of poodle food right
you've gotten you know 70 of poodle
owners to buy your food and you can't
grow anymore beyond that right well that
would be reasonable but then you'd
obviously just do a different type of
dog right you'd you'd hop verticals
right so there's not even a reason but
it would be the only potentially
rational reason
um would be uh that your Market uh has
changed so a different example is a
friend of mine owned a company that does
uh newspaper advertising right so they
actually help newspapers translate their
advertisements into digital products
which is pretty cool so they are able to
sell a whole like basically a whole new
ad product to small businesses um who
want to buy ads right which is by the
way how newspapers make money he could
not grow his business because newspapers
have shrunk by 25 year over year which
is 25 compounding the wrong direction
and he's been in that business for like
10 years so now the market size is like
literally like five percent of what it
used to be 10 years ago and so as a
result of that he was growing at an
inverse rate to the shrinkage of the
industry right and so he got to a point
where he couldn't grow anymore than just
basically servicing the ones that are
still alive and then as they fell so did
his business right and so that is the
only logical reason that a business can
Plateau that is not in your control and
unless you're selling your newspapers
which are probably not the reason is
much simpler which is you just don't
know how and I'll tell you a different
story that I had and then I'll I'll I'll
wrap this up at the end so I was having
a different conversation with a woman
who was doing I think four million
dollars a year and she was selling uh
info products that were weight loss so
like weight loss info products so like
programs and ebooks and things like that
which is cool right she's a big
following all that kind of stuff and we
got I went I did a podcast with her and
uh after he got off the podcast he was
like yeah so these are my plans I'm
going to be doing like an apparel line
and a supplement line and uh cream line
and whatever right and I just kind of
sat there and I was like well I think
that's a terrible idea she was like she
just looked at me across there she's
like what and I was like yeah I think
it's a terrible idea and she was like oh
and I was like why don't you just take
the thing that's making you four million
dollars and make it make you 10 million
dollars
where you do that
and the and the answer is the same as
the first answer I just don't know how
and I was like right well why don't we
solve that problem
and then not create a new business why
don't we just put all of our effort in
solving that problem and so I'm a big
believer and this is the the piece that
I want to share with you mosination is
that I'm a big believer in the theory of
constraints which means that a system
will grow until it is constrained right
it has a constraint and once you remove
the constraint it'll continue to grow
right until it reaches another
constraint and so
most people are always curious are many
people ask me hey Alex how did you
achieve quote so much in quote such
little time or at such a young age and I
say all that in quotes because so much
could be and young age whatever but I'm
saying I'm just I'm paraphrasing all
right and I think that
um one of the things that we have done
well is prioritizing what problems to
solve
and that is understanding the
prioritization of problems and realizing
that there is really only typically one
or two things that are constraining our
growth and by definition there'd really
only be one thing that's the constraint
until we reach another thing that might
be beginning to constrain us but isn't
the true constraint yet with setting the
tone and the reason that my views on
business have dramatically shifted is
that I have always had a tendency to
lean towards strategy acquisition
monetization pricing structures and all
of that stuff is important but I think
within a business there are two
components to it you've got the smarts
and you've got the hearts and you have
to have both and I think that most
people overestimate the importance of
smarts myself included and I think that
there's a lot to do with the hearts
because business strategy overarchingly
is not that complex but like you really
think about it right it's like you got
to find something that's good that
people want and you sell it for a lot
more than it costs you to do it and you
do as much of that as you possibly can
like that's kind of the idea right and
the thing is is
it gets lost in the execution it get
lost in the doing right as soon as you
hire first employees you're like no
employees can't boys can't do what I can
do it's like well that's a horrible
belief you should probably change that
before we try and move forward that's a
limiting belief right if you want to
have a big business and so when I think
about this from a cultural standpoint
and this is what has shifted for me is
that it's become so much more about the
soft skills it's so much more about
coaching and developing the leaders of
the company it's it's so much more about
addressing behavioral dynamics of
someone that are limiting them more so
than it is about tinkering and I can't
help but think that so many
entrepreneurs myself included I spent so
much time tinkering and and tweaking
things like what if we change this in
our sales process what if we change this
on this page what if we change the offer
like this what do we change this on the
pricing what if there's another payment
terms blah blah all these different
things right and think about this for a
second for yourself how many things have
you tinkered with in your business over
the last however many years how many
months and your business hasn't changed
at all right
because the real problem is not the
strategy the problem is not the smarts
right the problem is the heart right the
people are not doing what you want them
to do because they don't understand why
they need to do it and why it's
important right and that's the soft
stuff and you've got you know people who
don't want to talk to each other because
they don't like each other because one
guy's really annoying and so it's like
it would be it would better serve you to
fix that problem than to try and come up
with some new strategy right realizing
that has been one of the biggest
breakthroughs that I've had in my career
those two stories should illustrate the
difference between
um having a championship mentality and
having a loser mentality and what might
be going on in your business and I'll
leave you with one more story really
quickly so if any of you has ever
been on a championship team right if
you've ever played in a sports uh Arena
or whatever and you've been on a winning
team you've been on losing team right
and you've probably been on a losing
been a lot of good players but you guys
were not connected you weren't concerted
you weren't aligned right on the flip
side you had a winning team and it was
like everyone should have to practice
everyone you know tried their hardest it
was the effort and the consistency and
the alignment of the team that
accomplished the goal the rules were the
same everyone was trying to do the exact
same thing and so when you think about
the entire business landscape right your
competitors have access more or less to
the same talent pool that you do they
can see what your strategy is overall
and most people are not that dumb right
and so as long as you have a relatively
sound strategy like you're not selling
things at a loss right then the
difference between the two is going to
be your ability to execute and have
people execute on your behalf and so
that's going to become that like for us
as CEOs we do shift Wars becoming
championship team coaches which is why
John wouldn't if he had run a business
would have had a championship business
because he focused on the fundamentals
and one of my favorite sayings of all
time is Advanced people never don't do
the basics Advanced people never don't
do the basics I would go to I would go
to these stages and I'll watch guys get
on stage and they'd say you know we we
follow up with all of our leads you know
within five minutes you know when we get
on sales calls we always ask them why
they're there we label them a problem
you know we overview some of the past
things they've done and then they follow
a clear framework that as soon as
someone buys we you know we have a good
onboarding process and nothing they say
is revolutionary it's just that they
actually do it and the people are
actually on their behalf they're not the
Vince or don't have a manager like Vince
who's telling them they don't that they
shouldn't have to do that work right
who's sabotaging the business what they
did is they set the tone and then they
carry the bar and so their job is to be
intolerant of anything but excellence
and to reinforce that in the culture so
that it's consistently executed across
the company because that between two
companies with the same strategy will
make the difference between somebody who
who yields disproportionate Returns on
Advertising crazy profits good growth
great retention on employees low
turnover from a company that doesn't
have that right even though they both
have the same strategy or even if the
smaller company has the better strategy
this guy will win and this has been one
of the most profound shifts that I've
had most business strategies are not
complicated find something people want
charge a lot of money for it and deliver
that thing really well so much so that
they tell other people about your
product it's not overwhelmingly complex
to consider the execution is difficult
but the concept is not and so a lot of
people think they're going to win on
strategy when they're starting a
business when you could have two people
who have lawn care companies and one
person has a lawn care company worth a
billion dollars one person that can
barely break five thousand dollars a
month it's not because the strategy is
significantly different it's just the
execution how is it that an entrepreneur
or two entrepreneurs can start at the
exact same time and one can be get 10 20
30 times faster or when you start over
again you can always skip these steps to
get to your level of incompetence my
theory around this comes down to pattern
recognition and let me explain it's not
just pattern recognition from the
perspective that you have strategies are
something that you're you're recognizing
but actually patterns in people and so
I'm going to give this a quick story to
drive this this point home I have
struggled for the last decade to find an
assistant and so it's one of the things
I'm actually you know a little
embarrassed about but I I've gone over
seven on assistance
um so much sort of the point that I was
just I almost kind of gave up just even
trying to find an assist done and until
recently I every time I had an assistant
it just always right off the bat it just
never felt like right and I always was
like yeah maybe it'll get better it'll
get better at it and they just never
really did and the problem was that I
didn't know what it looks like when it's
right and so in the videos that I talk
about I use the word the term ideal
scene I don't know what the ideal scene
of this Dynamic looks like when we are
scaling companies right and I'll tell
you what I found out there in a second
but like when we're scaling companies
what we have to do is pay down ignorance
tax of knowing what ideal scene looks
like which is where speed comes from
having people who have outside eyes look
in who already do know what I still
ideal scene looks like so you can skip
steps faster and so I'll give you an
example what this looks like in real
life like for me in the role of
executive assistant thank God that like
for me it wasn't a necessary thing to
continue to grow the businesses now that
I have one I don't ever really want to
live life without one but
the entire time I kept bringing people
in I didn't know what to look for we do
hiring you know we do the hiring process
we do an onboarding and training process
they never really got up to speed or we
never really got in sync and then I'd
slowly kind of Fall Away there would be
distance and then it became kind of
awkward and then I would end up having
to cut the relationship and so in this
instance we immediately synced up I
really like the person I trust the
person and they are so proactive in all
aspects of my life that I just sit down
and start working and then she places
things in front of me I'm like hey I got
13 minutes she's like cool do this I'm
like I've got you know 18 minutes here
she's like cool do this and do this and
every time I'm done I'm like hey what
else should I do and she's like boom and
so we meet based on the priorities that
I have and then she has this big stack
and knows how long every every one of
these things takes because I talked to
her about how long I think the tasks
will take and then as I have openings we
slot it in so it's like I wake up and
I'm just crushing work until the end of
the day because I know that the amount
of time that's been allotted for each of
the task is the appropriate amount of
time and so and if I do finish early I
get another task done right and so we
can we can we can Crush stuff me quoting
my job was the single hardest decision
that I've ever made in my entire life
and I mean that genuinely it was the
hardest decision that I've made it took
me six months to do it and I listened to
Arnold's rules of success speech every
morning when I wake up about you know
it's okay to fail and I had to keep
saying this stuff because I was so
outwardly driven I was so status driven
that I didn't want to take the risk of
being seen as a failure and so it only
was when I was literally confronted with
my own you know the fact that I was
really not even willing to be alive
anymore is when that was kind of my
jogging to awakenness moment where I was
like you know what if I don't even want
to be alive anymore then what's worse
than that and so that was what
ultimately shot me on the trajectory to
you know quit that job sell the condo
put everything that I had in my car and
I drove across the country in 36 hours
to California which is where I thought
the land of Fitness opportunity would be
now mind you I was a Management
Consultant we did space cyber and
intelligence for the military at a
subcontractor or Booze Allen if you're
familiar with that consulting firm and
that's what I did for two years sounds
really you know cool and sexy but it was
not at all for me and I really did not
enjoy it but I learned some valuable
lessons like how to learn while I was
there and so I think that what most
people you know it really depends on who
you are and understanding your skill set
and honestly and how much pain you're in
and so there's also different ways to
satisfy that pain I think true to my
core if I had been in a different
company or I was working on different
projects at that time in my life I
probably would have never quit it was so
hard for me and I didn't have a wife I
didn't have kids I had zero dependence
and I lived on nothing and it was still
one of the hardest decisions of my life
because I'm very risk-averse so believe
it or not most entrepreneurs you know a
lot of people talk about how they you
know they didn't do well in school and
you know teachers never understood them
and they always knew they had to go out
on their own I never had any of that I
worked really hard in school I did
really well in school teachers liked me
for the most part and you know I got a
good job afterwards and so I did not
have the traditional entrepreneur
journey and it was only because I was so
sad deeply depressed in that time in my
life and felt so empty that I actually
made the jump and so I think the first
thing is like one are you are you
incredibly sad are you incredibly
dissatisfied with your life so much so
that you'd be willing to uproot and
change number one number two
entrepreneurship is not easy and so if
you need I think Elon Musk said this on
a clubhouse meeting and I just think
it's so true people are like what words
of motivation would you give for a new
entrepreneur if you need motivational
quotes or motivational words then
entrepreneurship isn't for you and I
tend to agree with him like if you need
that motivation like it is one of the
loneliest paths period you know at least
in co-workers you have other people who
are around you you can but when you
start on your own you're starting at
zero with no one and basically no one's
rooting for you like for me when I left
like no one really supported me my
parents thought I was stupid and that
this was a stupid idea I was throwing my
education away and I was risking
everything to go start a gym right which
is really not even that good of a return
on investment you know what I mean but I
was so committed to the fact that I was
so miserable that I was like at least I
can just live my life doing something
that I enjoy I don't even care if I make
money and that was literally the the
mindset that I was able to to quit with
and so I don't again I don't know where
you're at but the first piece of this is
understanding short and long-term
payoffs I did not make a significant
amount of money for years after I quit
my job all right so I'd say for the
first four years I I essentially broke
even and made less money than I did as a
consultant all right so like think about
that for a second right now there's a
lot of mistakes I made too and you're
going to make them as well because none
of us is perfect there's so many skills
that you have to like you have to
acquire so many skills to run a business
right and so you may have a single job
right now and you were you were doing
one specific function of one specific
sub-department of a business but in
order to be an entrepreneur you have to
understand all of it right in order to
be a successful entrepreneur so you have
to understand how to generate demand you
have to generate understand how to
generate leads you have to understand
how to work leads you have to understand
how to sell you have to send how to
fulfill and deliver and how to manage
people how to communicate how to relay
expectations how like how to recruit how
to hire how to interview like there's so
many things that you have to learn and I
don't want that to be overwhelming I
just want to confront you with Rihanna
because honestly if I knew
how hard it was going to be when I
started my first business I don't know
if I would have done it I just I forced
myself into a hole and I always like to
say this is you'd be surprised what you
can accomplish when you have no choice
as dark and morbid as I mean as what I'm
going to say is and don't get triggered
by this but like the fact that an entire
race in our country was enslaved for
hundreds of years and was still able to
do that every day shows the strength of
the human spirit and what is possible
when you have no choice and so I think
that to juxtapose what I said about how
hard it is if you can put yourself in a
position where you have no choice you
will be successful right if you want to
succeed as bad as you can breathe you
will be successful and so I think that
was the situation where I was in where I
was I knew that the alternative to what
I was doing was death for me and so it
was just anything is better than this
and honestly the next you know year of
my life even after that was still
incredibly hard but it was different but
it was still incredibly hard I mean
we're big fans of imperfect action and
so and I think that we're also at least
I'm a big student like you learn through
doing not through preparing to do uh
because I think a lot of times you learn
as you're doing what things you thought
were important at the onset are
significantly less important so it's
like you know I think the thumbnails and
the headlines and the first you know 20
seconds matter a lot more than spending
an hour setting up the lighting you know
what I mean and so it's just like return
on time and effort
um and so yeah so I mean if we want to
learn something new at least in the
companies that we have it's like we just
start doing we pull we pull the thread
that we can see and we just keep pulling
and figure it out as we go and I think
we end up getting to where we're trying
to go faster just through ex giving
ourselves permission to suck if you're
just starting out I think that for the
most part it's better to not have
Partners
um and that is because usually it's like
unibody and you're like hey we like
hanging out we should go into business
together when really you're you're doing
that for the emotional need to be
satisfied to have somebody to talk to
and share the experience with but not
because it's a good business decision
and the only reason for you to have a
partner is because they either have
money or skills that you do not have
that is it it's the only reason money or
skills that's it and so if you both are
entrepreneurial people and you're both
you know love selling I love marketing
you're very promotion oriented which
many entrepreneurs are right if that's
you
then if they're that way too then one of
you is not required and you have to
really face that it almost always fails
like literally it almost always fails
and so that's the first one the second
thing is that those jump into bed to be
other Partnerships don't have step
number two which is you don't have a
contract you don't have terms you don't
have an agreement and the reason is
because you're so afraid of like messing
up the vibe we don't operate that way
you will when it gets at the end but I'm
telling you right now I I now even when
I have somebody who approaches me and
says hey like will you take a percentage
of my company can you coach me through
this blah blah blah I say let's go
through the lawyers first all right
because the thing is is you get to see
how this person acts under stress
because it is stressful because
inherently you're going to disagree on
things and so this is the perfect
experience like perfect time for you to
go kind of get a simulation of that it's
like well what happens if you don't want
to work and I want to work what happens
if you leave what happens if I I don't
want to do this anymore well like you
have to go through all the scenarios and
get a good lawyer and you should really
have two that represent you uh if you
don't have the money for that then get
somebody to just counsel you on you know
you can Google a standard partnership
agreement there are templates for free
online and you can pay one lawyer for
one hour of of time to at least say
these are the things you should look for
now you know decide amongst yourselves
and so you can represent yourself in
your partnership you know agreement but
you have to have the agreement and you
have to spell it out in clear terms uh
because if you don't have that it's like
it's the Bedrock of good communication
and expectations right like otherwise
usually like most relationships
Partnerships end because of unmet and
unspoken expectations like well I
thought you're gonna do this I was like
well I didn't know but no one even says
that because it can't communicate so
first is you probably shouldn't just
jump together with somebody because they
uh they're just like you
if you are going to do that then you
should make sure that you have contracts
in place and then finally what I want to
do is kind of explain to you what the
three main roles roles that exist in a
business are okay three the three
pillars all right I want to see if I
have a tripod here all right here we go
here's my tripod all right so there's
three pillars
to every business all right the first is
acquisition which is The Rainmaker or
somebody who's gonna bring in business
so that's marketing and sales all right
acquisition the money getter all right
the second of these is the product which
is what you are actually selling it's
the Fulfillment it's the service it's
the widget it's the whatever somebody
who knows how to deliver it all right
and then third
you have the operations which is
everything else that has to happen in
the company paying payroll paying taxes
making sure legal and contracts and I.T
and uh you know finance and all like the
uh you know you're accounting all of
that stuff HR has to happen right and so
these are the three legs of every
business now they're not necessarily
equally weighted and that's it's an
important point right like a lot of
times there are good operators that you
can get for significantly less and many
times not even Equity
um because there are more of them right
now rainmaking being able to bring in
business is a very highly valued skill
in the marketplace on the flip side
having the thing the product that you're
going to sell is also very valuable now
this is why skill stacking is so
important if you can have multiple of
these skills then you have two or all
three of the legs right now your these
are the roles that have to exist it
doesn't mean you have to be partners
with these people but you have to have
all three of these things for your
business to stand up and so for example
within uh the company I'll walk through
my roles within each of the companies
that I own
and so uh the first is gym launch right
so in gym launch I am both the
acquisition and the product right
or that was my founding role within the
company Layla my wife runs ran all the
operations so everything else so like I
said it billing legal uh Finance HR all
of that stuff that had happened she took
care of right super important but
because of that we had all three legs of
the stool and we were able to build a
business right if you're missing one of
the legs it's not going to work right if
and with this is where this is really
dangerous is like a lot of the marketing
people that are in this world are really
good promoters they can get people in
they can sell them but then they have no
fulfillment they have no thing right and
then they have no one who's organized
and so everything like you send emails
in you try and get help and they don't
respond it's because they just don't
have the other piece I don't think it's
because they're bad intentioned I think
just don't have the skill and so you
have to have all three and so if you're
going to bring someone in
you you need them to have one of those
things right now you can start a
business and own all of it and just make
sure that you fill the roles with those
people but as you're thinking through it
there's the rule so if you're going to
bring Partners in in the beginning you
want to be clear about what it is that
they're bringing to the table now if
they're if they're one of those three
right then that's a clearly defined role
and then at that point that's what you
can lay out in your agreement and then
you can argue about or you know
negotiate whatever Equity if you're
doing this in the beginning but if
you've already started at that point
then you can look at the three legs of
the stool and see where where am I
lacking right and so for most of you
guys who are listening most people like
the promotion side so they like the
acquisition side
then what you need to do is find a
strong operator all right and depending
on what you're selling if you know the
thing that you're selling then you can
basically be product and acquisition and
have a strong second to help you fulfill
on those things and basically don't go
to jail right and you know get file your
taxes and all the other stuff
um and so when I'm thinking about
Partnerships and when I have you know
younger guys who are coming in many many
times after having discussions with me
and then talking to them each other they
realize that they had the exact same
role they like the same things and one
of them is not necessary and so they
oftentimes split and that's not a bad
thing right it's better to recognize an
error early than to recognize an error
late all right and so you may be in one
of these Partnerships where you're like
we gotta both do the same thing we kind
of just overlap on everything it's like
yeah that's just two people working the
same thing
um and so it's not like you don't want
to just be like oh there here's all this
work I'll do half you do have that's not
a good partnership you have to figure
out what are the things where I am good
at what are the things you are good at
and then we draw a line on the board and
everything on that side you own
and everything on this side I own and
I'm responsible for because if
everyone's responsible for everything no
one's responsible for anything right and
then nothing's going to get done and
then you can never know who to blame and
someday you're like well he takes out
the trash or I sometimes I take out the
trash and we just kind of we're just
like kind of get it done type stupid
there's no there's no big business that
works that way all right and so if even
if you are small you need to start
thinking big to become big right so you
got to do the actions before you get the
results you have to have the beliefs
before you get the outcomes of a bigger
business to become a bigger business and
the reason most businesses stay small is
because they think small and they act
small so they stay that way because the
outcome of what they're doing is the
result of the actions they're making
which are small right and so right now
if you're in a partnership
if you don't have a partnership you're
thinking about starting a business
I would definitely try and just acquire
the skills myself
get going and then the first hire I'm
going to have is going to be a strong
operational second right it's the first
thing I'm going to do if you are in a
partnership you need to put all the
activities that you do on a board I do
this when I do consulting stuff but all
the activities that happen in the
business on the board if you don't know
what it is you do a Time study which
means you write down every 15 minutes
what you do in a week right because you
probably don't know because you
scattered all over the place so if you
write it all down and you both bring it
to each other and you put it on a
whiteboard or put it on board then what
you can do is say okay these are all the
things these are all the activities that
happen in our business
let's divide these out and say who owns
these all right and that's the very
beginning of an organization because you
are becoming organized you are creating
roles and responsibilities you're
creating specialization of skills which
is what moves Humanity forward
specialization is a good thing right and
so the very beginning you get all of it
on there and you can divide it out and
you can divide it based on the skills of
the person if you both have the same
skills then either need to decide okay
well I'm going to become a specialist in
this and you're going to become a
specialist in this or we shouldn't be
doing this business together and you
should do a business that's just like
mine or or something else and you should
become and you should be that role for
that company and you should find a
second just like Iowa all right and
oftentimes if you can at least think
that way then you don't lose you don't
liquidate the most valuable thing in the
whole world which is your Equity all
right because if your thing actually
does grow if your business actually does
grow
then the biggest dilution of how much
money you're going to make is that first
decision when you started when you just
decided just right off the bat to give
half of everything away so first off I'm
a big believer in continuing to take
dividends out of a business as it
continues to grow and that's because you
want to decrease your downside risk
right because for some reason and the
statistics are very likely that the
business will not succeed in the long
term you know 90 whatever it is 90 or 95
of businesses fail within five years and
so uh it's it's much better in my
opinion to consistently take money out
of the business as you're growing it
because there's a very high likelihood
that it will not stick around A and B
many entrepreneurs have this idea that
they're going to sell their business for
some magical number sometime in the
future when in reality only one percent
of businesses ever sell and so if that
is the case again well I would rather
not stack the chips on a 91 to one bet
it does happen but the likelihood is low
and so I would like to take chips off
the table table on a regular basis so
that is the first part which is making
sure that we're taking money out the
second question is okay well now that I
have this money this 500 this million
this whatever what should I do with it
right and so one of the big things is I
just like to think about this through
the lens of opportunity cost which is if
I'm currently making let's say uh 500
000 a year right from my business in in
net free cash flow that's owner earnings
what I get to take out of the business
after reinvesting in in the growth and
competitive advantage that we need to
continue to maintain to to grow right so
if I have 500 000 of net free cash flow
that's coming to me and let's say I've
got a million dollars saved up if I were
to if I were to passively invest that I
should get about 10 ish a year right
that's just going to be investing
through uh indexes like the S P 500 Etc
right if I'm doing that then the
advantage of actively investing might be
the marginal difference it might be an
extra five or ten percent so that'd be a
50 to 100 increase because 10 to 15 is a
50 increase right but if I look at it in
terms of real terms uh just purely on
how much my net worth is going to
increase which is the lens that we have
to look at this through which is the
opportunity cost if I were to spend half
of my time thinking about actively
investing because it will take up half
your your mind space I promise you
because I've done this mistake before I
made this mistake before then what
happens is your active income will fall
at a disproportionate rate compared to
what uh your money is making you so let
me I'll walk you through a numbers
example so let's say you've got that
million dollars and you can get 10 a
year which is 100 Grand on 100 possible
Right but the additional 50 or 100 000 a
year uh 50 to 100 000 a year which would
be five to ten percent of that million
right you can get through actively
investing well if you're currently
making 500 000 a year from your business
do you think it would be reasonable to
take half or 25 of your time to go chase
that when you could probably get your
income from 500 to 750 000 in the next
year 500 to a million and so for me that
was always the opportunity cost of
actively investing which until my wealth
became so large that I felt like it was
out the opportunity cost of the money
that I should be making by paying more
attention to my money it was going to
outpace my income which is still almost
not there and so for me that is why as
for entrepreneurs it's my belief that a
you should be ripping out cash on a
regular basis because that's downside
risk protection it's not your upside it
is downside protection it's the fact
that what if my business does not
succeed as much as I'm a big believer in
being optimistic you also have to face
reality and confront facts which is the
likelihood that this particular business
that you're on I've had 13 businesses
that I've started up to this point and
now I own eight more the likelihood that
the business that you start is going to
be the one that you finish with is
extremely extremely extremely low right
extremely low and the likely that you're
going to sell that business for a big
number is extremely extremely extremely
low and so you take this money out and
you put it into the s p or you put it
into an index because it is passive and
you can put it there and the idea is
that you never have to think about it
again now the amount of money that you
should keep in cash uh in in my belief
is it should have about six months two
years worth of normal living that's
saved up in cash and that's just so that
you can sleep well at night and that's
it the other thing is that when you
invest that into indexes and whatnot you
can always take a loan against those
assets if you wanted to start something
big so it's not like it's illiquid uh
when it's there you can take loans
against those assets at 60 or 70 percent
uh loan to value meaning if you have a
million dollars in assets uh in the s p
most banks will give you 60 70 of that
uh or at least 50 right depending on the
stocks in in your history with them et
cetera that will give you basically for
free right they'll give you at one
percent or two percent uh money that you
can go and reinvest in starting another
business or buy a piece of real estate
or whatever right and so for
entrepreneurs it is my belief that you
should be investing most of your time
and energy or almost 100 of your time
and energy and growing your income
growing the main vehicle you have but
extracting the money and putting it into
a low brain vehicle that's not active
that's passive that's truly passive not
real estate flipping that's not passive
right truly passive if you're in crypto
right or you have some speculative stuff
that you that you want to get into it's
probably taking up way more of your
attention than it should be and it's
actually going to make your main income
suffer which means your net worth will
grow more slowly than it otherwise would
so it's all about the opportunity cost
of your attention all right now I'm
going to put this special note out here
for employees if the the primary
objective of the employee in my opinion
is to increase how much your income is
and so all of yours in this goes for
entrepreneurs too the the initial parts
of your investment should be growing to
increase your skills because that
increases your basis that increases your
basic income that you can continue to
yield from the marketplace based on your
skill set and so this is where I think
people step you know they step out over
dollars to pick up pennies if you're
saving you know 500 a month there's
nothing wrong with that but I would be
actively investing that 500 or the
Thousand or two thousand dollars a month
in the beginning into making my skills
more valuable because I know that if I
do that in two years I might quadruple
my income because that's the thing is
that your ability to earn is one of the
greatest Investments that's not just a
billionaire saying it really is like you
can like if you develop the skill of
selling which might take you two years
you can go from making sixty thousand
dollars a year to two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year or 500 000 a
year which puts you in the top one
percent just by earning that one skill
and so if you can develop that skill it
is worth the investment in most
investments in self-improvement are so
disproportionately low that it is worth
the investment even if there are courses
that you only get a handful of things
from you are still as yourself an asset
more valuable at the end of the day you
are the source you're the source of
where all the money comes from so it's
like when people don't invest in
themselves it makes no sense to me I've
spent every dollar I possibly could
gaining access uh getting mentorship
getting coaching getting programs buying
courses buying books and and doing that
stuff because I'm the source right if I
can improve me as the machine that
generates all the flow of income then
the rest of the stuff becomes easy right
and so first and foremost you have to
invest in that after you have an excess
of that then start pulling the dividends
out of the business that you have
investing those things that are passive
not active and then at the point where
your net worth from your investable
assets what 10 of that net worth growth
would be is in excess of what you make
per year then at that point it makes
sense to start shifting your perspective
towards managing wealth and growing
wealth rather than growing income a lot
of people struggle with this they
believe that they are inherently bad at
things because they are not good at them
and I think that that is an incredibly
dangerous belief set to have and so what
I want to do is kind of break that
belief sit down to hopefully break it
for you so I think one of the most
valuable beliefs because you know in
terms of building on success in my
opinion first you need to develop skills
that need to develop character traits to
make sure that you do those skills and
then you have to make sure that your
beliefs are correct so that you can open
up the world right but the beliefs are
kind of imbued throughout the entire
process because if you don't believe you
can acquire skill you never will right
if you don't believe you can have a
character trait you never will
and so
um I was having a conversation with a
friend of mine who's looking to you know
switch career paths you're trying to
figure out she wasn't making as much
money she wanted to make
and the issue
um that she was dealing with she's like
she just doesn't have a valuable enough
skill set right and she's like I want to
make this much money and I was like well
you're never going to do that doing what
you're doing right
um and I was like have you considered
learning how to sell right I mean
because if you sell you have a far you
know if you still have the desire for
security but if you know how to sell you
can you know pretty much write your own
paycheck if you know where to look and
um she was like I'm not I'm not good at
sales I'm not a salesperson and I was
like well how many hours of sales
training have you gone through it was
like oh you know none and I was like
well then why would it be reasonable for
you to be good at sales
right like that doesn't that doesn't
make any sense of course you're not good
at sales like you haven't done it right
well it's so it's the same thing like
well I'm not a very marketing type
person I was like well how many courses
have you gone through how many hours a
day do you spend studying marketing well
you know none well then why is it
reasonable that you like why would it it
would be unreasonable for you to be good
at this skill given the amount of
investment you've made right and so it's
this it's this recurring thing that I've
seen over and over and over again
um and it also it presents itself in
different ways like I you know I'll
speak at some event or something and
I'll start getting into very basic math
about about business just business math
like you know how much does it cost to a
Car customer how much what's the
lifetime value things like that and I
can see people starting to freak out
because they're like I'm not good at
math
and I have to lean back and our lean you
know pressure onto that belief because
one that's a belief that will literally
never serve you it's like saying like I
hate employees it's like well good luck
owning a business that you want to grow
to any appreciable scale right
um but with the math example most you
can you can you can massively succeed in
business knowing only out like not even
algebra just basic multiplication
subtraction division like if you just
know how to do that that's all you need
to do in just about everyone knows how
to do those things and at the very least
has a calculator who can do
multiplication division at addition and
subtraction that's it that's all you
literally need and the thing is is that
people mistake
that they are bad at math
when in reality they do not understand
the concepts that create the math
right cost per acquisition right okay
that's a math statement just expressed
in words and so everyone gets tripped up
and then they say I'm bad at math when
in reality they just don't understand
the term and by doing that they
inherently limit themselves from
learning because they have this checkbox
in their head that as soon as it gets
difficult they say ah I'm bad at this I
am bad at this I identify with being
poor at this thing and therefore will
never succeed at this thing that's a
requirement for being successful
and so
I think that for me one of the
Cornerstone beliefs that I that that has
helped me a tremendous amount I just
want to share it with you is that if
someone can therefore I can
and sure is that does that necessarily
mean that you're going to you know go to
the go to go to Mars it's like no one's
ever done that before I think that's the
next level belief no one's ever done it
and I'm going to be the first right but
I think if you can at least just believe
that if someone has done it it is
therefore possible and therefore I can
do it too if I do the same things and
the nice thing about actions is that
they are agnostic to your level of
deservingness and skill
what I mean by that is if you spend an
hour a day practicing sales
over a year you will likely be in the
top
ten percent five percent two percent of
people because most people do nothing
most people do absolutely nothing except
for deal with their emotions on a
regular basis and procrastinate and give
themselves reason for why they are not
successful besides the obvious one which
is that it is not reasonable that they
would be successful given the amount of
time and effort they've put in to
achieving it and so
um I the only reason for this is because
I had that conversation I spoke at The
Mastermind where the girl talked about
uh not understanding the math
um I I and just there's just so many
repeated of you know events like this
where it's like can you ask yourself
with reason would it be reasonable for
me to be good at this skill given the
investment I've made and uh as a
corollary as an antithesis to that
example I've got an 18 year old kid who
lives across the street from me
um and I sort of you know semi-mentor
him
um he's a good kid he works super hard a
lot of hustle and the thing is is he's
too young to know that he can't do
things yet
and what that does is it makes them
incredibly dangerous because he hasn't
been slapped in the face by the world
yet and so he believes that he can
accomplish anything he has no reason to
think otherwise and so I've been
actively trying to speak that into him
um and now he's he's wholesaling real
estate right now he's 18 years old right
uh I love this right and how did he do
it he watched YouTube videos for free
right and then he picked up cold calling
because I was like this is a book you
need to read for cold calling and so he
just started cold calling based on what
the YouTube videos said off of a free
list that he found on the internet and
he closes for his deal as 18 year old
and so does he have an inherent skill no
but what I did was I prepared him
mentally by saying like you're going to
suck at this for a very very long time
and eventually after doing it so many
times it will be unreasonable for you to
suck and at that point you will be good
right and so I think if we can all
approach the skills that we feel like we
are deficient in with that kind of
concept of of course I am going to suck
it would not be reasonable for me to be
good
but if I do these actions it would over
time be unreasonable for me to be bad at
these things and I think by doing that
you unlock a different ability to learn
and by extension grow and so anyways I
hope you find this valuable uh it's just
it's a belief set that I find repeated
especially in people who are smaller
business owners who are getting started
Etc and it drives me nuts because it's
just saying that you can't do something
before you've even started and that's
why people spend so long in in the
beginner stages because they they
inherently dispel away their ability to
learn and get better because say well
I'm not good at that well obviously
you're not good at that you have not
done it duh first off if you redefine
the term from happiness which is which
is based on outside circumstances you
are happy as a reaction Joy comes from
within which means that I can be sad and
sorrowful and filled with joy you can
mourn and be joyful because joyful is
how you choose to experience the
circumstances so first I would redefine
the word that you're shooting for right
um the second thing is is asking like
but why right and so a lot of us want to
make money because we're like I want to
you know and and then and then when we
talk publicly it's like I want to leave
a legacy I want to leave an impact blah
blah blah blah right all that stuff I
want to help people but the reality is
that everything that you do that is
external achievement is ephemeral and
what it means is it literally only
exists on the physical plane and that
physical plane is temporary which means
it will end which means that all of the
achievements and all the things that
you're doing on this plane literally by
definition will have no lasting impact
and so if it means that nothing that you
do any all the things that you
accomplish and all the things or rather
the wealth that you accumulate will
eventually disappear it changes the
perspective somewhat and so the way that
I like to think about it is the analogy
of a casino and so I think all of us are
given a token when we're you know when
we come of age and start to get into the
game and we sit down at a table and we
play and we play and we play and we play
and the players around the table are
bragging about how they're how big their
chips are some players win some players
lose and more more chips get stacked
right but the difference between that
casino and the casino of life is that at
the end of the day you leave the table
with your chips still on it and you
don't cash out and then everyone takes
the chips that you had there so you're
playing a fake game with fake money
and so I think when you realize that
like you can buy a castle you can buy a
house
and there's a person in India who has no
shoes who has more joy in their life you
realize that none of the things that we
do to accomplish
serve any real meaning whatsoever they
really just act as the shovel that we
use to dig the holes
that we're going to fill back up at the
end of the day when we die and so it's
like what shovel do you want to use to
dig your hole
and so I like to think of those things
as what things do I inherently find joy
in
and so for me I enjoy learning and I
learn through teaching and so that is
how I derive meaning
and the only thing that I can dedicate
my life to that is eternal are things
that will last past the physical plane
which are values and so if you can shift
your decision making process from
outcome based decision making process to
value-based decision making process
you'll always feel in alignment with
your identity and so for me when I
experience alignment between what I
truly believe what I say and what I do I
feel like I'm acting in the way that I
that is in alignment with who I am and
so I think that a lot of us have made
decisions or say things that are
contrary to what we believe or we do
things that are contrary to what we say
we do things contrary to what we think
and we experience dissonance and that's
most of our lives and so I think that if
you can free yourself into thinking I
can I believe these things to be true I
say them with certainty and and my life
is a reflection of those things which I
believe to be to be meaningful and I can
dedicate my life to that eternal value
and that value will exist after I die
and so that for me is is is kind of
where I derive meaning
from work
you are not successful in my eyes
because whenever you see some outcome
you stop the activities which means you
don't have the trait of consistency I
was like the reason you aren't where you
want to be is because you can't do
things repeatedly and so most people
can't do one thing over and over again
you need to be able to do the doing
without seeing the result of your doing
and you have to keep doing it and if you
can keep doing things independent and
this is both ways if it goes really well
you keep doing the thing that got you
there and if it's not going well comma
yet you keep doing the thing so that you
get good enough that one day it will and
that's the shift that most people don't
make and I think that's why most people
just stay poor and the reality is that
if you can commit to the actions and the
behaviors and the traits that you will
grow through doing then at the end of
this process a decade later you will be
the type of person who can do something
for a long period of time and wait and I
promise you that if you have that trade
money will never be a constraint in your
life and this is from Atomic habits
every winner and every loser have the
same goals
so when you measure Yourself by having
this external thing and people like set
goals
everyone wants to be rich everyone wants
to have a six-pack your goals don't make
you unique it's the activities that you
do that make you unique the goal of the
winner is to commit to the activities
the goal of the loser is to commit to
the goal 52 of 18 year olds High School
seniors think they're going to be
millionaires by 25. the world is going
to be shook
many of you will fail and that's because
most of you have the same goal 52 You
Think You're Gonna Be A Millionaire
right it's just math but only a small
percentage will because
if you want to be a millionaire you're
not going to focus on making a million
dollars you're going to focus on the
stuff that makes a million dollars and
so when you can divorce
the activities from the outcome then you
can focus on the doing which whether
your income does this over that period
of time your self-esteem Remains the
Same because you're committing to what
you can control if you can make that
shift
it will change your life so I started
making podcasts six years ago I
committed to that process when I signed
on with a YouTube vendor a few years ago
on the first call I said
I'd like to have this channel be
something in five to ten years I was
like We'll look at it then and see if it
was worth continuing to do I was like
but I'm in for a decade and he stopped
me afterwards he was like I've literally
never had a client say that to me ever
he's like they're all like how can I get
leads in the first 90 days from YouTube
and like blah blah I was like if we're
making progress
I'm good
I will commit to that I think that if
you can think that way you will get what
you want and then people will ask you a
decade from now man how did you have
this overnight success and blah blah
blah and aren't you like don't the
followers and the fans like how does it
not get to your head and you're like
because it was never the goal and so I
feel just as good at year one as I do at
year eight because the activities that I
committed to remain the same if you can
think that way and you can shift your
perspective it will it'll decrease your
emotional ups and downs and I think we
all need ways to decrease our emotional
ups and downs in the game of business
because like we need to have second
lives that their lives and the fourth
lives and the way to do that is to not
put your life your game playing life in
something that you can't control but
putting all your game playing life in
the things you can for me a very core
belief that has been I think intrinsic
to at least the material success that
we've experienced has been a belief that
meaning is
self-ascribed so that there is no
inherent meaning in the things that we
do or the actions we take or the
outcomes that happen but only that which
we ascribe to it and so because of that
I feel like it's allowed me to the point
of what you're saying about like the
amount of pain and the amount of
suffering that you have to go through in
order to to achieve the things on the
other side I think it's been able to
it's allowed me to reframe a lot of the
discomfort into what if this just is how
it always has been or what if this is
actually amazing
and what if this is exactly what it
should look like and so I think a lot of
times it's the it's the discrepancy
between our expectations in reality that
shape the emotions that we have in
response to any given situation bad good
Etc and so I think a lot of people can't
control their state and I we deal with
this with a lot of the portfolio
companies is it's like it's funny
because I don't even necessarily want to
get in this I want to talk about like
the business and what's the strategy how
we're going to execute this stuff but
you know there's a big percentage of
time where they're stressed and they
think there's something wrong with that
so I feel like
a lot of people feel like there's
something wrong with experiencing human
emotions
and so they are stressed and then think
there's something wrong with them
or they are sad and I know this is the
thing that the keyboards are you know
the fingers are right on top of it
it's my belief it is contrarian I accept
that
it's it's the beliefs we have about our
emotions that are the things that drive
us mad facts
and so somebody's sad and then they tell
themselves that they're they're bad
because they're sad or they're wrong to
be sad or they're because they're sad
um rather than saying isn't this a
beautiful thought about the human
existence like if I could not be sad
then I would not experience Joy so like
if I say that I don't want to be sad
anymore then I would also have to give
up Joy am I willing to do that no well
then this is just a part like I can't
say that I want sunny days if there are
no rainy days
like we don't say weather is good or bad
it just is
and so I think to the same degree The
Human Experience is also that way too at
least how I Define it and so I think
having that as my backbone frame in
terms of my worldview although
contrarian has helped me a lot in
dealing with the things that often
derail entrepreneurs on their path to
getting what they want and so for me
that's been very helpful so from a
contrarian standpoint of like Bully you
know Peter thiel's question like what
closely hopefully do you have that most
people don't agree with that's one of
them the biggest issue that most people
have is they don't have the ability to
discern what their Missing Link is or
what their next step is what's the if
you think about the theory of
constraints which is that a system will
grow until it's constrained and so what
happens is most people add potential to
a system but they don't actually
increase the throughput of the system so
for example if I had a a bridge right
and it has a weak Link in the bridge or
let's say a change probably simpler so
if you have a chain and you have to pull
two things the amount of force that you
can put on the chain is just predicated
based on the weakest link and so what
happens is that people reinforce a
strong link and not the weak Link in the
chain and so they add potential to the
chain but they don't actually add any
more strength that can be pulled and so
if you think about the amount of money
you're trying to make is up as the
amount of money that you're literally
trying to pull towards you that weak
link is going to be the skill deficiency
that you have and so most people solve
problems that aren't really there and
they spend a lot of their time
reinforcing skills that they enjoy but
that's not their deficiency and so
that's why like the entrepreneurship
thing is you have to be a jack of all
tradesmaster I've known you have to be
good enough to get the thing across
across the Finish Line to pull you know
pull the money towards you uh you don't
have to have the strongest link you just
need all the links to be strong enough
and so I think most people aren't good
at assessing their own deficiencies and
so if the follow-up question is how do
you assess deficiencies right how do you
know what's What's missing
the question is uh what are the revenue
generating activities within a business
how can I get myself closer to those
Revenue generating activities
um and so you can look at product as a
revenue generating activity you can look
at sales and revenue generating activity
you can look at marketing is revenue
generating activity and so if you think
about those as kind of the Three core
pillars of what businessing is and then
you have back of house right you've got
Finance you've got I.T you've got uh the
other pieces but the people who are sent
even in the back office know how to
generate Revenue and bottom line
for for their division so for example my
CFO uh Suzanne triplet she um you know
she led a 15 billion dollar acquisition
uh 5 billion or one billion the last
company she was at was 750 million she's
been dollar one to 100 million two times
so like she's she's been there and the
first thing she did on our like our
first interview she was like oh you
won't have to pay for me I was like and
she's paid very well
um and she's like you don't have to pay
for me she's like I'll save I'll save
more than what you're ever going to pay
me just first six months I'll save you
that and I was like oh cool and so smart
people know how to do that like like a
an intelligent you know video editor is
going to come and say dude I can 10x the
amount of views that you're getting on
this thing because he's going to tie
himself to marketing a good product
person is going to say I can I can
decrease our churn which is going to
increase your LTV I'm going to be able
to get more people to ascend because
they can have a higher MPS score and
they're more likely to want to keep
buying from us like so they have to just
figure out a way to tie whatever the
thing if they're really passionate about
something by all means go all in on if
you're I.T then you're thinking how can
I decrease page load times how can I get
conversion rates up you start getting
into the cro side how can I organize the
data in such a way that the CEO can make
better decisions and we have real-time
reporting against all the sales guys so
we can optimize our funnels towards the
best converting guys right like all of
all aspects of the business can make
more money but people don't think about
it through that lens so the first thing
is how do I tie what I do every day to
making more money in the business you
connect that dot and then you improve
that connection I get asked about
mindset a lot on podcasts they're like
when you're building a business or
you're building your career there are
stressors that come into play how we
manage the circumstances or the
conditions that come to us it dictates
how our life turns out everybody has bad
stuff happen you probably believed in
nodded your head like yeah everyone has
stuff happen and then we choose to make
it bad or good imagine for a second two
children that are playing one child
tells the other child your nose is
really big or you're fat
interesting is that the child who hears
it is unaffected and the child who says
it is unaffected they're like you're fat
and he's like huh parent comes in and
overhears it and she's like oh my God
takes the child that was called fat
Comforts them gives them the expectation
that they should be upset and then tells
the other one that that was bad and in a
moment there was something that is now
traumatic that otherwise wouldn't have
been and so when we're kids we walk into
the world with no meaning all we do is
we observe and then whatever the adults
around us tell us and say this means
that we take his fact and it's not not
true it's their interpretation of the
world and we inherit them and then we
spend the rest of our life trying to
undo and examine these beliefs that we
have been told by people that we
probably don't agree with when something
bothers you pull it out and look at and
say what happened and why is this bad
and what would it look like if it were
good and so the two tools that I use are
time and volume the volume example is
thinking okay I'm in traffic if this
happened every day would I be upset if
it happened every day I'd probably
expect it which means that I would not
be upset about it because it's just how
things always are if you want to make it
positive you say well what if every time
I got in a car normally it would take an
hour and today it took 30. I'd be pretty
excited about it and so all we did is
just change the volume on the
circumstance to recalibrate the meaning
that we're choosing to ascribe to it
good or bad I like to think of
circumstances a lot like weather which
is like you've got sunny days and you've
got rainy days and the problem in my
opinion is that people any day that it
rains they say is bad and day that's
Sunny they say is good when in reality
it just is it's just the weather
contrast is what create the quote good
and bad when reality there's just a
middle line and half of it's above and
half of its below then what we can do is
artificially move the line in our minds
by saying whatever this circumstance is
what would it look like if it were worse
and what would it look like if it were
worse all the time and if so then maybe
today's a good thing the second frame
that I like to use is time a hundred
years out but 10 000 years out how much
is this going to matter the reason
something affects you is because you
have deemed it meaningful you've said it
matters it's my world view that nothing
matters with a capital M like nothing
matters in the universe it doesn't
matter there's this statue of a head
that's in the Sands of Egypt all right
and it's bigger than this whole Road and
it's just the head it's worn out and
then scripted along the forehead it says
here lies
crazy name who own everything that the
eye could see the immortal so-and-so and
the only thing that was left was a worn
out statue head that no one knew who he
was and it was five thousand years old
if that guy who ruled the known world to
him wealth probably mattered right but
does it matter no probably not I've
relieved a lot of the pressure in my
life so that I could make better
decisions by zooming way out and
thinking ten thousand years from now
will this matter and if the answer is no
does it matter to me and then if I can
make the decision of like good or bad
based on my new context that I created
then I can live a life a lot easier and
so for me that helped me decrease
anxiety it helped me decrease sadness
around certain circumstances and I'll
give you the last example of this so I
had a cat named Bill Chill Bill rest in
peace homie Love the cat he died it's
like some freak heart thing or something
so you died in like two years when he
died I was bumped I was like this sucks
then I thought to myself what if cats
only normally lived six months how
stoked would I be that he lived four
times the normal length of a normal cat
I was like I'd probably be really stuck
I'd be like dude he lived a long life I
can't believe we had him this long and
all of a sudden my perspective around
the death completely changed I was like
I was so grateful that I got to have him
as long as I did when you play with time
and you play with volume first off we
have to be aware of the levers of
meaning that exist and then once you're
aware of them you can start moving them
in your favor and then looking at your
current conditions through different
lenses and say what would this mean if
it were amazing what would the
conditions have to be in order for this
to be an awesome thing and then all of a
sudden you just exit the game of happy
sad and get to be your own own game
maker at least that's what I tried to do
when I get upset look at it pull it
apart thing like is this real is this
true getting from a million to 3 million
is very difficult
um because you have to learn an entirely
new skill set which is like you have to
hire your first team right and that's
that's very difficult for a lot of
people
um you know three to ten is difficult
because you have to unlearn the thing
that made you successful up to this
point which is you're focusing on front
end rather than on product and back end
and so that becomes it's very difficult
it's like it's like spiritually
difficult at that point you know what I
mean once you're at three to ten you're
already out of the like I have to work I
have to cry my face off in terms of like
hours in because at some point the
amount of work that has to get done
surpasses your ability to work which
means you have to work through other
people
um you know at 10 million the difficulty
is you have to give up even more control
and so at each of these levels you're
giving up different types of control you
know in the beginning you're giving up
control of fulfillment
um the next level you're giving up
control of sales then you're giving up
control of you know finances things like
that then you're giving up control of of
marketing then you're giving up control
of managing all those things then you're
giving up control of leading you know
the company uh and so on and so forth so
like there's always this relinquishing
of control which is I would say
spiritually very difficult and it's easy
to say very hard to do and that's what
we look for in the portfolio companies
that we're thinking about taking on we
look at the CEOs and we're like do I
think this person has the humility to
give up control when it is required
jealousy is when you have a threat that
somebody is going to take something that
you have that they do not have all right
and so for example I'll give you an
example of each so Envy I may be envious
of a friend of mine so I was actually
talking to a good friend of mine who
runs a big weight loss company and right
now he's doing better than I am and now
I am envious of his success I am I can
feel it I'm envious I got off the phone
I was like I am envious of you right
on the flip side if someone comes to
talk to Layla right it is the fact that
they pose the threat of taking attention
or her attention that I think should
continuously belong to me that I would
feel jealous over I haven't had I
haven't felt jealousy in a long time but
that is that is an example it could also
be like with your kids if you have some
you know some other adult in their life
starts taking their attention or has
more influence over them you are jealous
of the influence that that person is now
is threatening your influence over your
child right so two examples they're
nuanced but I think it's important and
when I was talking to Nick Bailey about
this I was talking about how I think
Envy um gets a bad rap and I'm not going
to go into the spiritual religious side
of this or even the happiness side of
this because I think Envy absolutely
does not make you happy
but I do think that Envy will make you
successful all right and so this this is
where I want to kind of dive into this
Envy is adaptive right as human beings
this is actually from our old brain
right this is animals have this too they
are envious of one another and it's
because if in a group one person or one
being one animal whatever brings more to
the table you are now envious of that
person and what it does is it elevates
the rest of the group to go and achieve
the same which is good for the
collective not happier for each of the
individuals but is a pro survival tool
right and so for me understanding this
and at least being able to name the
emotion rather than saying I don't like
this guy or I'm angry at this person or
having this negative feeling that you
cannot put words to instead being able
to say I am envious has been very
relieving for me because now I can
actually tell those people hey I'm
envious of you and for some reason I
think it just creates another level of
Candor because it's a certain level of
vulnerability and saying you have
something that I wish I had but then
you'll notice that the conversation is
not defensive on that person's part most
of the time they're like well I'm let me
help you and it's only when we guys our
intentions or trying are trying to feign
you know pretend to be a different way
than we are where people also can sense
that you're being disingenuous like
great job man right when realize deep
down and they can tell from your your
subtle tonality changes and the way you
look that the um that you're actually
not happy for them right and so I think
if you can at least say it then it
actually gives you power now
in terms of judging your motivations
because obviously you might think that
Envy is a bad uh motivation
it is my belief that I would rather deal
with people who do good things for bad
reasons than bad reasons for good things
um or I said the same thing twice but uh
they do the right thing for the wrong
reasons rather than the wrong things for
the right reason all right I'd rather
someone who does the right outcome and
he gave me an example that was really
powerful he said a friend of his was a
top Navy SEAL
and uh you know one of the best Navy
Seals he trains Navy Seals just a total
badass right and before that he was an
EMT
and he talked about his experiences
being an EMT is that most people think
you know EMTs have to be really caring
you want them to you know they have to
save these people's lives every day and
he said uh the Navy SEAL was saying I
was not compassionate at all I didn't
really care that much about the person
who was on the table in front of me but
what I did care about was my stats I
cared about the status of being the best
I wanted to have the fastest to the
hospital I want to have the highest
survival rates highest success rates of
the people that were under my care
because I cared about myself being the
best and so the question is
if you were the person who was on the
table having a heart attack would you
rather have the compassionate EMT or
would you rather have the
self-interested EMT who is doing it for
status well if it were me I'd rather
have the guy who wanted to Pride himself
on being the best in the world and
didn't even care about me at all because
I knew his result was going to be more
Pro me than the other persons and so I
think that as as humans as entrepreneurs
we judge ourselves a lot on our
motivations and our in our intentions
but I think that if we can take a step
back and a name the emotion so that it's
not this amorphous thing that we can
understand but then take the next step
and say is this is this a pro-adaptive
emotion is this something that's going
to help me or is this an emotion that's
going to drive me to do something that
is negative and I think at least even
even in naming that we can increase the
time between emotion and action and the
further that time Gap is in general
the better the quality of the decisions
we make because the more rational we are
we're never completely rational because
we're we're emotion driven beings and we
have limbic systems that override things
but the more we can decrease the
triggers of the emotional triggers that
that cause us to make bad decisions
ultimately the better decisions we make
and so
I I say all this to say big picture
first naming the emotions is important
second it creates space so we can make
better decisions third we can analyze
those decisions and say is this
something that is going to help me in my
life or is this something that's going
to hurt me and then as a result of this
we don't have to judge ourselves as
strongly on why we are doing things and
rather what is being done because
candidly I am a very envious individual
and maybe this is me just
um
rationalizing my own negative you know
emotions who knows but at least for me
saying it that way and framing the
thought process in that way has helped
me feel uh better about myself and just
not or really just less bad if that's
probably a better way of saying it and
not constantly berating myself for
having desires that I think are wrong
and so uh Dan Sullivan said this and
I'll end with this is that
when people want something if you want
to make more money if you want to have a
bigger house you want to have a bigger
car you want to build a podcast Studio
whatever right
he said wanting is reason enough
because so many times we ask but why do
we want that
we're probably not going to change the
desire
and so letting us letting ourselves
desire things and giving ourselves
permission to desire things uh and
myself specifically has been incredibly
freeing and what it's done is given me a
tremendous amount of my attention back
that used to be allocated to analyzing
why I'm feeling this way or why this is
right or why this is wrong and instead
accepting the fact that I want something
and that wanting it is okay as long as
it is not something that is hurting
other people and that it's not something
that asserting me and so anyways I hope
that makes sense I hope that provides
you some value or hopefully maybe some
clarity around putting words to your own
emotions the decisions that results from
them and whether they are positive or
negative and eliminating the Judgment
from that equation provided it's
something that helps how do we behave
the reason that this is so important is
that it's one thing to know where you're
going but it's another thing to know how
you're going to get there and so this is
just as true in business Partnerships in
marriage in terms of what you want uh to
have happen and how you want to get
there as it is in business okay and so
what I want to do is actually just walk
you through the three values that we
have at acquisition.com and why we
believe them and so from an overarching
perspective the way to come to values
um is to look at what are the
non-negotiables okay and so what I mean
by that is and every company is
different because the core thing about
values is that they have to be things
that are true and innate to you right
like for example at Southwest uh have
fun is one of their core values and if
someone does not want to have fun or
does not believe in the processes that
they do to have a good time then that is
a non-negotiable for them that person
cannot work at that company it is a
fireable offense and so these are not
aspirational these are not things that
you would like to have these are things
that are core to who you are as a person
and as a team all right and so when you
decide on these non-negotiables they are
by their very nature non-negotiable
which means that you hire based on these
you Fire based on these and these are
the core Spirit of the team and some of
the mistakes that I see when people make
values is that one they don't draw the
line in the sand and so one of the core
things about a value is that it has to
you have to be able to say this is not
this right you have to be able to say
okay between Justice and mercy we lean
towards Justice or we lean towards Mercy
which means you have to repel people
with your values all right and so if
your values do not repel people then
they are not values they are platitudes
okay and so it's very important the next
thing is that when you're making your
values the values themselves need to be
ideally said in words that you would
normally say so if you have little
sayings inside of your community then
then a lot of times those can become
some of the values you have so for
example a gym watch one of our first
portfolio companies uh speed is King do
the boring work these were different
ways I mean we could just say work ethic
but that's not the way we would have
said it we could have said be fast or
fast turnaround times but speed is King
was the way we would have said it okay
and so some of the things that I've
learned with this is also you cannot
have too many values as in a say
differently you can have too many values
you have to be very selective at the the
true core values of the company all
right and so if you're you know between
two a lot of times you just have to
chunk up uh and kind of get a broader
value but they become the core and I
think that what we have found is that
three is The Sweet Spot and that number
is continued to distill down over time
but I think three is the amount that
your human brain can comprehend as
lenses to make a decision right and the
reason these values are so important is
that when you scale the company you have
to scale decision making which means you
have to scale the frame with which you
duplicate the decision-making process
which is should I hire this person even
though Alex is not involved in this do
they align with the core values and the
more stringent the values the easier it
is to have a black and white example of
I think this person means two out of the
three or one out of three but we only
accept three out of three and I will
tell you this as an additional point if
you have core values in the business I
would relay them to all aspects of your
your life if you would not do business
with someone for a decade do not do
business with them for a day it's one of
the navalisms that I like a lot and so
if you wouldn't if you don't want to
deal with this client for a decade don't
deal with them for a day if you wouldn't
deal with this employee for a decade
don't deal with them for a day you have
to and and the extent to which you hold
your line of intolerance around these
truly non-negotiables will dictate the
health of the organization and if you
make these non-negotiables and realize
that there are people in your
organization in your client base that do
not ascribe to these then you must make
the changes to fix it and that is the
pruning of the tree that will ultimately
grow the tree all right these are the
short-term pains for the long-term gains
recently I've been trying to toy you
with one that would create gratitude
there's a clip that went pretty viral
not that long ago it's also my number
one tweet of all time which is when I
was 20 I wanted to be a millionaire now
that I'm a millionaire I want to be 20.
when I'm 85 years old and in my mind I
imagine I will be a multi-billionaire at
that point I know that I would give up
everything that I have of material
wealth just to be poor and 20 again I
call this the frame of the grandfather
or the grandfather frame and it works
like this if you've ever looked at
pictures from your past and you look at
where you grew up or you look at you
know your old room or you look at a
picture of you with old friends doing
something we tend to feel these feelings
of nostalgia and I try to quantify like
what is Nostalgia so to me Nostalgia is
gratitude in the present for past
circumstances for whatever reason we're
able to kind of look past all of the
kind of minutia of how we were feeling
our moods and we're able to kind of like
see big picture the things that we are
grateful for take a pause here I'm sure
all of us have tons of childhood things
that we wish were different and blah
blah blah blah but there are still
elements of our past our childhood our
adolescence our teenage years our
college Years whatever it is right where
you feel grateful some of you guys are
superstars and are always grateful for
everything and I'm you know I'm Jelly I
don't roll that way it's not like I wake
up and I'm like man I just want to count
my lucky stars like just don't that's
just not how I function and I've been
trying this on and I I hope you do too
because it's been it's been really like
improving my life I tried to do this I
wake up thinking to myself if I were 85
years old and I got to go through a time
machine and be back in my body as I am
now to experience my life
from my 85 year old self seeing it again
if I wake up and I feel my body and I'm
like oh
this is so nice I don't have all the
joint pain ah my wrists don't have
arthritis and then I wake up and I'm
like I remember when we used to live
here even when I looked at Layla this
morning I was thinking to myself man
like this is my wife right at the
beginning of our marriage you know we're
only six years in we wake up and we walk
over to you know to have our coffee in
the morning which we always do and I'm
like isn't this so nice I remember when
you used to have coffee here together
this is great and I look out the window
look how young Vegas looks it doesn't
have all these buildings and these
flying cars like it does now it's it's
so underdeveloped compared to what it is
today and I feel gratitude for an
external just environment which I would
never really think that but I know that
my 85 year old self will totally
appreciate those things and as I'm going
through the day applying that frame also
to business where I can see that you
know the CEOs of our companies and the
people that work within our holding
company at acquisition.com they're
stressed about things and in my mind I'm
thinking oh isn't this cool that we get
to do this together isn't that fun isn't
that neat look how cute that is it is
the most powerful frame that I've
encountered I think the reason it's so
powerful is one it operates almost
entirely from a frame of gratitude that
for me I can feel for whatever reason
gratitude journals the meditations
things like that like I don't feel that
but thinking about my 85 year old self
being able to re-experience life through
my 32 year old body it's really shifted
how I see things and also decreases the
amount of anxiety and stress I have over
outcomes because I'm like this isn't
going to matter in the long run I also
think it helps from a business the term
loosely but like a business wisdom
perspective because when you think about
the decisions you think about it within
the larger context of your life and
you're not like oh yeah I'm going to
make that short-term dollars because
you're like I'm 85. I don't have
anything to prove you know what I mean
if you think about like the really
stressful things that you've had happen
in your past I feel Nostalgia for the
sleeping on the floor that I did at my
gyms for how tired I used to be at the
end of the day of taking 20 plus
consoles for months and months and
months on end and rather than feeling
stressed about it or resenting the fact
that I have to do it like I get to do
this I get to make videos talking to a
camera look at my 32 year old self-go
trying to make his content trying to
help other entrepreneurs like Isn't that
cool if I had to characterize seasons of
my life I would say I was very angry as
a teenager and young adult and then I
went from Angry to being aware of the
deficit between where I was and what I
considered to be happiness from there I
kind of switched to what I have
affectionately called the happiness
Mantra which I lived for a very long
period of time which was I stopped
trying to optimize for happiness at all
and just really stopped thinking about
it all together which I think moved me
closer to something that I would
consider to be Joy you can be joyful
independent of circumstance because Joy
is from within happiness tends to come
from external right it comes from
circumstance and I think when we look at
the grandparents or at least the people
that are older that I aspire to be is
like they just have an internal Joy they
have gratitude for being able to live it
one last time because the end of the day
like
it is our last time people have two sets
of resources right that they allocate
that they've got time they've got money
yeah and so if you look at someone's
bank statement and you look at their
calendar you know what their life is and
you can also predict where their life is
going to be in x amount of years right
and so if someone wants to change what
their life is going to look like you
have to reallocate where you're
investing the resources that you have
and so from a Time perspective people
who are poor in my opinion spend a lot
of time not doing stuff and that sounds
terrible to say but like at the base
level they're distracted they're not
doing the right stuff right well I was I
would even say not doing anything just
distracting them right playing video
games Netflix Etc you know all that
stuff right so they've got there's like
the basis like they don't do anything
they're purely distracting themselves
from their current state which is hard
because it's hard to confront reality if
you're like not happy it's easier to
just distract yourself right now the
level above that is you've got people
who are operating they are working every
day but they're operating in low
leverage opportunities right so they're
they're doing things that do not give
them a lot of return on their time right
and so it's like I could work it doesn't
matter how many hours I work at
McDonald's I like it's very very
difficult to come wealthy there right
just near impossible right
um versus like you could
buy a building for 10 million dollars
and then sell to somebody else for 11
you know for 11 million dollars just get
the contract and make a million dollars
on the exchange super high leverage
right from a Time perspective which is
crazy for somebody who doesn't have
money to even contemplate something like
that but the only way that that happened
and that required no money is skill
right and so like that's an example of
like it didn't require money to make
that money that's skill that's required
to do that and so
first is the time right people are not
doing stuff with the time that they have
or they're doing low leverage activities
for the time they have and then they're
not trying to increase their output per
unit time which means investing in their
skill set so like one of the easiest
ways to gain leverage on your time and
and when I say leverage just for
everybody like Leverage is the
difference between inputs and outputs in
a system so
um you know archimedia said if you give
me a lever long enough I can move the
world and so the same degree if you have
enough skills you can do anything right
and so skills give you leverage on your
time so you get more out of each unit of
time so if I'm a master cold caller I
will get more sales and calls books for
the same amount of time that somebody
who sucks at it same time more output
right because they developed a skill at
a masterful level 100 yeah and so when
people are allocating their time
um they're not by percentage they're
they're kind of like consuming their
time rather than investing their time so
they're either doing nothing
or they're consuming the time rather
than putting time into getting higher
Returns on their time which is education
right and so education you can have from
like the conceptual learnings watching
stuff like this
um or and or the actual doing right and
so you know you learn taking action 100
failing messing up you know feeling like
an embarrassment and reactions yeah the
first thousand uh cold calls you make
the first thousand cold emails you do
the first thousand doors you knock on
the first thousand you know what like
you'll learn more from that than you'll
learn from every single book you read up
to that point on the concept like you'll
learn right
um and so people don't allocate nearly
enough time to that in the beginning
deficits occur when we speak desires
right and so um I love this statement
um desire is a contract we make with
ourselves to be unhappy until we get
what we want and so whenever we State a
desire like I want this I want this
amount of money I want whatever you
literally sign a contract that says like
I won't be unhappy until that happens
right and so like I had this thing
earlier on where I was like I want to
have meaning I want to have great
meeting in my life and I was talking to
a guy who made a lot more money than me
because I asked him I said how do you
create and Destroy meeting in your work
that was the question I asked him on a
podcast and he was like why do you think
life needs to be meaningful and it was
the same exact thing as the happiness
versus like the meaning thing where it's
like I say life has to be meaningful and
therefore everything that I'm doing like
I create this expectation of Life
whereas if life just is it just is and
it's the only way that you can actually
be there
um it's just it's just pure acceptance
right which is why like the whole like
shoulds of like we should work we should
have balance we should X it's like I
believe marriage is a compromise like
these are just statements of belief that
are casting expectations out in the
world that are just bound to be untrue
at some point and then create dissonance
and so it's like I believe marriage is
marriage and I believe my marriage is my
marriage and I believe your marriage is
your marriage and like I believe that I
can work 24 hours a day if I want to and
that is all period not and it's bad or
and it's good and there's no judgment on
it it just is and so like if I get you
know if I get dopamine secreted in my
brain when I start working cool like and
I will optimize for dopamine and if I
die I know that on a thousand
Generations nothing I do anyways is
going to matter so who cares like that's
like the the opening thing in my book is
like there are no rules like we live in
this like this like shoulds and have
to's and like like happiness everyone
talks about it and it's just like
everyone is unhappy because they say
they want to be happy rather than being
like accepting like happiness like I
just am
period and then like I don't need to
judge the am it just is as a quick you
know Pro tip for everybody if you've got
stuff that people ask you to do for them
because you're good at it maybe you're
good at Tech it's like can you help me
set up my like Wi-Fi and stuff you know
blah blah it's like that means you're
solving problems you can chart like what
people ask you to do as a favor is an
indication of the things you can charge
for later right so
I had all these people who are asking me
uh not all these I mean a handful of
people who had asked me for programs and
stuff and so what I did was during my
last year of Consulting I started
something called the free training
project and so the free training project
was I would charge 500 to a thousand
dollars but I would I wouldn't charge it
they had to donate that to the charity
their choice in exchange to work with me
right and so that way I wanted people to
Value it but they weren't paying me
directly so they'd get a write-off they
felt good I had a ton of Goodwill also
in the marketplace too because I was
like I'm doing all this stuff for
charity I got I got all these people
reaching out to me like this is so cool
blah blah blah right
and so after a year of doing that I had
probably I don't know 12 really good
tests of like great before and after
pictures that I had collected from my
clients and I told them that was part of
the deal I was like I'll like you have
to donate it I would like to do this for
real later but
um you have to let me use your
testimonial and they were like that's
fine so once I had that
um I had those first you know 10 12
customers who had who had great before
and after pictures
um I transitioned many of those
customers said hey I'm doing I'm going
to do this full-time now are you
comfortable paying the same amount
you're paying to charity except just
making a charity of Alex because Alex
can't eat either and so and that was
actually how I transitioned from
not-for-profit or donating everything
and I'd even set up the entity I just
told them to literally donate it and
send me the screenshot I didn't even do
anything like that
um and so I didn't have a website
all I had was an LLC and a PayPal
account so like for everybody's like I
don't know how to start a business I was
like you literally just need a bank
account and a way to process money that
is it like two things and you can Google
how to figure out if you can't figure it
out from Google entrepreneurship might
not be for you all right but you look
like think about there's 30 million
business in the United States 30 million
other people have figured this out
which means you can too so bank account
payment processing make the first 10
free or some sort of charitable thing so
that people like don't feel weird or you
don't feel weird about selling Etc after
you have it after providing this service
to people you can transition people from
free service to paid service and if they
don't want to start paying you then that
gives you insight as to either you suck
right or they suck which is also
possible too but either way
a certain percentage of those people
will continue to stay in pay and now you
have income now you can also ask those
people for referrals which is exactly
what I did so I think half that business
came in just for I got you know the
initial ones came in from friends and
family and me posting and so I was I'll
I'll close the loop on what I said
earlier a year later after I had the
testimonials I made a public post being
like hey I've got this thing now I made
a website which is that was my big
announcement I made a website I still
have the post I found it it's 2013. I
was like I made it I made a website and
uh I I am now open for business and so
if you would like you know training
stuff let me know
um this is what I'm doing now you know I
had some testimonials and go check out
the site whatever and so from there I
was able to get I think about 20 guys uh
who were willing to let me do just like
almost bodybuilding type stuff because I
was kind of like what I was powerless
back then and so
um I think I want to say I got 20 guys
at 200 bucks a month and so I was making
four thousand dollars a month
uh from those people and it took me four
hours every Saturday to do the
Fulfillment what was the Fulfillment I
would just I would just update their
training programs and and send them
nutrition uh like update their macros
s updated meal plans
um and then like you know new workouts
split for the week Etc
um and then I and everyone had my cell
phone and I would just text them the new
stuff and if they had any questions they
could hit me up like it was a very
simple business
um and so that's what I did it was just
one-on-one online and it only took me
four hours on Saturday morning and to
show you what kind of person I am I
hated it uh even though I loved Fitness
I hated having to do something the same
thing every day
um like on the delivery side so I ended
up having the genius idea of saying oh I
need to own a gym because then I'll be a
business owner I'm really just
self-employed right now
um and so that's what got me to start my
gym rather than probably doing the wiser
decision and saying okay this cost you
four hours a week and you're making four
grand a month maybe you should do this
for 40 hours a week so if you think
about us as kids right like how do you
how do you Orient yourself of the world
you get reinforced or punished at all at
all phases directly indirectly but you
get reinforced or punished and the
things that you get reinforced you do
more other things you get punished you
less up right like that's just how how
we how we learn Behavior how we learn to
function in society Right Touch the
thing ah it hurts it's that's we got
punished okay you know you uh your
parent tells you to sit down and be
quiet and eat
and you learn to sit down and shut up
and eat and then we wonder why adults
don't move because we're told to sit
when we're running around right we learn
at school sit down and be quiet 100 and
we and we wonder why uh we eat so much
when the reward for everything we did
when we were a kid was food right we
wonder these things so the reason
external validation is so hard at least
for me is because it's how I learned
everything is because external
validation gave you know gave me the the
directional guidance of what's good and
what's not and then as you get older
it's where am I going to get that
validation from and so I would say that
my external validation
um comes is still 100 there it just
comes from different sources so I'm more
selective on Whose validation I want so
how much external validation do you need
in order to
overcome this belief to go all in and do
it in half the time yeah no I think I I
just I need to be able to validate
myself and that's fundamentally I think
Epictetus said this he has this quote
it's so good but it's basically like
you need to be able to give you don't
need to swear to somebody else you
should be able to swell your swear to
yourself and bear witness to yourself
because your word should be good enough
so you need to eliminate external
validation right from you feeling good
enough probably yeah it's probably that
like obviously you need it's good to
have feedback in life so I think that's
why it's it's also difficult for some in
general because it's not eliminate or
have more of it's to what degree and
from home and about what and so then it
gets a little bit more complex but even
using those different lenses I think
it's it's good to unpack it for anyone
who's listening which is like okay
Layla said this so this is not mine
um but most times when we're afraid of
something
it's not actually like this amorphous
crowd that we're afraid of it's like one
or two people's opinion like it's your
dad or it's your whatever it is right
and you're worried about what they're
gonna think and they're not even
thinking about you but you think they're
thinking about it they're thinking about
their dad
whatever it is right and so she restated
this earlier on to Mike like when we
were together five years ago she was
like are you and she'd like me me name
the person it wasn't my dad it was
somebody else for this particular thing
she's like are you gonna let this guy
stop us from getting what we want wow
and it was like when I saw it it was
like looking in front of me I was like
she's like what if this guy hates you
and thinks you're terrible is that a
worthy enough reason to still keep going
and I was like yeah just like them let's
go first you develop the skills right at
a proficient level then you dive deep on
those skills so that you get better and
better at them and typically that comes
through consistent execution and
repetition which means that it takes the
character traits a focus and
determination and drive right and being
able to be consistent and not go like go
away and start looking at shiny objects
looking at shiny objects looking at a
new opportunity looking at this other
side hustle you want to do whatever it
is right because there's always new
things and what's crazy about this is
that the higher up you go the more
seductive the woman in the red dress
looks like and I'm saying that from a
matrix is my all-time favorite movie
um the woman in the red dress
I'm using this as a as a parable or
whatever visual for opportunity and when
you're starting out the woman in the red
dress always looks attractive and the
thing is is that the higher up you go
the more of a 10 she becomes now if
you're a girl then I don't know a guy in
a red suit whatever I don't know that
maybe that looks more like a pimp said
forget about that but whatever you know
George Clooney or whoever your person is
whatever you're my point is
um like I thought that I was having
discipline and saying no to a certain
level of opportunity when I was starting
my gyms right and I had to develop that
discipline and then we started and then
we started making a few million dollars
a year and I was like okay I need to
develop a new level this one because
there's more things that I want to do
that I have to not be able to do right
one of the biggest successful things I
did was not start the supplement company
until a year and a half after almost two
years after gym one started all right I
had planned starting the supplement
company at the same time as I started
gym launch original
three and a half four years ago like
they were at the same time I wanted to
do both and Layla the angel that she is
was like no that's stupid don't do that
and so she thankfully was like
you have to have you have to stay
focused and so because of that we were
going to have the explosive growth that
we did and then at the right time we
were able to bolt that on now
um big big big big picture I don't know
if I would have done it again I still
probably would have stayed even more
focused on gym launch if I could do it
all over again now we have it you know
we we write a check for six hundred
thousand dollars every single month to
our gym Lords uh in terms of commission
checks so that's real money that I get
to send back to the community and that's
very fulfilling for fulfilling for me
um and it solved the problem that I
always had on a hemogen so like there
are reasons that I did it
um and uh and so
like history will tell whether it was
the right call or not um I can never
live the life of what it would have been
if I hadn't done it
um but I think if I were going back in
time knowing what I know now I might not
have done it
um but you never know so I'm telling you
like I've I've made these mistakes you
know what I mean and the thing is is
that that level of opportunity looked
even more seducting or seducing or
whatever the word is
um when we had two years more of a
distribution base compared to when we
had at the beginning and so I wasn't
able to say no to her that opportunity
later on as I was in the beginning and
that was a deficiency in my skill set at
the time my character trait of staying
focused right and so
um like I'm saying all this if you're
looking at it in terms of in in
verticals the first step is filling the
holes and that's stacking all the skills
together so you can get the first dollar
to go over and that's just becoming
proficient not amazing just proficient
you don't have to be an expert at
running traffic you just need to be able
to actually know how to run an ad and
the thing is is that most proficient
skills only take like like not a lot of
time like you can Google how to do X and
if you consume for like two hours of
information you'll probably be
proficient most people just don't take
those two hours to do it because it's
uncomfortable and you're not good at it
right
so you consume the information and then
you try right and then you fail because
you're not good at it you learn and then
just use those first initial tries you
learn more in your first 20 sales than
you do in the first 20 hours of learning
about sales stuff right you first time
you actually step in the ring you learn
more about fighting than you do during
all the time that you're practicing
right because it's real right so you're
developing you're stacking your skills
and you're becoming proficient at it
Next Step you have to do repetition and
be being willing to get punched in the
face over and over and over again right
so that you can deepen those skills and
that's what amplifies the skills that
you have so that you can get to another
level
then as you get to another level then
your character traits need to be strong
so you can stay the course all right
like the biggest thing in the book uh by
Angela Duckworth called grit which is
really interesting
um is that the people who are most
successful in life just stick with it
like great is stick to itness is what it
is so it's How likely are you to abandon
a certain path to pursue another thing
right and the people in the beginning
have very low stick with itness
entrepreneurs shiny objects shiny object
shiny object they're jumping from
opportunity to opportunity and they
never give any of the opportunities a
chance to be successful so one of the
interesting things that maybe you can
think about in terms of a quote that you
can take with you is
you can be successful at anything you
want just not everything you want all
right that was a huge lesson for me all
right I had a I had a friend from high
school who reached out who had a
contracting business and a roofing
business and they were flipping houses
so it's three separate businesses and I
was like dude like like what do you want
help with he was like I don't know like
what do you think I should do and I was
like pick one he's like well we're
making money in all three of them and I
was like cool pick one each one of those
businesses can be a billion dollar
business you can be a billion dollar
roofing company you can be a billion
dollar flipping Homes company you can be
a billion dollar general contractor
there are examples of each of these
things right but you just can't be a
billion dollars in all of them and so
there's a fallacy that we tell ourselves
as entrepreneurs which is that if I do
more things I will make more money when
in fact I need to do fewer things to get
to where I want to go and the reason I
can tell you that it's the truth is
because you naturally think the other
way and that's what most people think
which is why most people aren't
successful right is they they can't
focus because there's too many things
it's just so easy to just add this one
thing and do this other thing and all of
a sudden you're you spread thin you're
not focused on amplifying the things
that you're doing to get better you're
not deepening the skills you're
spreading yourself thinner right and so
once you acquire the skill set once you
become proficient then you amplify the
skills that you have by deepening them
and in order to do for them you have to
have the character traits of sticking
with it being patient being focused
learning to say no and doing things over
and over again I've got employees that
make a million bucks a year plus so like
you can absolutely become filthy wealthy
and that's income right and so a lot of
businesses that are at 10 million
dollars a year the owner might only take
a million bucks in income depending on
you know margins Etc and so like
a lot of a lot of employees will wish
for they see Top Line as income which is
just a very employee mindset
um they're like oh if I make six figures
a year I'll make six figures a year it's
like Well if you really want to make six
figures you gotta probably make 500
Grand a year you know what I mean
revenue wise at least if you don't want
to have just bought yourself another job
right because so let's let's talk
through this transition so if you're an
employee when you make the switch you're
still an employee you're just employee
of a different business that you happen
to own and you are basically 100 of the
expenses and so the business itself
actually makes no money you as the sole
employee of that thing and the boss
um gets to call your own shots but you
were still the employee right so you're
wearing all the hats Etc
um and so it's relatively nuanced you
know I mean like if you had a six foot
consulting job and then you start
Consulting on the side for example
through your own LLC you have the same
job you just got rid of the person who
is giving you Direction and now you are
responsible right the thing that most
people have to do is they have to go get
money right you have to go make money
and the way you do that is you sell
stuff right and the way that you can
even begin the conversation to sell
stuff is that you have to have people
who interest in the thing which means
you have to make your products known and
we do that through advertising right and
there's five ways to advertise which I
just went over earlier
um and so it's like pick one of those
five ways
start doing it on a consistent basis
bring people in what do you sell them
that's what 100 million offers book is
for it's like this is how you figure out
what to sell and then you sell them the
thing and then after that you'll have
some delivery now usually if you have a
consistent method of advertising and
selling with a without what to sell from
the offer then you can start getting
people to help you uh on the level of
delivery you have which comes down to
Breaking the delivery into chunks rather
than holistically and saying how can I
specialize the labor because you trying
to say I just need somebody to do what I
do is silly right you need to figure out
how can somebody do how can I get how
can I get five people to do 20 of what
I'm doing and do it consistently right
and then you can increase your
advertising sales is a very high
leverage thing in the beginning if you
spend all day selling just you you would
have enough for five people to do work
I'm wondering from your first ten
thousand to then like and not just you
like maybe prescriptive advice now and
then let's add a zero each time so ten
thousand to a hundred thousand a million
like what's the mindset ship that I have
to go by adding a zero to my Revenue
every step a little way so I don't get
stuck
it's it's a really good question so when
you're adding zeros you're you're you're
adding an order of magnitude right so
it's a multiple you know of 10 that's
happening with each of those scenarios
and the only way you can really just add
an order of magnitude is not by doing 10
times more work but by adding leverage
right and so we have to have leverage
through the things that we do and so you
know in the beginning you transition
from being employed to being
self-employed right and so that's like
kind of the first transition and then
your your limit is going to be your time
and how much you can build per hour
right
um from there your your next level is
going to be building the core team which
is usually five you know five or so
people which will be representative of
departmental functions within a company
right you'll have some element of
promotion some element of selling some
element of customer service some element
of finance and things like like now and
then you are kind of managing in that
you're not really really leading yet
you're really just managing the people
below you and in that in that time
typically you are better at the job at
each of those roles than the people
beneath you because you cannot afford
people who will be better than you at
those roles from there adding another
level of Leverage you then add another
layer of management that goes and then
you really transition into being a
leader because you can't possibly like
each of those people now have five
people underneath of them right now
you're now you're at you know 25 or 30
people and most of the
um most of these stagnation points do
happen around trip links
um and that's usually because another
whole layer of infrastructure needs to
get built within a company
um and so that's where people don't know
what has to happen and so that's when
you go you know and what's your leader
you have to go into like kind of Step
into the Visionary role and you're
really hiring people who come with
batteries included Solutions already
having proven inside of them not I have
to go find some person teach them how to
manage a sales team teach them how to
recruit like no no like you're finding
somebody's already built a 30 person
sales team to help you build take your
take your five person to a 30 person
sales team right it's like you want to
find somebody's already run the Olympic
gold and then have them run it with you
rather than like Oh I'm a running coach
I've never run gold but I'll try and do
it with you and the thing is is that
when you're earlier on the reason it's
difficult is because you can't afford
some of those people yet and so that's
why early on you have to spend a
disproportionate amount of time learning
the skills right rather than
um
rather than hiring people who already
have those skills so in the beginning
you're learning and your ability to
learn is the bottleneck and later it's
your ability to recruit people who have
learned and so it's just like in
business where you can buy or you can
build like in terms of growing through
mergers and acquisition so this is
really going from top down at a at a
medium level you can buy or build Talent
you can buy Talent by paying premium
dollar for the best people or you can
build it and both of those are
strategies you can build a system for
for design for Designing and training
sales people that was something that we
were really good at and so we could take
people for less than top dollar and then
make them into top dollar sales people
right now
the the risk that you should have there
is that some people then start
recruiting your sales people because you
because you did the building for that
but it just depends on the strategy of
the business in terms of you know
overall and so
um in terms of going from 10K to uh 100K
a month to a million a month to 10
million a month each of those represents
orders of magnitude
um on Leverage that you can employ
within the business and I'll just finish
with one little thing I know just ran it
a little bit
um but the The Leverage uh and this is
from Naval robot this isn't me but I
remember the four C's he doesn't say
four C's I remember four C's because
otherwise I can't remember it but it's
like you've got you've got code you've
got content you've got collaboration
you've got Capital right and so
collaboration is the base of that
pyramid of just getting other people to
do stuff for you so you get time back by
having other people give you their time
and you pay them for it right the level
above that is capital you use other
people's money to fuel growth right and
if you know how to structure your
business properly you can also use your
customers money to fuel growth if you
prop if you if you monetize well in that
you can if you can set up your your
marketing and your sales system such
that you can make more money than it
costs you acquire customer and the next
customer within the first 30 days you
have a negative acquisition cost which
means you can use that money to then go
get more customers and you basically
have a limitless acquisition cycle now
you'll still have bottlenecks but
there'll be infrastructure bottlenecks
on the back end so there's always a
bottleneck but it no longer becomes
acquisition so you have collaboration
then you have capital and then the top
two are our content and code so you have
software to zero positive application
which gives you Limitless leverage and
at the same degree like what you've done
uh with media right content uh it
doesn't cost more money for more people
to see this like if you and I were on
here with just one person or you and I
are under with a million people it costs
the same amount for us to do it but we
have libraries and so with most
businesses and this is like a fun rule
of thumb for anybody who's looking
when you look at the biggest businesses
that have been around the longest they
typically will have all four of those
aspects
um of Leverage built within the business
like you look at Facebook they have they
have lots of people they have capital
from the outside they sell media based
on code right
um and so as you're looking to scale the
company it's like how many boxes of
these leverage can I check and I would
even look at my own life and I'd say
right now we have three of the four like
I don't have a big software component
within my business but we do have media
we do have a collaboration we do have
capital and so I think that for us and I
made a presentation about this like I
think for us going from 10 million a
month to maybe 100 million a month I'll
probably have to figure out some sort of
code thing uh but you know at current uh
we're able to you know still do 10
million a month with the stuff that
we're doing if you're like I really want
to make money but you don't really like
business I think it's like I started in
Fitness and then I realized I had a
deeper passion for business like I liked
it more than I liked Fitness and I was
obsessed with Fitness for a long time
but like when I like the day I started
my gym was the day fitness became number
two and then business became my first
love
um and I'm still you know in my love
affair you know with business my
long-term relationship with business and
it's because like like the only way
you're gonna be
everybody else is is to truly love it
and if you don't I think it's very
difficult to do that and I think it's
just like maybe picking another metric
or a different bone to gnaw on so like a
lot of marketers will talk about how
their products are amazing right like
how many times have you heard people
like no no no our course is also our
program's awesome or whatever right they
say that but the thing is is like and
I've I've done this at like a couple of
like workshops I've been invited to and
I'm like all right who here knows what
their you know their CPM their CTR their
you know their their CPL like their set
percentage their close rate their CPA
their CAC like who who knows all those
numbers everyone's like oh yeah uh uh
100 I'm like cool I'm like what's your
what's your TTV what's your CHS what's
your NPS what's your turn with your
activation points or CRC and they're
like what I'm like right so how can you
say you have a good product and you
don't even know what the metrics are to
track good product when people
understand the game when you understand
that I can never take a drink so thirst
quenching that I'll never need another
drink again there's no meal
so amazing that you'll never be hungry
again there's no sex so good that you'll
never want sex again it just that's just
the way the human animal is wired like
when people are at peace with that yeah
like then now you've really got a shot
at loving your life understanding the
cycles and that you're gonna keep doing
the climb and so you better love the
climb
I love the uh
the that moment before the moment
because I was like I was I was thinking
as you were saying I was thinking back
to like the few of those moments that
I've had like the first time you know
you start running ads and like you start
getting your first leads you're like
it's working yeah like it's that you
know I mean that moment or the first I
remember uh when I got uh I hired my
first sales person and they closed the
sale and I wasn't there so as the first
person that had made me money who wasn't
me yeah and I was like I pulled over the
side of the road and I teared up because
I was like
it doesn't have to just be me anymore
yeah you know what I mean it's like I
was just thinking about all these these
moments that I've had
um I remember when we were Layla and I
were sitting over the kitchen counter
and we had just switched from uh flying
out a sales team in person to do these
turnarounds uh to switching the
licensing and
um I got on the phone to tell the guys
who I was gonna launch the next month
that we weren't gonna do that anymore
we're thinking about switching
directions and so I said hey you know
what I can't do it but I'll I'll tell
you how I do it but I'm not flying out
there anymore and they were like oh
that's fine how much and I didn't want
to do it so I picked a super high number
and then uh which was six thousand
dollars at the time and uh the guy said
yes and I was like and I remember that
moment being like holy what just
happened and I had seven more calls a
day and like that day I made like sixty
thousand dollars and I had just been un
like the story I was talking Let's Go
full circle like I just been completely
broken like in that moment like Jim
launch hadn't been created yet there
wasn't you know all these other things
but in that moment I was like what if
this keeps happening like are we out of
it like did or like did we finally is
this the one thing that's finally gonna
get me out of like failure after failure
after failure after failure and so it's
just like uh what is the what is the
event that gives you the biggest
predictor of the future success so like
there's micro wins of like hey the
funnel's working I've got leads and then
you have like a day of huge sales like
what if this happened every day and then
maybe you exit Quest you're like what if
I exit five more times you know I mean
like so anyways I was just that was
really cool for me just even thinking
through like those those those snapshots
of moments
the desire for legacy is the desire to
cheat death like that's what it's like
we don't want to die we want to last
forever so we want to make something
that is impermanent and so we fool
ourselves into thinking that the
accolades and the material success and
the books we write whatever are going to
last forever and they're probably not
right and so like I mean the sun's gonna
disappear at some point right like if we
don't do anything before then like at
the very least that's gonna happen and
so if that is the inevitable outcome I
think it shifts the way people think and
I think that's when you start changing I
mean Tony Robbins talks about like
global global belief systems and that's
why if someone like adopts new religious
belief like everything changes because
the reasons they do and the way they
believe the world Works changes and so I
think that if they did do a 100 death
tax it would be a really interesting way
to see the downstream effects of how it
would change the way the players played
the game what do you think would happen
if all the billionaires started
Distributing their wealth sooner I think
would they be as hungry to be and driven
to push and build and innovate yes to
generate the wealth if they knew I got
to give this away anyways quickly I
think they would well I think it's
because it's I think it's I think I'm
going to say something that might sound
bad but
um I think winners win
because of who they are and so I think
it's like sales guys like you can have
an incentive or a comp plan they just
want to win but they are sales people
and if I get on the phone I want to sell
because of who I am not because the comp
the cop is the ticket to get me to say
yes to the deal but it will not change
my activity I will do it because I love
to sell right and so I think
billionaires get there because they love
the game like you don't get to a billion
without just because you obviously don't
need it for you you stop needing it for
you millions and millions ago right and
so you do it just because you love the
game what I do think of the reason that
I I like that solution is because
uh Elon Musk said this but uh private
Enterprise is 10 times as efficient at
Capital allocation compared to the
government right so every dollar that
private private Enterprise spends it's
10 times more efficient and so it is
like if if we were to death tax 100 so
whatever you accumulate while you're
alive it just goes back like and the
thing is it's not that it would go back
into the system through the government
it would if you were lazy
but most people knowing the government
was going to take it the less efficient
vehicle at the end of your life you
would then start thinking about how can
I allocate this money efficiently and so
what I think what would happen is you'd
create far more Ingenuity and Innovation
around social Enterprise
before they die solving problems knowing
that the wealth would eventually
disappear so like it's more there's this
backstop that no one wants to hit and so
I think what happened is they would
change their behavior before hitting the
backside I don't think a lot of people
just be dumping their bill into the
government I think just knowing that
they had to would then just trigger them
to yeah yeah that would be you know hey
that's Alex's two cents of the world
which is obviously different a keystone
habit that has served me very well and
it's only been in retrospect explaining
it to someone else that I kind of had
more clarity on it which is why I'm
sharing it with you when I have
something that I want that I do not have
so I have a desire which means I've made
a contract with myself to be unhappy
until I get what I want right and so I
have this thing that I want externally
and I think I've had enough experience
with this to know that simply writing
down the goal means nothing and so I
think this is contrary to Common belief
or practice which is like people write
down their goals are more likely to
succeed sure I mean having a direction
is more likely to achieve than not
having a Direction so I'm not going to
disagree with that but here's an
interesting statement that um may hit
you which is that winners and losers
have the same goals right everybody in
Olympics has the same goal everybody
who's in business has the same goal
right they want to increase how much
money they're making you sell more
products get more customers Etc so the
goals are actually not that unique and
so the fact that we're writing them down
sure it's a first step because we have
to have a direction in terms of what are
we trying to accomplish sure but I think
that what you'll see that is different
because if you look at two people with
the same goals and one person achieves
them the other person hasn't then it
can't be having the goal that is the
main driver of success right right and
so then you get you know you dive a step
underneath that and you look at what are
the behaviors that created that goal and
now we get much closer to the things
that are actually driving the progress
what gets more interesting at least to
me is if we know the activities that are
going to generate the result we want so
maybe it's we want to get more customers
which means we need need to advertise
more and I use advertise by the
definition of what the word actually
means which is to make note and so if we
do activities that make our products and
services known like doing more private
Communications which would be one-on-one
reach outs one-on-one cold calls 101 DMS
101 emails Etc prospecting or one to
many so Public Communication which would
be uh you know broadcasting across
different platforms for media right so
you have radio you could have an email
list you could have actually that would
be an example of a high version of scale
of the original so I apologize there but
like making posts on social media things
that are public forum where people can
find out about it right if you do more
of those things more people find out and
that would be the activity that's
associated with getting more customers
right but the thing is is that people
will know what that activity is right
they will know that inherently they
should be doing more of it and yet they
don't most important lessons that I've
learned in my life have come from doing
and mentors
and so on a day-to-day basis it's
reducing the time between when you wake
up and when you begin working right A
lot of people lollygag and delay and
procrastinating things like that and if
you just think about there's only a
certain amount of time in the day I want
to increase my output per unit of time
as much as possible a lot of people have
these superstitions that they have to do
a certain thing they must do X Y and Z
but all you have to do is talk to a
single mom who has like five kids and no
still start businesses they're not doing
any of that stuff they're waking up and
they're working before their kids are up
and then once their kids go to bed they
work then too right and they're not
doing all the lollygag stuff that you
know you see trending all over social
media it's like they're working and so
like the single greatest skill in my
opinion is being able to find a place
that you can shut out external stimuli
and you can focus yes the single highest
Roi habit that I have is that for me
between 5am and noon I have nothing on
my calendar it is just work no meetings
and then all my meetings happen after
noon is this for the Entre now if you're
if you're like in a job right now then
it's got to be in the morning before you
go to work and in the evening after you
come back from work but like having that
dedicated time and if you're like well
I'm not a morning person fine then just
work late like that's okay like I've
I've got billionaire buddies who are
like oh I wake up at 10. but they work
really late that's their that's their
special time that no one bothers them it
tends to be at the book ends of the day
though just from my experience because
in the middle of the day you get
pestered and it's hard to get into that
deep focus that really that deep
learning that you get when you really
pour yourself into something because you
made it this far starting a video I want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
one-on-one with Alex check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there you will attract much better
Talent having a better opportunity
vehicle overall the best people are
attracted to the best opportunities I
mean we're big fans of imperfect action
you learn through doing not through
preparing to do because I think a lot of
times you